okay good morning everyone and welcome
to the February 3rd
meeting of the science technology and
energy Committee in the state where the
wind chill atop Mount Washington is
expected to go below 100 degrees below
zero sometime in the next 24 to 36 hours
as usual we'll begin our meeting this
morning by rising and joining
representative munz as he leads us in
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
foreign
I apologize that the calendar listed
this morning's presentation as being by
public utilities somehow the word
commission got omitted but the
presentation this morning will actually
be by the Public Utilities Commission
and they will be here for a couple of
hours but they have a hard stop at 11
o'clock
so we're looking forward to hearing what
they have to say I'm sure the committee
members will have a few questions and
we'll allow those questions as we go
along but keep in mind that the
Commissioners must leave by no later
than 11 o'clock
so with that I'll welcome the
Commissioners from the Public Utilities
Commission and hand the microphone over
to
chairman Dan goldner welcome
thank you representative
um
I'd like to
um to just go briefly over the
presentation overview I'm I'm here I'm
Dan goldner the PEC chairman joined by
Commissioners Chota batai and Simpson to
my uh to my immediate right
I'll go through an intro and overview of
the Public Utilities Commission
commissioner choto patai will go over a
rate setting and fostering competition
and then commissioner Simpson will go
over protection of consumers and
interacting with regional regulators
so before we kick off I thought we would
just sort of briefly introduce ourselves
and give you a little bit of our
background
I spent uh I'm a mechanical engineer by
training I spent my first six years
at Texas Instruments doing mechanical
design work mostly in the thermal realm
I then went back and got an MBA
spent the next 12 years or so in finance
and operations
moving all around the country living in
California lived in Texas different
places
eventually went to Norway Oslo Norway
for three years where it's not as cold
as Mount Washington but it's pretty cold
yes
is that right it was Dallas Houston and
is that right is that right so always a
little West and North
so that was um so did that and then uh
repatriated here to Manchester in 2010
where I ran our research and development
operations on the west coast for Texas
Instruments for those last 10 years or
so so that I'm happily married and my
wife Elisa and I have three kids one is
working down at Boston Children's and
the other two are still in college so
I'll turn it over to commissioner
chettapattai for uh for an introduction
foreign
good morning everyone it's a pleasure to
be here
am originally from India but I came here
in 1991
more like the last couple of days in
1990 really and then did my PhD in
economics and that ultimately I did it
from the University of Washington
Seattle
um I went back to India worked as in a
consultancy firm there I then moved on
to uh
it's the uh at that point uh probably
true even now but at that point the
biggest state electricity Regulatory
Commission there so I joined that as an
economist and um then came back to the
U.S at uh nrri briefly at OSU
and then joined the world bank and then
eventually made it to New Hampshire so
I've been here since I've been here for
21 years now
and um
I was with the POC
um erstwhile POC and it also was at
assistant consumer Advocate at one point
um and I've worked in a couple of I've
also worked for the Minnesota AG
I worked at Liberty Utilities for a
while and I was a consultant so so I
have a background in
economics and energy I also teach
currently sometimes so that's my
background and as far as my family is
concerned I am happily married too and
um my wife is a toxicologist for the
state she has she has a PHD in chemistry
so she works for the DHHS
um my daughter is 15 years old so she's
going to high school and um and I have a
boy as well it's a dog
and he's so that's my you know
out of my professional life that's
good morning members of the committee my
name is Carlton Simpson
commissioner at the puc I'm a lifelong
resident of New Hampshire I grew up in
Hampton uh lived in a house that my
great grandfather built a lot of family
history in the town
I went to school there went to high
school at Phillips Exeter Academy
college at UNH I got a degree in
electrical engineering I then went to
graduate school at WPI got a master's in
electric and computer engineering with a
focus in power systems engineering
after graduate school I worked at Unitil
started as an engineer there started
doing regulatory work eventually went to
law school at night at Suffolk
University in Boston got a JD with a
focus in energy and environmental law
became unitil's director of government
Affairs in that capacity I presented
before this committee for a couple of
years I see some faces that I recognize
but a few new faces as well so it's nice
to see you all and meet the new folks
that are here since that time you've
gotten a bigger room which is nice about
twice the size so that's excellent
then I joined the commission just over a
year ago
um I'm also married my wife and I have
11 month old twins a boy and a girl so
we're very busy with that and uh just
looking forward to speaking with you all
today and going through the presentation
with respect to the commission and
answering any questions that you all
I'm sorry
all right
um thank you and good morning again the
first thing I'd like to go through with
for the hard copies this is Page Three
is is the public utilities commissioned
as it's currently constituted
and this is every single person in the
organization so we're very small and and
tight organization there's the three
Commissioners that you see before you we
have an administrative assistant we have
two attorneys two clerks a management
analyst the reception is for the
building reports into the PC a couple of
part-time analysts and then five senior
advisors who have a mixed skill set
between a legal skill set and Technical
skill set mostly economics
so that's that's the PEC in front of you
and um when people use the word new puc
what they what they mean is that the
Public Utilities Commission was split
from the Department of energy July 1st
2021 by by this legislature
um really focusing in the puc in a
couple of areas one is conducting
adjudicative proceedings across
different regulatory issues but
primarily rate setting financing and
asset transfers and mostly electric gas
and water utilities though we do have a
couple of other areas that we that we
adjudicate which I'll go over here
momentarily
and we also have critical
non-edjudicative functions such as our
investigative Authority rulemaking and
declaratory rulings an example of the
rulemaking would be our 2200 rules which
which govern Community aggregation just
as an example of what those rule makings
so turning to uh page five don't forget
to advance your slides sorry I didn't
Advance the slides there's the slide I
was just going over my apologies
and uh and this is a slide that talks
about what the old PC looks like looked
like in the new puc looks like and I
think this is hopefully a helpful
juxtaposition of the two
in the old commission there were nine
divisions there were more than 70 people
there was an executive director there
was a general counsel nine division
directors
and a staff that reported through the
the staff oversaw oversaw policy
Administration and it also offered
positions to the Commissioners in
adjudications which was something that
the legislature and um and I think
perhaps the governor were concerned
about and was was one of the reasons for
the split and in this new Commission on
the right side of the chart here you'll
see that three Commissioners the 12
full-time people in addition there were
there were the two part-time folks that
you saw on the chart
um everyone now reports directly to the
chairman and so that's uh that's for you
know I think communication is
streamlined um everyone can easily
communicate with each other there's not
a layer of management uh in between uh
all the folks working at the commission
in the doe who I know you heard from a
couple of weeks ago is known independent
and statutory party to all the
proceedings they provide the commission
with independent information on the
record that helps us render uh reason to
sound in in Fair decisions
foreign
so the next slide page six is an
illustration hard to see on the screen
probably but perhaps easier with the
hard copies that just shows
um
the utilities that we regulate so on the
colorful chart on the upper left those
are the electric utilities dark blue is
eversource light blue is Unitil yellow
is Liberty
and on the bottom you can see how those
split in terms of customers so most of
our electric customers in the state are
eversource customers there's over half a
million ever Source customers in the
state and they're over 80 percent of the
state's electric customers
um underneath that you have a Unitil and
Liberty
that have 13 and seven percent of the
state's customers respectively
on the color chart uh next to the
electric chart so immediately to the
right you can see on that chart the
yellow which is liberty and the dark
blue which is Unitil
Liberty has about a hundred thousand
customers in the state and Unitil has
about 35 000 customers so that's like a
three-quarter one quarter split yes sir
we have a question from representative
Thomas well thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question I'm just
curious uh
does the puc have any
um Authority in how these areas were a
lot allotted to the very utilities and
if so uh very briefly can you explain
why they're so fragmented
commissioner Simpson would you like to
take that one
so the puc has has franchise Authority
and utility franchises are authorized by
municipality
um historically if we go back to the
turn of the century 20th century
the original utilities were primarily
Gas Utilities in the country and they
manufactured natural gas for lighting
and then those street lights were built
out through municipalities and then
similar with electric power as electric
power generation became more widely
available there were small scale
generators that then built Distribution
Systems off of those power generators to
serve local areas so there was this
fragmentation of of companies and it was
really at a more local level like for
instance one of our utilities in the
state is Unitil and one of the
predecessor companies was Concord
Electric company so there was a utility
for Concord
similarly in Hampton and Exeter Exeter
and Hampton electric company there was a
generation facility that built out built
a distribution Network and served the
local area and the puc is the entity
that authorizes utilities to
operate within municipalities today all
municipalities are franchised for
electric service but on water natural
gas side sewer there are opportunities
for new utilities to come about I think
another piece that's important to
recognize is a lot of consolidation
that's happened over the years the
fragmentation is the merger of multiple
companies over the years so Unitil is
what was Concord Electric and extra in
Hampton they have two discrete systems
across the state but it's one utility
today that serves both of those areas
does that answer your question yes thank
thank you
before you continue representative
Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman so I noticed a few
areas up in the northern part of the
state in white they have no electric
those are municipally served so there
are individuals
um some Municipal Utilities that serve
those areas and they're not regulated by
the um utility company that our chairman
has is not on here because they're
independent is that correct is that
the co-op so the New Hampshire Electric
Co-op is not on the table in terms of
customers the commission has uh
significantly more limited regulatory
authority over the New Hampshire
Electric Cooperative we do not rate
regulate The Cooperative
um there are programs and areas with
which we have regulatory Authority but
our core Focus as the commission of as
an economic rate regulator we do not
approve and regulate the rates that the
Cooperative charges to their customers
and that's why they're not reflected on
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I notice uh that
several towns are served by multiple
providers
um you know I I'm looking at Hanover and
I see that it's got Liberty and New
Hampshire Electric Co-op for example and
but many towns like that so if the
franchises are done municipally how does
that happen so I think that's a a again
a legacy of the way that the systems
were built out that the systems built
out organically over time to serve
customers and within municipalities you
may see that there are multiple
utilities and that's because multiple
utilities built out over time and as new
homes and properties are developed it
may be more economic for
a utility that perhaps doesn't serve
that Community but is closer to that
property than the incumbent within the
municipality and there are agreements
that sometimes come before us to enable
a utility to serve a customer that's
outside of their franchise but would be
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you thank
you for coming in
um
your your staff has decreased quite a
bit and and I realized that it that is
probably in lot well it's large part due
to the restructuring of the relationship
between the puc and the DOE but can you
comment on on whether 12 people plus the
three of you is enough to fulfill you
know what's still a pretty significantly
large portfolio of responsibilities
yeah thank you for asking I think we're
very cognizant of the fact that we're
we're spending rate payer money we're
spending you know eventually taxpayer
money and so we want to be you know
right size so that we're uh we're we're
doing the job with uh with the minimum
amount of resources and based on what
we're doing today we believe we are
um we do have sufficient resources to
cover everything today I could go over
some statistics if it wouldn't be too
boring in terms of the output of the
commission and what we've been able to
do with the current level of resources
we do have an open uh um an open
requisition for an additional
additional senior advisor so there is
one open position
uh but but the short answer to your
question hopefully is that we believe
we're right-sized for today's scope now
if the legislature were to add
responsibilities to the puc then then
that would be something that we would
need to look at depending on the scope
of those activities a follow-up yes
follow up
um
one of the responsibilities that you s
that you um say that you you have is you
know that you have investigative
Authority who who does the
investigations
um from the 12 people that you have on
staff
so that's uh that's a commission
activity so it's not uh it's not a
single person or persons that's the
Commissioners that's the staff uh
whoever is assigned to that particular
investigation
and uh just as a follow-up to his
question if you became the site
evaluation committee would you have
sufficient staff provided there was
maybe some additional Staffing in the
legislation to do that take on that
responsibility we would need additional
resources to handle the SEC activity as
currently constituted in the legislation
that I've seen
representative partial has a question
would like to thus get clarity on this
one thing that you said
um thank you for coming today by the way
of course utility franchises crossover
medicinal borders at times for the sake
of so one municipality may be served by
representative Noel has a question
thank you Mr chairman
my background was in the railroads and I
noticed you don't have any reference to
the railroads anymore it has has your
regulatory Authority uh lapsed in
regards to the railroads
I think the answer to that is yes in
fact there's legislation proposed by
representative Vose that cleans up some
of the statutes and um and particularly
with respect to the railroads it moves
it moves it to the appropriate Place
mostly the Department of Transportation
okay now I guess we can move on
I haven't even finished the slide yet so
that's that's exciting it must have been
a good slide I appreciate the questions
um just to continue after the to the
right of the plus sign on the um
on the on the table is there are the
water utilities in the upper right
there's about a dozen water utilities
that we regulate primarily pennichuck
which is based out of Nashua and uh
Aquarian is the second biggest so I
think um panacek has about 35 000
customers uh Aquarian has about ten
thousand
so that's the scope of the water
utilities the sewer utilities are very
small and there's only about a half
dozen of them all of all of which are
less than a thousand customers and then
finally we have some Authority
regulatory Authority in the Telecom
space for us it mostly takes the form of
poll transfers at this at this point in
time
so before I move on to the next slide
I'll just just pause a minute to see if
don't say any move along all right thank
you thank you so just uh moving back up
to 10 000 feet
I'll highlight our mission statement and
it's to ensure that customers of the
utilities that we regulate receive safe
adequate and reliable service at just in
reasonable rates I'll also Point your
attention to line four on the mission
statement which is
to provide a thorough but efficient
regulatory process that is fair open and
Innovative and when I think about this
line I think about a trip to Frankfurt
you know about 10 years ago and the line
at the airport in front of the metal
detectors was about half a mile long
literally half a mile long
almost everybody missed their flight
flights were taking off with 10 or 12
people on those flights and when I got
up to the front of the line we all got
up to the front of the line we saw a
gentleman going through everyone's bags
very very thoroughly he was turning over
every shirt every she looking inside
every shoe each bag took about five or
six minutes for him to go through and
everyone was missing their flight so we
don't want people to miss their flight
at the puc we want to be thorough but we
also want to be efficient so we're
processing dockets in an efficient
manner so we don't want to be like the
guy at the Frankfurt Airport
um we also
um want to Foster competition where
appropriate provide necessary uh
customer protection and of course
perform our responsibilities ethically
so
um you know the best way of saying that
I think is to look at RSA 36317a which
is the commission as arbiter
so it's our job to see that the
commission balances the interests of the
customer
and the interests of the regular
regulated utilities and uh we need to
keep the utilities have to stay in
business they have to have shareholders
they have to be able to afford the
investment that's that's critical
without invested
um utilities uh that we would we
wouldn't have Services here in New
Hampshire and that's and that's critical
and at the same time we want to make
sure that the customer the interest of
the customer are being taken care of and
mostly that's in the form of cost but
there are also different attributes to
making sure that the the customer is
attended to representative oh I'm sorry
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I have to ask this
question only because uh from comments
I've seen on Facebook uh and I'm sure
lack of understanding of what the puc
can do
what would you say to people that are
saying that with these
spiking rate hikes which are devastating
to most of our constituents
why why can't the puc just tell utility
I'm sorry that rate is too high for our
consumers uh we just can't let you go
that high with that rate even though
you've provided us with documentation we
feel it's it's it's going to hurt our
customers and our constituents and this
we we just can't allow that
why can't you do that that is for the
benefit of people that say you should
have oh no thank you for that question I
think that uh first of all we have an
investigative docket open right now
um to the to the point of Representative
Munds that is um that we're looking at
how we can do what we call default
service which is the rate you're talking
about for electricity or cost of gas
which is the rate for gas
and looking at ways in which we can run
that process better we can improve the
process to hopefully get lower rates for
consumers inside of our current process
inside of the current rules and statutes
what happens is that the utility comes
before us
they have a process where they go to the
market and they try to secure the best
rate that they can inside the the
wholesale and Retail markets and um and
and get that lowest rate for consumers
so there is a process in place today to
um to get the lowest possible rate so
far as we know but an investigative duck
it can can explore different options for
example other states use laddering
schemes where um basically your dollar
cost averaging As you move on the way up
and on the way down in terms of utility
prices so that Smooths things out some
other states are going directly to the
day ahead market and so they're they're
taking some uh potentially some risk out
of the
um out of the equation so the risk
premium I should say out of the equation
so different options that that we're
looking at and evaluating and that that
docket is ongoing and we expect to think
the next hearing on that is later this
month
follow up thank you Mr thank you for the
follow-up can you please define ongoing
because our people are hurting with your
rates and if anything can be done sooner
than later
yeah I think there's there's two things
going on here one is that we have rates
that have already been set uh for six
month periods because we because
consumers and I'm talking about the
electric Market consumers also
um are very interested in stable pricing
so so those prices are set and and
stable the process improvements are are
longer term though we don't intend on
this investigative docket lasting years
we intend on it lasting months so we are
motivated to resolve it as quickly as
possible
representative closure has a question
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
um following up on representative
Thomas's question uh I really have two
questions one is what incentive do the
utilities have to keep the default
service cost low and how often is it
that the puc does say to a utility no
so um
I'm sorry can you give me your first
question again I lost track your first
and your second what's the incentive
that the utilities have to keep the
default service cost low I think they
you know they're in the business of
servicing customers and that those
customers are unhappy with utilities
when utility rates go up they they take
the heat for that and so I think
utilities are generally speaking
motivated to get the lowest possible
rate it's to keep their phone from
ringing and keep their customers from
commissioner Simpson would like to add
to that I have some slides
coming up that discuss the regulatory
framework that exists within New
Hampshire and there are differences on
both electric and the gas side with
respect to the supply portion of what
customers pay for a bill
fundamentally on the electric side New
Hampshire is a restructured state
meaning that our incumbent regulated
utilities do not own and operate power
generation resources
so
they purchase energy within the New
England Market through the New England
power pool and I saw New England
participants
um it's I think a similar analogy is
that when you go to the gas pump you
don't have an opportunity to
lower or raise that price it's based on
on what the market price is and the
utilities are purchasing electricity
they're purchasing gas in in the market
and they do not Mark those costs up
there's no profit that's made there
so it's ultimately
procured by the utility and then
passed through to cust retail customers
directly and then with respect to the
question on what motivates the utilities
why would they be motivated to not
charge those rates
um I would say that utilities are
overall price sensitive and they they do
not like to see
a price shocks and instability in those
markets because they recognize that
their customers that they serve are
going to be negatively impacted by that
it's bad business for them it's it's a
bad customer relationship that they
build with their uh with the customers
and with the utility
in the second part of my question please
about how how often you deny a rate I I
personally don't I can't think of any
time when a rate has been uh a default
service procurement rate has been denied
by the commission I've only been on the
commission for just over a year so it
might have happened in the past but it's
uh it's something we could look into if
you'd like us to follow up on that
question we're happy to do that
uh representative munz has a question
too
thank you Mr chair
um
the utilities are also publicly traded
companies and they have responsibilities
to their shareholders I just want to
confirm that there is no profit margin
on the default service rate it's just a
pure pass-through of what their purchase
what they're purchasing in terms of
to develop the rfps to solicit that to
perform the mechanics of of that that's
included in the cost that they can
recover
but there's no incentive there's no uh
earnings on top of that for the
utilities for default service
follow-up
yeah I I I want to add another aspect to
this
um the the rates that the utilities ask
us to
um bless they we do look at whether
those rates are competitive or not now
that itself is not a very easy process
but
if we if if there is a threshold there
and we kind of conclude that the rates
aren't competitive then we can we can
decide that that default rate is not you
know acceptable
representative munz has a follow-up so
thank you for clarifying that on the
administrative cost so I'm assuming that
that's something that you're looking at
routinely to make sure that those levels
are appropriate
yes absolutely and I think to build off
of what commissioner goldner had noted
with respect to the ongoing
investigation what we're trying to do is
is evaluate the process that exists
today that's largely been in place for
20 years since restructuring around 2000
2001 when the utilities in New Hampshire
either owned their own power plants or
contracted directly for power and
long-term contracts now they issue a
six-month solicitation
to procure the amount of energy that
they need in order to serve their
customers and that happens every six
months they go out into the market they
issue an RFP to uh to power generator
companies or or entities that buy Power
in the market and serve the utilities
the utilities do that competitively and
then they procure energy through those
rfps
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh with the
transmission rates being so high and
part of it and with the utilities that
can actually control the transmission
can the transmission costs be divested
or spread amongst years to bring that
um
the the transmission rates are again
um part of the the folk responsibility
so ultimately it's the iso New England
that
um is running the transmission grid and
so those costs are again
bypass so I'm not 100 sure whether
um if you're asking you know whether we
can do something about sort of breaking
up those companies but they are under
the responsibility of the you know the
folk jurisdiction
um it's possible that a particular
transmission utility company may be also
the one that owns distribution
yeah you know utilities here
but I think
that's a very good question but I really
need to think through whether that can
be even done uh asking transmission
companies to be divested uh separately
um I would add that
ISO New England has a responsibility
under the federal power act for
transmission
planning so they develop the forecast on
what's needed for transmission
infrastructure and then the the
transmission utilities they're regulated
by the Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission because today
transmission is in interstate commerce
it hap it occurs over state lines so
it's outside of the regulatory authority
of the states or our commission it's
regulated by the Federal Energy
Commission
representative Noel has a question thank
you Mr chairman uh just a point of
clarification when you're talking about
the utilities you're talking about the
transmission companies
I I'm using that word generally speaking
there are distribution utilities that we
regulate and there are transmission
utilities that are generally speaking
regulated by the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission
follow-up follow-up
thank you
does anybody address the issue or
regulation with the generators the ones
who actually provide the power to the
distribution companies or utilities so
States retain regulation over power
generation it the the when we talk about
regulation it primarily is citing that
when you are looking to develop a power
generation resource it there's a citing
process to to get that facility a permit
so they can be constructed and operate
safely
so that is regulated by the site
evaluation committee the three of us are
members of the site evaluation Committee
in addition to six other members some of
whom are state employees like the
Department of Transportation
commissioner but we also have public
members so in New Hampshire the SEC
oversees the the certificates that
develop uh
or that would be provided to power
in terms of
directing or or identifying when there
are needs of power generation that is uh
primarily handled by ISO New England
because they're operating the regional
on questions about rate setting because
commissioner Simpson is going to talk
about that later in the presentation I
believe
yeah I I will be but oh okay sorry I
thank you just uh wrapping up my portion
of the presentation just two more slides
and then I'll turn it over to
commissioner Chota batai who will then
turn it over to commissioner Simpson I'd
just to briefly go over the commission
uh code of ethics so
um the Commissioners and staff can can
generally speak writer lecture
concerning the regulatory process
in New Hampshire for example this this
session today but at the same time there
are strict prohibitions on ex parte
Communications in cases pending before
us neither the Commissioners nor the
staff of the commission can publicly
comment about a matter pending before
the commission so that that sometimes
comes into play when we're we're talking
to folks
okay so my final slide is just relative
to communication
um our
um our webpage is uh I think it's an
excellent reviews however we're also
moving over to sort of the state format
so the format you'll see out there today
for another couple of months is the um
is the existing format that's been in
place for many years I think folks
generally like it it's pretty easy to
find things and and locate what you need
to out there
and again in a couple of months we'll
we'll uh we'll be on the new website
um and uh you know our encouragement
would be to go out there and poke around
and look at look at the dockets and
there's a lot of useful information out
there and it's really part of our work
to provide a transparent process for the
for the Public Utilities Commission so
with that I'll turn over to commissioner
for his section I can just flip the
slides
so I think it's slide 13 Maybe
12.
um
so I I will keep this pretty high level
as you would imagine rate setting is a
fairly complicated process
um so the first thing I will note is
that the the biggest chunk of rate
making happens
with respect to distribution rates so
when a Distribution Company files a rate
case it requests rates particular rates
and there is this adjudicative process
which ends up being which ends up
resulting in the commission ultimately
recommending or or you know
approving rates so that's the process so
this this slide just tries to get into
at a high level what it is the
distribution rates
um really try to capture essentially
there's the concept of Revenue
requirement that a company needs and I'm
talking about a Distribution Company
um that is the the operating and
maintenance expenses it's uh
depreciation and amortization all of
that
they also have to pay taxes
and an important piece is really what
return they will get on the rate base
meaning the the and I'm going to use a
very
without being
precise about it the plans and capital
that they put into place
that helps them provide electricity
service a distribution service that you
can call that the rate base and they get
a return on it so it's like any other if
you think about private companies they
they invest they expect that they're
going to get some profits and then
return on it so this is that return is
also adjudicated and a rate of return
rather and um it is applied on the rate
base to get them their earnings so to
speak so that's how the process is and
and and underneath that then you have
different billing determinants that are
used to figure out what exactly the
rates are going to be say for example
per kilowatt hour per customer things
like that
okay
please
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question again I have to ask
the question because of the chatter on
Facebook to people uh talking about rate
misunderstanding on the actual rate of
returns they they say utilities get 12
15 percent uh but in in relation to that
comment
how do you I I know there's a small
range that you can determine for the
rate of return so how do you determine
particularly in these high cost times
how do you determine what rate of return
that they should get on this next rate
hike particularly when the rate hike is
um
I will refrain from
speaking about
how things should be done for example in
that environment when if a rate case
comes to me but let me talk about it
generally and I I would I I would let
folks know that I used to be the return
on Equity expert for the POC as well as
for the Office of Consumer advocate so
let me talk generally
so so what happens is
um in you have the investors would look
at like this is how much money I have I
want to invest in different Ventures and
you
um you as an investor you might decide
to invest in an utility
but what return should you get on it
it's really largely uh driven by
um the the the the
competition across all investors they
are kind of revealing the opportunity
cost of their business or what their
money so that is done through a process
it's a pretty complicated process we
look at a sample of different utilities
at the and we look at how the financial
markets are operating and you use
um for example you will use a discounted
cash flow approach to come up with you
know what really are the investors
actually getting at this point in time
and that's what an analyst would do look
at those things and say you know what in
this current environment the return
should be this much for the distribution
utilities so that's how the process
works
um
sorry um and and what what you're asking
about the rates going high that is the
it's it's it's possible I mean it's a
fair question it's possible that
because of that the distribution the
return on distribution uh investment may
actually get impacted in the market and
whether that seeps through the analysis
when you look at a proxy set of
companies and do your DCF component
analysis that I I can't speak to at this
point
follow-up thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for the follow-up I I'm not I
may have asked the wrong question uh but
maybe um it doesn't matter I was really
talking about what establishes the
profit margin for the utility per se is
is that the same thing as what you just
described yes oh okay thank you yeah
representative munz has a question if
you want to elaborate on that yeah I can
elaborate and then turn it over if
that's okay
um so it's uh it's helpful to think of
it in buckets so you have the supply
bucket which is the fundamentally the
pass-through that we were talking about
earlier where there is no profit margin
that's on the supply side you have the
transmission side and then you have the
distribution side which is what
commissioner choto Pattaya was talking
about in this fancy equation you see at
the top of the sheet it's illustrative I
know it's complicated and a little
confusing when you look at it but I just
like to say that when you look at this
is for the distribution utility alone
that this particular equation and the
weighted average cost of capital the
commissioner shutter but I was talking
about is with respect to only the
capital portion of that of that of the
distribution utility there's lots of
other things in there like their
overhead costs these other things where
there's no return on that so it's
important to sort of break it into the
component pieces and I know we've been
talking about Supply and the return on
Supply and the return on the
distribution utilities and I just wanted
to segment between those two
foreign
[Music]
so the utilities and I I have a few
slides about some of these underlying
principles but the utilities make money
on capital investment the the utility
plant that they invest in and build the
wire that they hang on the polls the
polls that they put in the ground the
Transformers on the pole the gas main
that's in the ground the water pipe
that's in the ground the physical
infrastructure what they spend on that
physical infrastructure is what they
earn their return on those returns when
we gauge whether a utility should be
entitled to an eight and a half percent
return on that money that they spent on
capital or a nine percent or a 9.5 the
utility comes in in a rate case and they
present what's called a proxy group and
they show a proxy group of similarly
situated utilities across the country
whether it's gas electric water and they
demonstrate that in other states this is
what a similarly situated utility earns
for a return on investment and why
that's relevant is because these are
incredibly Capital intensive businesses
they borrow hundreds of millions if not
billions of dollars per year when they
go to financial markets like financial
institutions large Banks to borrow money
the interest rate on which they can
borrow money
varies based on the regulatory
environment and one of the factors
that's heavily weighed by the financial
Community is the return on investment
and this is fundamentally one of the
biggest struggles as Regulators when you
saw earlier that our logo is the scale
of justice and that RSA 363 designates
us as the Arbiter to balance the
interest between the utilities and the
customers and we have to consider all of
these factors when we set rates when we
set earnings to understand how do we
Foster healthy utilities that can borrow
and Access Capital in the markets at
competitive rates versus the significant
impacts that that has on your
constituents and customers in the state
that's that is ultimately the challenge
that we face in our roles as rate
regulators
that's a good explanation thank you
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and um I you you may have
answered some of my question already
um but just I want to clarify when you
talk about the the the the rate of
return being tied to the return that
um investors can get in other
uh Investments I mean that would include
the stock market for example
um but then commissioner Simpson you
mentioned that um it's it or you implied
and correct me if I'm wrong that it was
tied more to the the cost of debt
um
you know I guess what I'm trying to
understand is
how much do fluctuations in the stock
market and fluctuations in you know what
the FED is doing in terms of raising
interest rates how much does that have
an impact on the rate of return and and
and you know assuming it's assuming it
does do you do you adjust the the
allowed return in this equation based on
what's going on in those markets the the
answer is yes and that it affects both
of the items that you just articulated
cost to Capital cost of debt
um there are many factors that we have
to weigh in that analysis and it boils
down to when financial institutions look
at Investments they have different areas
with which they invest to diversify
their portfolios one of those is
utilities so the question for them is do
I invest my money in a utility in New
Hampshire or do I invest my money in a
utility in Massachusetts or Utah
and that's based on these these uh
factors that we consider in the rate
making process but my colleague is the
PHD in economics and an expert so he can
collaborate further so again I'll try to
keep it simple
um
an investor when I say an investor
um they are interested in spending their
own money that is kind of equity it's
not debt for an utility it's trying to
attract investors and it also has the
ability to go to the debt market and get
you know through say bonds or whatever
and they too have to be mindful of what
mix of debt and Equity they should
Target and that also becomes part of the
analysis when we are setting the
weighted cost of capital what is the
just uh and reasonable return so that's
that becomes part of the Analytics
follow-up uh so just a a follow-up given
what's going on right now where the the
stock market uh performance has gone
South which you know I regret every time
I look at my bank statement
um and the cost of cap the cost of debt
is going up because the FED is raising
the rates any sense of what that's going
to mean in terms of the allowed return
is that going to like drive it down
um
depends on the specifics of a particular
let's say filing but again speaking
generally
um
let's say if you have an environment
where the the interest rates on debt is
pretty low right so you might end up
concluding in this environment it's okay
to go a little bit more debt then so the
the weightage might be different and
ultimately
you have to keep in mind that when as a
neutrality you are getting money from an
investor or Equity you know post as an
equity
um that receives less priority
compared to the debt instrument that I
might be involved in so if I have to
return I have to give money to people I
have to prioritize debt so that issue
also comes into play and so
um in in an environment where the debt
the the debt rate is going up quite a
bit
you might say you know what
um
maybe the mix isn't
um what we have right now
and that's why I said it depends on the
specifics so and it maybe we can go a
little bit more equity which is fine
um but but
because I don't want to be exposed to
the to the to the prioritized you know
commitment that I have for for debt
instruments
so it's complicated
it is
representative partial did you have a
question okay thank you all right
so like I'm just making sure I've
covered yep okay and um so but I want to
also add that as you go to slide 13 that
rate setting is not simply about
distribution rates okay
um in fact are the rates impact
customers electricity gas water sewer
and Telecommunications bills and it goes
back to for example the as an example
the energy Supply component right and
it's important for those other other
components
we have to still be mindful of whether
the the utility has asked the proper
rates ultimately it's about billing
determinants you know whether a
particular rate design is the right
approach things like that so they imp
they influence
um you know there are things like System
benefit charges uh there's stranded cost
charges and there are these those
pass-through rates that I talked about
they also have to be looked at by the by
the commission and that happens
in my opinion more frequently than we
think it uh you know does perhaps
because there's all kinds of
reconciliation processes put in place
and to be clear and I'm going back to
the the this the point that uh
commissioner
Simpson was mentioning
um
as far as the rate base that I mentioned
in the previous slide that is really
about distribution companies that is
about the physical assets that those
companies need to be able to uh provide
service
that's that's one category so they
expect a return on it based on you know
this uh sort of the capitalist economy
here
um
for the other rates the utility is not
expected to or allowed to have any
return those are just pass-throughs so
you have a question representative
Summers
thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you commissioner for taking
these questions in fact being an
economist you're probably the perfect
person to answer this question for me
one thing and maybe we completely
misunderstand this but several folks
have spoken to look at it as a business
sense and they see you know the common
account assets equals liabilities plus
equity and so looking at this rate here
if does the utility have control of the
amount of depreciation to be able
because normally depreciation
more depreciation you put on right the
lower the taxes become which means the
lower the rate of return would be needed
is it can it be is it run like that do
they have control how much they can
depreciate or is it regulated to a set
amount
yeah
um
speaking generally and based on my
experience and I'm not a depreciation
expert but I can tell you that
um what tends to happen is the the
utility would say this is how the
depreciation schedule should be and then
you'll have the other parties including
POC staff I'm going back to the Earth
while POC they will say nope that is not
the that is not how it should be so
there's it's not it's not it and it's
not entirely determined by the utility
there is a
you know there's there's a process there
too
continue please
okay so
I'm going to move on to the topic of
the first
right now in New Hampshire
a customer can decide to stay with the
utility for their energy portion
so use default service pay default
Service rates
or they can go to a competitive supplier
and that
to the best of my knowledge I think it's
been happening for like two two decades
okay
um
that's already there
a lot of the
commercial and Industrial customers I
think have already made the switch
so very little remains with default
service but for residential customers
that has not happened to the extent
perhaps when
the when this move was made
the expectation was okay so
but it's it's customers do have that
choice
currently we also the commission has
um
allowed Community power aggregation and
and there has been a proliferation of it
and I need to be careful when I say that
it's still in the early stages when I
say proliferation it really the the
those towns are
uh submitting petitions okay approve us
for Community power application that's
happening a lot more and
um so that's what I meant that too
as an economist I will tell you when
people have more choices
it's good it it puts competitive
pressures on prices and and if you have
a monopoly service it doesn't have a
whole lot of competition then it's it
tends to
um
accommodate more inefficiencies so in
that sense the that those two moves are
but as we were talking about
I was also amazed to see the hike in the
prices the energy Supply prices right I
mean I'm I'm I also consume electricity
so it does affect me
um and you know it so I I'm on default
service right now and I try to think
about you know what should I do
differently right so I'm sure most
people are doing that
but it's also a question of what
processes are put in place and we as
Commissioners we come into it
I became a commissionary roughly a year
ago there are these processes that are
in place we try to follow them and you
you come up or you end up
facing this situation so then you start
asking whether there are things we can
do to the processes itself
to make it less problematic for the
customers
you still have to abide by the statutes
we are a restructured state we we the
generation is no longer
um uh regulated and all of that within
that scheme we are there things we can
do and that's that's part of what we're
trying to do in that uh investigative
docket okay so just small so that's my
second slide second bullet here
um
speaking as an economist keeping things
and I've been involved in a lot of
Regional electric matters
um I was
one of the analysts for the Public
Utility Commission that used to go to
the nipple meetings to the ferc and all
of that so I mean I can I can tell you
from my experience
the iso New England Market which is
where
all of the
issues about very high prices is
happening right now the energy Supply
there the focus is
is kind of
a lot more on the supply side
the
you know the generating companies things
like that
and I think there may be approaches that
we can take on the customer side or on
the demand side that can also provide
ability for us to
keep the prices at check the ones that
you face
in the energy Supply rates so and that
is a question are there things we can do
so so I kind of point out few things
here
a better retail level rate making
oriented like can we use tou it's it's
it's been approved in some cases but
that doesn't mean it's end of the the
job it's can we improve it then there's
there's other items like Dynamic pricing
real-time pricing so that
um and that creates opportunities for
transactive energy and and what I mean
by that at a very high level you if you
realize that electricity
it's a unique product you have to match
demand and Supply every instant and so
in some ways you might say you have
Market every instant being run
um like so you want to meet and you're
looking for a price signal that that
tells you where the demand meets the
supply because that's what basic
economics will tell you it's you know
it's it's the the laws of demand and
supply
and I'm kind of uh and so it's
and but we we have a system here we have
average rate right a customer's rate is
decided default service rate this is the
rate for the next six months and that
creates actually opportunities for
customers to be able to actually bring
more value into the picture and maybe
help lower the supply rates
but it's it's it's it's a as I started
saying it's a very general concept but
I'm just sharing my thoughts as an
economist okay great I wanted to let you
finish your point before I pointed to
representative Corman for a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question when you listed uh
things that we can be done on the demand
side one thing that you omitted was
Energy Efficiency and I'm wondering uh
why that wasn't in the list
Energy Efficiency is also part of how
you can
reduce the demand so in that sense it is
absolutely part of the demand it's in
the in the in the picture already
so I I I'm talking about are there other
things that are more responsive to the
market realities
instantaneously that's what I was
focusing on here a lot of the times
Energy Efficiency is like almost like a
base resource it's there you should
definitely exploit it but here I was
focusing on how better we can achieve
the uh equilibrium between supply and
demand and and so there may be things
so I understand what you're saying
um but can I infer then that that you
feel like Energy Efficiency is as it's
as far as we've gone and we really can't
do anymore it's just there or or can can
more be done on the demand side with
regard to Energy Efficiency
generally speaking there are
um I mean first of all I have to be
careful because there's this is an
expiry thing and you know in the future
sometime in July there will be another
Docket in energy so I'll keep it really
General
we should always look for ways to
get
um
you know demand based resources into the
mix as long as they are cost effective
and we should always strive
to even have Energy Efficiency that
um that can be achieved
to help us with the cost effective you
know Solutions so I I would say nothing
is
I'll add
um I would agree there's a lot more that
can be done in terms of Energy
Efficiency and and demand responsiveness
and what a commissioner chadapattai is
uh discussing on this slide are the rate
foundations on which customers are
charged and today under the Paradigm
where you have a fixed rate
you there are opportunities to reduce
that but in terms of Energy Efficiency
there are things that people still need
to do but they could change when they do
it so for instance I am on a time of use
rate my utility in Hampton offers time
of use rates and I'm a customer on that
my electricity price changes based on
the hour of the day I change my behavior
I charge my car at different times I
turn on my dishwasher or my dryer at
different times because of that
I think what
we are presenting in terms of
opportunities to Foster competition are
rate designs that enable customer
control of demand responsiveness and
that includes
Baseline Energy Efficiency Technologies
like we have today but there are many
many other opportunities as well that we
could capture and provide customers with
more information so that they can change
I will I will add the the focus for me
here is fostering competition and really
what I'm I think uh commissioner Simpson
explained it well that are there ways to
um as a customer
if I can bring in flexibility Into The
Fray
that would lead to a better situation
right now what tends to happen and
that's what I was talking about my
experience with the regional markets
it it is kind of understandable but
there's a focus mostly on the supply
side
that that's that's the point I'm trying
to make
could I uh just get your clarification
on one point I think I heard you say
that Community aggregation is a lot like
a competitive supplier
is that a valid way to make that
comparison
I would say that I
don't know the absolute answer for that
question but what I was saying
was
if just like a competitive supplier
if you have a community aggregator and
they give you different rates
and they have a different way of
managing resources
that's providing
competition there's another option out
there
how I don't have the answer this is
really a question whether that can be
done in a way that is truly achieving
that goal which is it puts more pressure
downward pressure on the prices I it's
it's a it's a question for everyone but
but
you need to always be in my opinion be
more willing to
um
to allow for more options
great thank you
representative partial now has a
question
making sure those and thank you thank
you again uh this question I'd like to
ask uh Mr Simpson you were speaking
about your and sounds like a very
exciting system you have of being able
to Monitor and uh plan your electric use
in order to flatten the Curve uh you
must live in a place other than the uh
eversource where you have a meter that
can do this I would imagine I live in
the town of Hampton my utility is Unitil
yes and majority of the our state does
not have the capacity to enact that
third bullet because we do not have the
type of meter that allow us to do that
so we have ongoing proceedings right now
that pertain to this so I'm going to
speak generally I can discuss my utility
rate with Unitil because it's a we've
issued an order it's an approved rate
with respect to enabling time of use
rates more broadly across the state
that's been a policy Initiative for
several years here in New Hampshire
there's been uh the general court passed
a law several years ago I think it was
Senate Bill
517 that that started an investigation
looking into time of use rates
specifically for electric vehicles and
uh I think
understanding and and continuing to
investigate uh broad deployment of that
uh rate type for customers is is of
interest for us and is something that
we're we're looking at in multiple
proceedings the underlying systems that
you mentioned like metering uh that
plays into it and
um I think going back again to the the
our discussion about
you know the scale of investment these
being very Capital intensive Industries
the challenge that we face is that
technology moves more quickly than uh
the financial commitments that are
required in this industry uh sometimes
bare so the investment in a broad
enterprise-wide system like that is
hundreds of millions of dollars it has
to be used for a certain period of time
I'm not saying that I personally want to
hold back on that I'm very interested in
time of use rate designs personally
um I I hope that we can enable more
options like that for customers uh so
that they can take control of their
energy use and the costs that they bear
okay thank you before uh you move on I
want to apologize to the three of you
but I must leave I have to introduce a
bill in another committee so
representative Thomas will be uh
presiding over the rest of this meeting
uh
and I thank you all three for being here
giving us an excellent presentation and
I regret that I'll miss the rest of it
but uh thank you please continue
foreign
by all means continue please so um going
slide 15.
it is really tied to the point that I
was making at the end in slide 14 and
what I wanted to share from my end was
that
um
even as
the state of New Hampshire New Hampshire
participating in the regional processes
there may be opportunities to rely more
on the demand side
to bring value to customers here and the
the point I'm trying to make here is
that if you if you know how winter snaps
work
then there could be times when you have
a pretty prolonged winter snap and that
creates huge problems for the New
England region because we are at the end
of the the gas pipeline Network and so
it creates problems we and
we could really see a major issue
because of that so what the intent of
this slide is to say
generally as a customer
you know if you're not paying a whole
lot on electricity and I'm talking in
terms of percentage of your income okay
um you may say why do I worry about the
fluctuating prices I am just paying
three percent of my salary on it okay if
it becomes four percent one year two
percent the other year I I don't need to
think so much I don't need to track how
I'm consuming how I'm running the washer
dryer and all of that I don't need to do
that so I'm just going to be
that may well be true a lot of customers
may actually not need this kind of
flexibility but I can definitely see
that when you have a a prolonged winter
snap kind of situation the prices go
crazy
um you know even up to maybe even three
thousand dollars like you know two
thousand five hundred dollars so it's
there is there is opportunities for
customers to extract value out of that
and do things even during winter and
that's what I'm saying with this slide
so we we need to also think about that
that may be not happening right away but
the
um the um
urgency of it
it's all dependent on our experience
if a really bad cold snap hits then
we'll start thinking about it and
usually what happens in again in the iso
New England World the focus is more on
the supply side
so
representative has a question and thank
you Mr chair uh following following on
your current discussion of customer
choices uh I'm thinking of residential
customers uh the price rate that we were
stuck with or stuck on uh I think of as
a signal to to the customers and they
must be thinking of of changing their
service to find a less costly Service uh
do you track that information do you
have access to that information and know
how much of that is happening yeah uh
yes we do track that information about
15 percent of the customers in New
Hampshire
use a third-party supplier that is not
yes sir okay and and I assume that this
is ongoing for some people it probably
takes a little while to learn about this
and get themselves set up to chase it
out yeah I think a lot of people are
surprised that uh the that rate is not
the uh that the number of the default
service
um number of customers taking default
services so High
um that the transition hasn't been uh
faster
um in other states it's been faster I
think a lot of people in New Hampshire
blame it on the original rollout which
was before any of our time but there the
rollout maybe wasn't as smooth as it
could have been so uh it is surprising
and now we have the community
aggregation thing rolling in and will
that you know start to start to dominate
default service is is a good question
it's early days so we don't we don't
uh I have a question a follow-up to uh
representative Knowles question so
um could it be that
as far as I'm aware if you were to
change your entry supplier
uh to a lower rate the
the
impetus is on the customer to make sure
that he watches that when the next
um
time period comes like after six months
or whatever it is uh they may forget
they it's it's a it it's upon them to
say oh I don't want you anymore because
your rates can be higher than the other
rate I was on before I left now I have
to switch again is there a way that we
could smooth it out so uh customers
don't have to remember to do that so
much I guess is my question
okay I think that's a very fair concern
um I've personally used third-party
suppliers
in the past and and there is no
notification there's uh we you know we
have the big calendar at home and we
write the date on when it when it when
it's coming due and that's maybe not the
best way to to run a railroad no pun
intended
um so so that that is something that uh
that is problematic in terms of this
notification process as it exists today
from the third parties
the if I may ask a follow-up do you see
I would let commissioner
so I would I would leave that question
to the legislature frankly
um I think that there are factors to
consider when you weigh whether or not
you impose changes like that I mean
clearly that or I should say changes in
terms of program structure or rules have
an impact in how the competitive
supplier Community then weighs the risks
that they factor into their price
and what they ultimately charge
customers so I think that's a policy
decision that would be best answered by
the legislature but I would I would say
that there are many considerations on
how those changes might impact
I want to
respond to
what commissioner Gunner was talking
about you know he's he's he has
competitive supplies you know I I can
tell you just day before yesterday I was
talking about
yeah we can we have options and I told
that to my wife so you're telling me now
he's like so she had no clue but I that
also tells me that she doesn't listen to
me because I probably did did tell her a
long time ago
um so I know friends who are very
particular they're actually looking at
the rates all the time they are on
competitive Supply they're they it's
also a question of how long you want to
be locked in
okay so they think about that aspect too
so you might you might as the prices are
beginning to go down let's say then you
might say you know what
um if I if I uh jump into a log price
for the next for one year that may not
be smart because what might happen is
the prices go down
so much that the average rate that that
the competitive supplier is giving me
that may be high so let me just I I know
that I had those discussions with mine
so I just wanted to share that okay
um
I think that's that's it please keep
sharing
representative once has a question thank
you Mr chair
um
which which government agency has
oversight responsibility for the third
so the department of energy tracks those
prices if you go to the New Hampshire
Department of Energy's website you can
see all of the competitive or I believe
all of you can see competitive Supply
rates that are offered in New Hampshire
um and they have the responsibility for
for uh providing that information to the
public and reviewing it
follow-up
follow-up do they also have
responsibility for
um addressing customer service issues
such as not notifying people in a timely
manner when rates are changing
um
there they have a consumer division that
works with customers I don't know if
they
I'm not sure if they're if that's
something that is an initiative of
theirs or not
um but we as the adjudicative body for
really primarily utility rates we don't
interface in that way that's now been
uh I see we have not much time left I'd
like to have you continue so you can
cover your material uh before we ask too
many more barrages of questions
okay so I'm up next
um
we wanted to address the topic of
protection of consumers so I have a
slide on that where I'll discuss our
various authorities but then the
remainder of my presentation is really
just to try to be educational and
provide context I think we've had a lot
of the discussions this morning but I've
tried to structure it in a way that
helps explain utility history utility
regulation generally speaking some of
the precedent that we rely on as utility
regulators and then the New England
Market at Large
so with respect to protection of
consumers
we generally regulate the utilities in
in the state and our goal is to ensure
that they do not charge illegal unjust
unreasonable or discriminatory rates the
utilities are answerable to us to
provide for safe and adequate service
the department of energy and the office
of the consumer Advocate also are
authorities in this space for protecting
the public
if a complaint is filed against a
utility at the department of energy
and there's no resolution to that then
the complaint can be submitted to the
puc and we can hear that complaint and
come to a decision
um we are authorized on our own
initiative to investigate and inspect
utilities and initiate proceedings if we
feel that there are risks out there or
that there are issues that deserve uh
our uh oversight and furthermore the
utility can come before us on their own
initiative as well
we can request that the Attorney
General's office initiate a legal
proceeding for a utilities failure to
perform duties
and the commission can order reparations
uh is it possible to hold a question
until they get going a little more
further so they can get the material or
is it something it's can can you write
it down and ask you what and ask later
thank you
so
um I mentioned this earlier but
generally speaking utility regulation
arose in the 19th century
um around the provision of water service
initially and then that uh gas service
for gas lighting
um this came this concept of the natural
monopoly is critical uh John Stuart Mill
in 1848 utility service could be
supplied at a lower cost if the
duplication of facilities by competitive
firms were avoided
um there's a there's a picture that many
people have seen of early electric polls
with dozens of electric wires hanging on
them that is not an efficient model for
the provision of an incredibly Capital
intensive uh business that is essential
to the public so we enable utilities to
have a monopoly because fundamentally it
is more cost effective to have one
provider of these Services than multiple
providers
um we
have regulation in order to protect the
public interest from that Monopoly power
the utilities have to offer Universal
service they have to offer service to
everyone they have to do it safely they
have to do it reliably and they have to
do it responsibly because customers
can't shop around from their incumbent
provider they only have one
going to our next Slide the regulatory
compact is a concept in the field of
utility regulation and what it means is
that there's an agreement that exists
between a utility that's a private
company and the government
we've given them a monopoly they're the
only one that can provide service in a
geographic area the utility therefore
has an obligation to serve all customers
within those bounds
the government in turn promises to set
rates that the utility can charge in a
manner that will compensate the utility
for the costs that they've incurred to
provide that service and the case
precedent is we often refer to the Blue
Field case that the utility is entitled
to rates that permit it to earn a return
on its property it can recover its cost
and on the property that it that it
develops the infrastructure that
develops it's entitled to earn a return
on that for the provision of that
service that's incentive regulation that
we've
incentivized utility Behavior we've told
them you have this Monopoly you you can
operate you're the only one that can
operate in this area you have the
opportunity to earn a return on that
that incentive regulation Paradigm
limits some utility decision making
utilities are fundamentally risk adverse
because of that that construct but it
also can incentivize other utility
Behavior
um and Under The Hope case just in
reasonable rates involve the balancing
of investor and consumer interests so
again going back to that concept that
Capital intensive very expensive
utilities have to borrow money raise
Capital that the balance of that
incentive regulation is to enable them
to access Capital at competitive rates
can we get through this presentation a
little bit more and then we can write
your question down we will allow
questions later
thanks until you're done with your part
of the presentation okay I'll try to
move as quickly as I can
um the next slide slide 20 uh just
demonstrates the elements of the
electric grid and uh
I I present this it's an often shown uh
graphic to show really the the utility
structure but also fundamentally
jurisdiction in the jurisdictional
questions and relevance that exists
between the states and the federal
government so on this graphic you see uh
a generation facility on the left a
power plant
um that then connects to the
transmission system which is Interstate
generally speaking and that provides
bulk transmission of energy across state
lines those lines then end within States
and they uh connect to the local
Distribution Systems which are primarily
uh state which are State and are
um going to our next slide just to give
you some insight into you know where
does this Authority come from why why do
states regulate distribution why does
the ferc regulate transmission
so the state regulation is rooted in the
U.S Constitution under our police power
and that's the ability for states to
regulate for the societal benefit of
health safety and general welfare and it
isn't specific to utilities that's a
broad Authority that states have under
the United States Constitution
um under the 10th Amendment Powers not
delegated to the federal government are
reserved for the states so that's
expansive that if the federal government
has not said we are going to regulate
this area of business that is left to
the states to regulate and state
regulation as I noted generally focuses
on local distribution of energy the
generation of of energy and intrastate
activities activities that occur within
going to the next slide
um the federal government's regulatory
Authority in this space uh comes out of
the the Commerce Clause in the United
States Constitution that the Congress
shall have the power to regulate
commerce among several States
um so when there's something that
crosses state borders that is now
overseen by the federal government and
not state governments and the relevant
federal statute is the federal power act
and that provides that ferc has
jurisdiction over the use or sale of
electric energy in interstate commerce
applying to the transmission of electric
energy in inter-state Commerce and to
the sale of electric energy at wholesale
in interstate commerce so there's a
natural gas act but I think the it's
well stated in the federal power act and
that theme applies generally
any other sale
meaning distribution of retail electric
energy is regulated by the states
regulated by this commission which was
created by the legislature
um and other regulatory authorities all
rates in connection with the
transmission or sale of electric energy
subject to the jurisdiction of the
Federal Energy Regulatory Commission
shall be just unreasonable same as us
rates that we set and regulate must be
just and reasonable as well
I think it's a good time to pause and I
like to get back to some good questions
uh sure I representative Carmen if you
had your course no four and I believe
representative Summers had a question at
the time so let's cover those questions
or any questions that that might come up
on these last two pages that were quite
interesting but as a matter of fact
thank you Mr chairman uh so I'm just
going back to uh when you talk about
investigations and I'm just curious
um when when does the puc decide to open
a docket what are the uh criteria
um what are the limits to what you can
do uh things like that
we have um maybe one of my colleagues
might have the statutory reference the
RSA but there's an RSA that enables the
commission to open an investigation and
um it's it's General Authority
um perhaps one of my colleagues might
have the you know have the text
um
we
when there are areas of
um
the the industry
or elements of of Regulation
that
Merit further study
an investigation is an option for us
the general court from time to time has
directed that the commission opens an
investigation and there have been
investigations into things like electric
vehicle time of use rates that was an
investigation that the commission
conducted a couple of years ago
um
the the commission has also opened
investigations on our own initiative and
I'm sure you're you're thinking about uh
some recent ones like Energy Efficiency
or the investigation that we have into
the provision of of uh default electric
service and gas service
because of our roles as as adjudicators
we're governed by ethical duties uh and
ex parte in that we we cannot engage
with open matters before the commission
with the public everything that we do is
is on the record submitted to us through
a public forum and that protects
customers that protects the process
investigations we conduct similarly in a
public manner
we have an open docket we have public
meetings that folks can come to
sometimes they're called technical
sessions
where there's no decision that the
commission and is adjudicating there's
nothing that the commission is trying to
come to for a decision or has been asked
to it's more when there's an issue that
deserves uh
further analysis and learning by the
commission
so we can do that in an open uh public
forum can get stakeholders together we
can ask questions they can provide us
with information
and
we can we can do that in a public way
that enables a a conversation
and information submitted to us to learn
more
a follow-up thank you so you mentioned
the Energy Efficiency report so let me
refer specifically to that uh what was
yeah I can I can touch on that and
perhaps the other Commissioners would
have some additional comments
um I I'm the longest tenured
commissioner at a year and a half I
started in May of 2021 uh the
Commissioners to my right started in
December of that same year so we um
we were not um in the Energy Efficiency
dockets that preceded us we had never
had the opportunity to ask questions or
engage in those dockets so for us
um this investigative DACA was an
opportunity for us to do some learning
and understand what at a deeper level
what was going on in that particular
I would add too I um
I
did not participate in that proceeding
it was before my time that it was opened
and I understand the questions that
arise out of it I would say that the
investigatory ability of the commission
is an important
um
option for the commission to exercise in
certain times
within the scope of the Energy
Efficiency realm there were a lot of
administrative changes that happened
both to the commission and within the
space of Energy Efficiency regulation in
the state of New Hampshire the
commission was restructured
administratively in 2021 and then in
2022 there was a statute that passed
that directed the commission to use
specific tests for the evaluation of
cost benefit within the Energy
Efficiency programs and um
my understanding is that the commission
at the time needed to embark on that
investigation to better understand the
tests that were in place that put in
place by the legislature and would be
used within the evaluation of Energy
I'll go back to representative Summers
for a question he may have thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question this actually will probably
cover almost every one of your slides
you just had here that's one question
but um on your regulatory compact you
had in here the utility has an
obligation to serve and regulation
incentives utility behavior
um we we actually had New Hampshire
Electric Co-op that was met in front of
us and they had stated that their rates
gave us our their current rates and they
were less than half of what the
regulated rates were for the utilities
now
um they said that this was because the
fact that they can go the market on a on
a daily weekly monthly basis to be able
to price compete for the price in the
market compared to where the electric
utilities could only go once every six
months
um is this is the fact that they can
only go once every six months is that
part of the regulation how does that
incentivize Us by them not be able to
price compete more often it's a great
question and we have an investigation on
going to look into those those processes
um
I think what we see is that
Commodities markets fluctuate on a daily
basis a moment by moment basis and
the utilities plan for a day when they
go and issue an RFP to procure energy
Supply
um so
there might you might go out one day and
the price is significantly lower than
the next and that's due to a lot of
global factors Supply factors unknowns
that are hard to predict
um similarly or or conversely I should
say sometimes you might get a really
good price on a day and you lock that in
so it
it's a process question and we're
grappling with that ourselves and we're
trying to gain more information through
this investigatory process and uh
understand what factors should be
considered and gain feedback from the
public about what could be changed in
that process and how it could be better
one follow-up quick follow-up uh is
there anything then written in stone or
stated that makes it the regular the
utilities not be able to behave like the
it's a great question
you you might you might get some
assistance by looking behind you to the
consumer advocate
foreign
I'm not a lawyer but
um I'm just speaking
at least I'm trying to address part of
the question that you're asking
um
through the best of my recollection
then
the restructuring happen and when the
default Service rates were being
put into you know place I think I think
there was a concern about uh they
shouldn't be facing the volatility that
would result if you are letting rate
pairs go up you know and deal with the
prices every day okay so it's a very
general answer from me but I think
that's I may have seen that that is the
reason why things were what they were
over the last so many years but that's
just uh my instinct is that there is a
commission order from years and years
ago that dictated that process I'm happy
to go back and and look and see what
that precedent is but I can tell you
today that this is the process that the
utilities have been using for years
decades and it has not really evolved
over that time and that's the purpose of
this investigation is to look in into
what might be opportunities for
evolution in that space
and I'll I'll take Chairman's
prerogative to follow up on the
follow-up to just so it's my
understanding then it's
it's not any state law that would
prevent that it's just go back to review
I mean I I think um I think what
Commissioners is a symptom chat overtai
or we're communicating which I'll just
augment is that you know this commission
these Commissioners are are pretty new
we've come into the process we've
inherited a process we're looking at
that process in an IR docket to see what
we can do differently so we're very
engaged very interested in in this and
then on the nhec question I would say
two that uh but probably if you go back
and you look at a longer Horizon it
would be interesting to see what the
data would say there currently the natc
rates are lower I think if we go back
and look at history there's some
perturbations in that in that analysis
and we we'd be happy to go back and
gather that data and uh and send that to
this committee if that's helpful
okay thank you representative munz has a
question yeah I think my my questions
along the same lines here I mean I do
think it would be really interesting to
know whether the the um the standard of
setting rates every six months is
something that has been set by Statute
or just and therefore we have to do
something or whether it's just um you
know an order that you can then revise
so I think it would be very helpful to
know that
that's a great question and we'll follow
up with you on that
at this point I'd like to reserve the
rest of your time to finish your
presentation so we can have a few
questions after that please sure so I'll
move as quickly as I can uh one of the
the really relevant Federal statutes
that has transformed the landscape of
utility regulation over the last 50
years or so was perpa the public
utilities regulatory Policy Act of 1978.
this came about following the energy
crisis in the early 70s and it was
implemented to encourage energy
conservation fuel diversity Equitable
rates and enhance competition for
supply-side resources in the Electric
market you might have heard the term
qualifying facilities and that really
stemmed from this policy from purpa
which stimulated Market competition
that has led to restructured States like
we are in New Hampshire
and underperpa what these competitive
market generators are entitled to is
What's called the avoided cost so what
the vertically integrated or the utility
Monopoly that would own generation what
they would have to pay uh if they built
new generation and can subsequently
avoid by purchasing power on the
competitive market
the next slide shows a map of the US and
the state of deregulation on the
electric side there's about a third of
the states in the United States that
have restructured or deregulated
electricity markets some states have
deregulated gas markets in New Hampshire
commercial and Industrial customers have
the option to shop around for their gas
supply similar to Electric customers
if you go to the next slide this just
shows the regional transmission
organizations that exist across the
country We Exist within ISO New England
they are the RTO the regional
transmission organization that runs and
operates the regional grid and there are
several others across the country some
states are not in an RTO and individual
utilities within States perform these
functions but we are within the
Northeast New England Regional grid
next slide
this shows ISO New England's control
room they have a control room in Holyoke
Massachusetts where they operate the
regional grid
um
rates within the region are regulated by
ferc and ISO New England has tariffs
that are regulated by ferc their job is
to ensure the reliability of the
interstate transmission system and to
administer the Region's competitive
wholesale electricity markets
next slide
um the Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission is is the puc's analog at a
federal level
um ferc is composed of five
Commissioners as opposed to three
um they're all appointed by the
president of the United States uh with
the advice and approval of the United
States Senate Commissioners on ferc
serve five-year terms and have an equal
vote on regulatory matters just like the
and then my last two slides uh just
discussed some Regional entities and
National entity that we work closely
with for New England the New England
Conference of Public Utilities
Commissioners or neck Puck is the
Consortium of utility Regulators in New
England
um they're a non-profit corporation that
provides Regional regulatory assistance
on matters of common concern to Public
Utilities commissions convene meetings
organize different meetings with
Commissioners across New England they
don't have any independent regulatory
Authority it's just a Consortium that
organizes utility Commissioners across
the region
and then next slide similarly their
Federal analog is narok the National
Association of regulatory utility
Commissioners it's one of the oldest
associations of its type in the country
it's a non-profit that serves State
commissions
and they work to improve the quality and
effectiveness of public utility
regulation they work on a lot of papers
do research have meetings that convene
discussions
um and it's it's something that state
Regulators from around the country are
involved in
so that's the end of our presentation
I'm sure we're happy to take any further
questions that you all might have thank
you
representative um Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um so the puc has a certain role uh the
doe has a certain role the general court
has a certain role Office of Consumer
Advocate has a certain role everybody
has a role do you feel like these roles
are clearly defined do you feel like the
general court should clarify things any
further
foreign
you know I I think that um
that the change made on July 1st of uh
of 2021
um everyone has been working really hard
to make those adjustments and and and
move forward and and sort through all
the different challenges associated with
the reorganization and uh I I answered
your question I think would be that I
think there are some Growing Pains
there's always challenges but I do think
that
um I do think that uh the change was
well defined and I think that we have a
good understanding of our role inside of
I see representative munz has a last
question
I'm sorry I'll I'll say represent months
and then represent a partial will have
the last question go ahead thank you
thank you Mr chair
um in one of the early slides where you
were talking about the old versus new
puc you mentioned that the the doe
provides the commission with independent
information on the record
um
given that the doe is an executive
department
how independent is that information
versus you know you doing it yourself
yeah I think I'll try to answer the
question I can't uh I can't really
answer the question about the Doe's
objectivity would be a better question
for the doe than it would be for the puc
but I know that the OCA who's here today
and the doe who's a mandatory party to
all our proceedings provide extremely
valuable and really necessary
information for us to balance the
interests of the monopolies the
utilities with the residential repairs
and with all of the other different
pieces and different attributes that we
need to consider so I would just say the
doe is a critical part of us getting the
information that we need and I um I
don't know how to uh I don't know how to
okay I represent partial uh please
finish up her excellent presentation
here with your question thank you chair
and thank you again
um first a comment and a question I'd
love to see John Stuart Mills quoted in
any presentation and I thank you for
that
um you mentioned that purple means to
encourage energy conversation
recently the puc released a report on
Energy Efficiency planning programming
and evaluation was mentioned earlier the
device program such as New Hampshire
saves and some say puts a thumb on it
the report claims that the granite state
test is asymmetrical and inconsistent
with industry Norms on the surface it
appears to be inconsistent with the
findings of our benefit cost work group
report conducted in 2019. I think I'd be
remiss if I did not ask for further
comment from the POC this time though I
do understand that time constraints May
foreign
based on the
the record request responses that we had
received in that docket we are simply
trying to analyze the information
and I think it would be incorrect to
um assume that that is how we
necessarily look at it it's just a sort
of a question
and um coming from
from
my vantage point I mean it's it's it's
there is
the the economics based question about
what do you mean by society in which
when you talk about societal benefits
and all of that so it's not a very we we
weren't really reaching any conclusions
it was just looking at the substance and
coming to an understanding of what it
means to us we have we are still
learning and we are getting we have
gotten comments in the docket and I
think it's would be good for anybody to
take a look at it
I can tell you we are still it's just
that docket was really meant to improve
our understanding of what things are and
it's it's still in sort of an ongoing
process
oh right
uh well thank you
um yes I love good questions to me
they're better than good answers because
it's questions that move us forward
um my concern and maybe you can quiet
this concern is that
um asking these kind of questions
tends to point to certain directions and
tips the hand of the puc's what you see
is planning in the future
would you say that that would should not
Ed
tonight the
um can you um it would be helpful to
point this to a particular section or a
particular question or concern that you
have relative to the uh
relative to the um the the report is
there a specific area that you're
concerned about where I'm just trying to
understand your question
um
well my general concern is the
preservation of New Hampshire safes and
[Music]
um
this report seems to devalue the work
that is being done
uh by New Hampshire saves
um
and I'm just wondering if it tips the
hand unfairly
to other
away from New Hampshire saves okay thank
you for the clarification I think I
would say in the other Commissioners can
certainly comment as well is that the
general court was clear about the amount
of money that they want to spend on
Energy Efficiency and New Hampshire
saves here in New Hampshire I think it's
roughly 75 million dollars a year as I
recall
in the commission inside of that has the
obligation to understand what's being
spent and how it's being spent and make
sure it's being spent in a
cost-effective fashion so that's our
role in that so we're respectful of
course that the general court has
provided and appreciate the fact that
the general court has provided Clarity
and the amount of spending and that that
in many ways makes our role more
understandable and easier to execute
thank you for that answer thank you
or something
I'll just say for myself I'm very
interested in Energy Efficiency as I as
I mentioned earlier I have a background
in electric power engineering and I view
the efficient operation of energy
systems as critical to ensure cost
Effectiveness success
and reliability I think that there's a
lot of opportunities that can be done in
that space and build upon the the work
that's been done over the past 20 years
the com the legislature made very clear
in 1996 when when it passed RSA 374f
that Energy Efficiency is a priority of
New Hampshire and it remains a priority
of New Hampshire codified in statute
um
I speaking on behalf of myself
I view the programs that the utilities
have administered over the last 20ish
years as successful
and
just like we're looking at evolution in
the space of energy procurement I think
that there's a lot of opportunity for
technology to be a critical part of
enabling customer control demand side
control
um
and it remains a a
strategy that is important for the state
and we we remain committed to that
well I want to thank the three of you
for being here today I also want to be
respectful of your hard stop at 11
o'clock which it is right at this moment
so once again we we say uh to you that
we appreciate you being here we
appreciate this excellent presentation
and your willingness to answer our
questions and we'll look forward to
having you back again at another time
um in fact I'm expecting someone from
your from the commission to be here
later this afternoon to testify on House
Bill 219 at three o'clock
so we'll see somebody from the
commission at that time and until then
we'll say uh good day to you and see you
next time around thank you for inviting
us it was a pleasure speaking with you
all today thank you now we will be
opening a public hearing on House Bill
211 but I'm going to uh Institute a
five-minute recess so that members can
take care of themselves personally
before we start that public hearing so
stand by we'll be uh starting HB 211 at
1105.
I officially opened the
which is an act relative to her report
by the department of energy on the
effectiveness of the system benefits
charge
and I call to the testimony table the
prime sponsor of the bill
and vice chair of this committee
representative Doug Thomas
thank you Mr chair and thank you to the
committee members for hearing my bill
this bill is a housekeeping Bill and it
was asked by the Department of
Environmental Services to present it it
was a result of action we took last
biennium to eliminate the electric
oversight committee and we had to
rearrange
reports about where uh other reports
that were contained in that original
regulation to be sent as a result of the
Department of energy being being formed
and the result of the elimination of the
of the oversight committee the
Department of Environmental Services no
longer has a a role to play in
submitting a a report on the citizens
benefits charge so they said this was a
typographical Old Mission that we didn't
get rid of and they requested just to be
to be removed from that and that's the
basis of this bill it's just to correct
an error that was overlooked less
biennium
thank you representative seems like a
fairly simple and straightforward Bill
any questions from the committee about
seeing none I'll call forward
the next person to testify on this bill
that would be Griffin Roberge from the
wow
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh for the record Griffin
Roberge from the New Hampshire
Department of energy I'll keep my
testimony brief House Bill 211 is a good
bill you should support it
um that is pretty much my testimony it
is
um it is a very um it is just a
housekeeping measure I reiterate all the
points that representative Thomas Made
there was a little bit of confusion in
House Bill 1270 and House Bill 1258 from
last year that include DES in drafting
the system benefits charge report this
is just to clean up and I'll take any
seeing none I thank you very much thank
you
and with no more pink cards in hand
I will ask is there anybody who would
like to speak who has not submitted a
pink card
Mr chairman I did submit a pink card I
think it's working its way over but um I
will just say that uh uh we uh fully
concur with the comments that were
provided by the department of energy
um and uh Mr Robert's extensive
testimony and I we agree this is a
housekeeping we requested this we have
nothing to do with the SBC distribution
and again this was just a drafting error
so we're we're supportive of the bill as
well it was at our request as uh was
noted by representative Thomas and we
thank you
foreign
thank you any questions for Mr
Fitzgerald
seeing none
I will now uh call to the testimony
table The Honorable John Mann of
allstead
who would like to make a comment or two
on this bill and he is
pardon
we'll come on to the table and sit down
and let us enjoy it yeah very very
simple comment really that oh it seems
you turned it off instead of on
I think
um Energy's efficiency is extremely
important for our future
and any justification for it any
supporting
information uh
um or guidance information guidance
suggestions
about Energy Efficiency that are
that the department of environment could
come up with would be valuable
in supporting Energy Efficiency programs
finding value for the Energy Efficiency
programs and so on
so I uh I would go the other way and
suggest that they should write some
comments about
how important or not if they find it
that way how important the Energy
Efficiency programs could be
okay that's it thank you and it's nice
to see you uh John appreciate you
driving over here on this frightfully
cold day
any questions for The Honorable John
Mann
seeing none
we thank you
and now with no more pink cards in hand
I think it's safe to say that we can
officially close the public hearing on
House Bill 211 and I'll ask
representative closet to give us an
indication if there's any blue sheet
activity on this bill
on House Bill 211 the blue sheet there
is one in favor none a pulse
I do not have the online
okay thank you
we'll try to maybe get that later
I will alert everyone here to the
possibility that we will exec this bill
at four o'clock when we have executive
session
the ranking member is not here at the
moment but if she agrees to executing
this bill on the same day house rules
will permit that so we will add that to
our list of bills to exec at four
o'clock
pending a discussion with the ranking
member
and with that
we will now officially break for lunch
so we will be in recess until one
o'clock
if you decide to go out for lunch make
sure you bundle up it's cold out there
okay good afternoon everybody welcome
back to the afternoon session of science
technology and energy for
Friday February the 3rd 2003.
this afternoon we're going to hear three
bills in public hearing
HB 633
hb-139 and hb219 after which we will
enter executive session
where we will have an executive session
on HB 418 HB 92
hb630 HB 234 and HB 246 and possibly
hb211
so with that I'd like to open the public
hearing on House Bill 633 relative to
Electric Distribution Company market
share prohibiting certain electric rate
increases and requiring enforcement
against eversource and I will introduce
or I will ask to visit the testimony
table the prime sponsor of this
religious proposed legislation that's
representative Horrigan
welcome representative
thank you very much I'm representative
Timothy Horrigan from
from Durham and I'll just note uh behind
me one of my constituents
Mr Hall is here and he won't agree with
the bill I'm not sure all those I think
maybe a lot of his criticisms are well
taken but I think this uh I think just
builds a usually useful as a starting
off point um get us thinking more about
how to uh deal with eversource with the
corporate sector in general so
um it's a short bill and if passed I
think it would have so many drastic
consequences in fact I'll be I'm
um I have no idea where the 11 votes
needed to pass this bill out of
committee would come from but if I don't
if the bill didn't exist we'd get zero
so
um I think it some of those are going to
be pretty
would be pretty wrenching especially for
eversource but it's better than the
undesirable consequences call drones a
year it's over ever sources Monopoly
control of the Electric market here in
New Hampshire
and by the company Stranglehold over the
government institutions which are
supposed to regulate that market so for
years we've suffered from ever sources
high prices and mediocre service and as
well as uh
at least a certain amount of it's
continued obstruction of development of
renewable and sustainable energy and
just last year the research Got Away
doubling the price of electricity and uh
my opinion I'm not sure what whether
there was a good reason for that even
though we understand uh
um I'd like to understand we're a small
part of a regional uh Electric
market and we are part of iso and
everything at least we're still part of
iso I don't think you've passed that
bill pulling out yet so
proposed and spill are certainly doable
we have the power to to do them even if
this bill passes the law exactly is
introduced and I'm not sure if that's
going to happen I was actually surprised
it was just a short and simple bill but
um because I had a proposal that
a colleague got from one of his
constituents and actually that colleague
ended up not being on the Masthead of
the bill but um
and I was surprised the drafter just
drafted it pretty much as we presented
it to them of course that particular
drafter he was an excellent attorney but
it's I I will note for whatever it's
worth he retired about three weeks he
tired about a month after uh drafting
this bill but he was a very good
drafting attorney so
and uh so the Public Utility Commission
the primary energy already have the
power to Peg electric rate increases or
the rate of inflation
I mean I even I'll admit that's
problematic is like the Consumer Price
Index doesn't necessarily track what the
cost of producing Distributing
electricity but they already have the
power to do that the Justice power
already has the power to break up
monopolies such as eversource and I'm
not saying either those tasks are easy
like
like I said if I get 11 votes in this
committee I'll be as amazed as anybody
else but I might as well try
the there's many many fine details that
the various executive branch agencies
will have to work out but it can be done
and it could be done and I I'm an Ever
Source customer myself I appreciate the
service they provide me as especially uh
especially today when it's we're finally
getting some cold weather but if dill
passes or something or something based
on it
um I'm one of hundreds of thousands of
grand estate or should be paying what I
think is a much fairer price for this
essential service so uh
um I'm going to go ahead and urge you to
ought to pass on HB 633 it's uh your
bill it's in your possession now you're
certainly uh free to uh free to amend it
and I uh
I would not be I would not be surprised
if it ends up being various uh
effectively amended should you choose to
go forward with it so uh
that said I guess I can quickly take any
questions although I haven't had my
lunch yet and I have another bill coming
up pretty soon but you're welcome to ask
any questions
thank you representative for introducing
this legislation before you leave the
room would you submit a pin card of
course yes
haven't haven't written anything on it
but I will do so of course thank you
thank you appreciate that
do we have any questions from the
committee for the prime sponsor of this
legislation representative Wendy Thomas
has a question thank you very much Mr
chair
um thank you for being here
representative we've been hearing from
um
other agencies and and other Bill
sponsors that world events play into
higher prices
um so how would world events fit into
this bill
well if you pass it exactly it is the
world events Energy prices are already
Afflicted to CPI I mean I think
that's uh that's certainly true
especially the uh
conflict in the Ukraine that's been
going on for a year that's uh
that's going to continue to increase
energy prices and I think that's the
outbreak of that war is one of many
reasons they're never going to go down
as low as they were in the uh you know
in the during the during the pandemic
years but um you know
but as I guess but as I said still I
think this is a this is something
similar to it is a better idea than just
sort of the free-for-all we have now
we're pretty much the electric companies
uh just I think just set their own
prices uh basically so thank you thank
you
well seeing no further questions from
the committee I want to thank you for
introducing this legislation I urge you
to submit your pink card before you head
for lunch yeah and good luck with your
next bill introduction enjoy working
with it enjoy working on it so like if I
think there's a lot of good I think
there's a I think I think something good
will come out of this okay thank you
very much I'd next like to call to the
front of the room the representative
from the Department of energy Mr Griffin
Roberge
thank you Mr chairman uh Griffin robbery
uh State energy program manager at the
New Hampshire Department of energy the
department is opposed to this bill as
introduced department has significant
economic and legal concerns with the
bill as it's currently written
to provide some context to the committee
New Hampshire's electric distribution
utilities as part of RSA 374f that's the
electric restructuring statute do not
own generating assets or the resources
to produce electric power for the energy
sold to customers through
um default service those utilities
competitively solicit prices from
Regional generators for electric power
on the wholesale Market again through a
competitive solicitation the prices that
are received through that solicitation
reflect Wholesale Electric market
conditions and Electric utilities do not
make any profit from the sale of default
service what's important to know is that
the cost of default Energy service or
the cost of the power procured by the
utilities is directly passed through to
New Hampshire's electric consumers as I
stated electric utilities do not make
any return rate of return on those power
costs but they do make a rate of return
on the resources needed to distribute
and transmit that power to customers
once these solicitations conclude the
New Hampshire Public Utilities
Commission then conducts an adjudicative
proceeding to determine the utilities
electric rates this adjudication ensures
that the costs recover by the utilities
are prudently incurred and are are are
just fair and reasonable these terms
prudently incurred fair just and
reasonable are important as they are
significant legal terms that have been
built upon many years of legal precedent
these terms are the basis by which the
puc and other state regulators and other
states approve electric rates and the
utilities rate of return on their
Investments
um as I recall Tom Frantz our director
of regulatory support was here and
testified to the committee during our
other Department's presentations that
New Hampshire typically has an eight and
a half to a nine and a half percent
return on equity for public utilities
which tends to be in the middle to lower
portion of what other states typically
offer as a rate of return to their
utilities
looking specifically at the bill section
two of the bill requires that no
electric distribution utility in New
Hampshire shall be permitted to raise
its electric rates to customers by an
amount that exceeds the annual increase
in the Consumer Price Index put simply
this provision results in an
unconstitutional taking from Public
Utilities by way of background Public
Utilities offer a good that is
considered a public service that's the
availability of electricity costs for
utilities may go up to provide that
service but this bill would prohibit
them from recovering the cost to provide
that adequate electric service so for
example if in a year until these costs
go up six percent but they're only
prohibited from uh from getting a rate
of return of three percent because of
the Consumer Price Index they are out
three percent uh for an adequate rate of
return that in itself is an
unconstitutional taking under the under
the Constitution
um restricting the ability of utilities
to recover their costs will also likely
impact default service solicitations and
run the risk of failed default service
auctions leading to increased costs to
rate payers uh simply put public utility
rates are based on cost of service
regulation and this language would
likely run afoul of legal precedent
established in long-standing U.S Supreme
Court cases
um
section three of the bill requires that
no utility shall be permitted to have
more than 50 percent of the market share
in the state the thrust of this language
uh in the Department's eyes seems to
encourage competition amongst electric
distribution utilities by way of con by
way of background this was largely the
landscape of electrical markets back in
the early 1900s and if anyone needs a
refresher on what that looks like that's
where you had independent utilities
everybody has their own infrastructure
you have 16 or 17 different poles and
wires going down the road going down the
same road so this bill could potentially
return to that again that landscape was
when multiple utilities existed and
again when companies owned their old
pose of wires and if there is a return
to that there are significant legal and
economic and safety implications if that
if this language were to move forward
today's distribution utilities are
regulated natural monopolies that
control their own service territories
around the state I believe the committee
saw the puc's testimony earlier today
about
uh franchise territories those living in
a utility service territory get their
default service from that utility
whether it be eversource unitel Liberty
competition still does exist to some
degree consumers are obviously allowed
to seek out competitive Electric Supply
um to shop around and find more
attractive electric rates the actual
distribution of that power though is a
regulated Monopoly service
additionally the language in Section 3
is quite broad as it doesn't make any
mention as to how market share is
defined is that based on annual electric
electric sales is it based on the size
of a utility service territories that
are owned in the state
these are just at least um the concerns
that the department has identified with
this bill and that uh concludes my
testimony and I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you Mr Roberts representative
notter has a question
thank you Mr chairman it's a two-part
question one will you be sending us
um your testimony and can you please
repeat the part that you said about the
unconstitutionality of this bill sure so
uh I can these are just talking points
I've written up for myself but I can
certainly put them in an email and send
it to the committee later
um regarding the unconstitutionality of
the bill that's largely focused on
section two of the bill
um again the
cell this public utilities offer the
availability of electricity which is
deemed a public service they are allowed
to recover costs they're prudently
incurred at just fair and reasonable
rates the bill as its proposed indicates
that their own utilities are only
allowed every return up to the max of
the annual CPI if a utilities costs
incurred go up say six percent they
cannot recover any anything more than
what is established in the CPI of that
year
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Roberts for taking my question so when
you were talking about eversource uh
being potentially broken up uh you you
brought us back to the situation a
hundred years ago would it be possible
to break up ever Source into
fewer pieces than than the hundreds that
that might have been you know maybe two
or three pieces thank you for the
question I mean I imagine you might but
again
um you
you'd run signal you'd run into some
significant constitutional and economic
concerns with that and that it is their
infrastructure they'll likely need to be
a reimbursement for their infrastructure
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question
thank you Mr chair
um this is just a clarification question
I guess
um this is the second Bill where the
fiscal note has not been attached
um and it says due to time constraints
the office of legislative budget
assistant does is the doe holding up any
of these fiscal notes in any way I do
not know that but I can certainly uh
well first off thank you for the
question but I can certainly look into
that and follow back up with the
committee thank you very much
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in again
um
businesses lose money all the time
um and and suggesting that um
the
um you that that if the if the if the
utility lost money because of this
action
is an unconstitutional taking of
property that's a pretty significant
um
claim I mean is there precedent for that
yes so first off thank you for the
question
um under you know there's various uh
Supreme Court cases uh going back to the
1920s and the 1940s that really uh
established that regulated utilities
such as those operating in New Hampshire
today are entitled to a fair and
reasonable rate of return on their
Capital Investments to deliver electric
service to customers in the state
um those are I can certainly provide
cases in an email
um I'll be quite honest quite long
titles but um I can certainly follow up
with the committee with reference to
those cases if that's helpful
follow-up follow-up
um
but I guess what I what I'm what I'm
what I'm saying is that if this if this
bill passed
the the state would be setting what that
fair level of return would be correct
um so
you know that how can that then be
enough how could there then be an
unconstitutional taking of property
thank you and if the rate's been
determined so
under under these various cases and I'm
certainly no attorney I can I I can feel
him right over my shoulder Don creases I
know I'm going to answer this when he
gets up here but um what was it
um as I mentioned regulated utilities
are entitled to a reasonable opportunity
to recover their prudently incurred
costs that is vetted through puc
adjudications through whether it be
puc's here or similar processes in other
states
um they are entitled to prudently incur
uh recover those costs that they
incurred if the state then comes in and
says nope you're only established this
amount no more through any type of
adjudicative process that is determined
to be an unconstitutional under uh
taking
thank you
okay seeing no more questions from the
committee I want to thank you for
justifying the gifts bill
and I will call next to the front of the
room
Mr Michael Licata from eversource
who's requested four minutes and he
good afternoon uh
Michael Licata representing eversource
energy thank you for the opportunity to
testify before you today
um I'll keep my comments uh
fairly focused uh and and brief I think
Mr Roberts covered many of the points
that I was going to but I did want to
emphasize a few
um a few key factors so
by way a background again eversource
energy provides electric distribution
service to over 400 excuse me 540 000
homes and businesses throughout the
state of New Hampshire and on behalf of
the company and our 1500 employees who
live and work in the communities that
you represent I encourage you and
request that you find this legislation
in expedient to legislate as Mr robare
said
um the changes in section two of the
proposed Bill if passed would in fact
represent a violation of the Fifth
Amendment of the United States
Constitution as an illegal taking of
private property and that's not
something we say lightly uh that's not
something I I put forth lightly but
allow me to explain why that is the case
and I'll use the example uh
of our most recent I guess our default
service rate setting that occurred over
the summer
the utilities are directed by State
Statute and puc order to competitively
procure default surface on behalf of our
customers
what that means is every six months we
are required to issue rfps for load
following Energy service for our
customers we issued those rfps into the
competitive Marketplace as Mr Roberts
discussed we receive responses back
we select the lowest cost response from
a viable bidder that is then filed to
the Public Utilities Commission that
reviews the competitive process and
ultimately approves the rate based upon
that response
the utility has little to no control
over the responses that get that it
receives back from the competitive
Marketplace nor does the Public
Utilities Commission
and those costs as Mr Robert said are
directly passed through to our customers
without any markup or profit margin
associated with them
over the summer we did that normal
solicitation and because of high cost of
natural gas market uncertainty driven by
global market forces we saw the costs we
received back from the competitive
Marketplace change from our current rate
at the time
of 10.6 cents to 22.5 cents
which is almost a doubling of the rate
utility again has an obligation under
State Statute to provide default Service
as a financial as a safety net to its
customers
we have an obligation to provide that
service
if this bill were passed at the time
the law would have said even though you
have competitively sourced this product
on behalf of your cost customers
following State Statute and puc Order
you are not allowed to recover your
costs associated with that above the
percentage of the federally set Consumer
Price Index
there would be a significant gap between
the cost the utility incurred to provide
default service
and the cost that we were allowed to
recover through rates
that is a taking
and the utility would go bankrupt
and certainly the state of New Hampshire
has experience with this and its
customers
this is not an area that we
tread lightly on
uh this is significant legislation
that we hope the committee takes very
seriously
uh many of the things that the bill
sponsor said are factually incorrect
about what this bill does
what the state of New Hampshire has
control over in these areas and the
effects of this bill
moving on to the other two parts of the
bill
the first
would prohibit any one entity from
serving more than 50 percent of the
market share of the State of New
Hampshire
as Mr Roberts pointed out
the term market share is not defined
which is very important
whether that means the geographic area
of the state whether that means the
sales of electricity within the state
whether that means customer account in
the state and I would note that two of
those three items do change over time
finally the bill directs the Attorney
General to begin action against
eversource by name
to quote
restore Market competition in New
Hampshire
this appears to stem from the inaccurate
understanding of utility distribution
service
utilities function as natural monopolies
because it is less expensive for a
single entity to provide a service in a
specific area than it would be to have
multiple entities providing that same
service in place of Market competition
because of this
we are heavily regulated
by State uh by the Public Utilities
Commission of the state that is the
entity that reviews all of our costs
expenses Capital Investments to
determine whether those were prudently
incurred before setting the rate to
recover those costs
the idea that small a larger number of
smaller utilities will drive Market
competition is incorrect
you would simply have a larger number of
smaller utilities
the idea that a larger number of smaller
utilities would reduce cost is unfounded
as well there are significant benefits
from having
efficiency of resources due to a larger
utility that would be unrealized
for these reasons we respectfully asked
the committee to find this legislation
in expedient to legislate and I would be
very happy to answer any questions that
I can
from the committee
thank you for your important testimony
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um you said that you send out rfps every
six months uh to determine rates is
there anything keeping you from sending
them out more often than that yes
uh the manner in which we procure
default service is defined in puc order
26092 which is based upon RSA 374f colon
3C
all right thank you representative
Corman has a question
great minds think alike I guess any
further questions for
Mr locata seeing none I thank you very
much
and I call to the front of the room
Mr Don creese from the office of the
consumer advocate
who will
Enlighten us
as to why he supports this bill
uh thank you Mr chairman just to
reintroduce myself briefly I'm Donald
crease the consumer Advocate and as I
think you all know by now my job is to
represent the interests of residential
utility customers
um I I thought it would be useful uh to
come to the defense of poor old
representative Horrigan who I've never
met before I didn't recognize him until
he walked into the room and I and I
didn't agree with the disparaging
comment he made at the beginning of his
presentation about eversource or
corporations in general I I don't think
it's helpful to treat anyone or anything
as if it's inherently evil and I don't
think corporations or eversource are
evil but I but I have a lot of sympathy
for uh the concern or I'll just say I
share the concern that drove him to
introduce this bill and and he here is
why I'm just going to Rattle off a bunch
of prices for you uh now as you know
default Energy service is the price that
you pay for the electricity that comes
out of your wires and you pay that under
the Paradigm that was adopted by the
legislature in
1996 of electric industry restructuring
and so I'm just going to Rattle off the
prices I know about the New Hampshire
Electric Co-op has what it calls Co-op
power that's its default Energy service
that's 13 cents a kilowatt hour
the main Public Utilities Commission
which is in charge of what they call
Standard offer in Maine so they do the
procurement and then they tell the
utilities what to charge the two prices
they set for this year are depending on
which of the two big utilities you're a
customer of 16 cents or 17 cents a
kilowatt hour these are rounded off
numbers
eversources price is 20 cents a kilowatt
hour Liberty Utilities price is 22 cents
a kilowatt hour and unitils price is 26
cents per kilowatt hour and that doesn't
even take into account the other
components of everybody's electric bills
meaning the separate charges that you
pay for distribution service the poles
and wires and the transmission grid
Transmission Service which is uh high
voltage so so electricity prices have
shot through the roof and we are in a
state of Crisis people are suffering and
we have this one product default Energy
Service that all of these utilities that
each has been required to divest of
their generation assets are going to the
same market and buying and yet the
Prices range from a low of 13 cents at
the New Hampshire Electric Co-op all the
way up to 26 Cents at Unitil I agree
with representative Horrigan that
something is wrong and it would be a
good idea for the general court to
figure out what's wrong and then try to
fix it now I do agree with my friends Mr
Roberts and Mr locata
that we have a constitutional problem
here uh and as they've already explained
to you when you basically tell a utility
that it is not allowed to recover it's
prudently incurred costs what you have
done in effect has what you've
effectively done is taken the
shareholders property and confiscated it
and apportioned it to public use without
just compensation that violates the
Fifth Amendment to the U.S Constitution
and its state analog and the industry
term for that phenomenon is called
confiscatory rates that that simply is
not okay we might want to do it but if
we tried it uh Not only would the
utility go bankrupt but it would file a
lawsuit long before bankruptcy and they
would win in federal court
um but I I think it's an overstatement
to say that there is nothing that can be
done short of imposing confiscatory
rates this morning you heard
commissioner Simpson of the puc talk to
you about natural monopoly but the
natural monopoly is not as pervasive and
permanent as you might think it is and I
have an example and and this goes to the
other part of this bill that talks about
the uh Monopoly nature of eversource and
its counterparts and their market share
uh I I think it might be a good idea to
go after their Monopoly but I wouldn't
carve it up geographically I would carve
it up uh I guess functionally and and
here's what I'm really thinking about
the natural monopoly in meters if there
ever was one is crumbling there is no
reason why your local Distribution
Company whether it's eversource Unitil
Liberty or the co-op should be should
have an absolute
Monopoly on the meters some of you might
be old enough to remember when in order
to have a telephone you had to rent a
telephone
from the local Bell Telephone Company uh
that that was done in by the U.S justice
department in the 1980s and it is time
to do exactly the same thing with meters
there's just no reason why another
company can't Supply you with a utility
grade meter and the reason the utilities
don't want to do that the reason
eversource I think doesn't want to do
that is because that surrenders a key
part of the utilities hegemony and
eversource has notably dragged its feet
on deploying Advanced metering
infrastructure in this state yesterday
over in the Senate they took credit for
the fact that they are now conducting a
study of the feasibility of Ami
deployment Advanced metering
infrastructure deployment why are they
doing that because I insisted that they
do that as a condition of my signature
on the settlement agreement that
resolved their last rate case but every
other utility in the state is farther
ahead than eversource is on Advanced
metering infrastructure that is a
problem
this morning you heard from the puc
Commissioners and they talked about
default service and what they're doing
about it and they mentioned that they
have an open investigation that's true
but we've known that this has been a
crisis for over a year now and so far
nothing has happened it appears that the
puc's attention was focused on the
report that they just issued which uh I
I think
was intended to undermine the case for
continuing to have rate payer funded
energy and efficiency in New Hampshire
what they really should be focusing on
is default Energy service because we
need to change the way that we procure
default Energy service and I think since
this is a public policy problem it is a
subject that is ripe for you the general
court to consider and I have a modest
proposal I think it is time to do all of
the default Energy Service procurement
at the same time essentially in the same
room much as they do in Maine where the
main puc does it here in New Hampshire
we could have the state department of
energy do it and we could even
completely change the Paradigm and
instead of putting out requests for
proposals we could actually do a
descending clock live auction so that
the bidders can kind of eyeball each
other and that might reduce the whopping
big risk premium that we're all paying
to compensate the wholesale suppliers
for the uncertainty that they perceive
in the in the market I guess the last
thing I want to say by way of my
testimony today is that there actually
is a case it's appeal of Public Service
Company of New Hampshire it's reported
at page 13 of volume 141 of the New
Hampshire reporter it was decided in
1996 and it says that electric utility
franchises are not exclusive now it
would be ridiculously inefficient to
build out a redundant Distribution
Systems in New Hampshire that's why
nobody wants to do it but the utilities
even though they would like you to think
that they have guaranteed cost recovery
and an iron climate Ironclad Monopoly
neither of those things is true the
Constitution simply secures to the
utilities a right for a reasonable
opportunity to earn a reasonable return
on their investment it is not guaranteed
and it is theoretically possible for
competitors to come in and actually
challenge the district attribution
companies monopolies
oh I think that is everything I wanted
to cover I promised I would do it in
four minutes I have a feeling I failed
I wasn't timing you but I have a feeling
you failed as well
I'm going to ask you a question though
about something that you did mention
just a moment ago and that was
removing the Monopoly on metering
if we did that
would we end up with a kind of a wild
west situation where we would have all
kinds of different mismatched meters all
over the place and how would the
utilities cope with that that's a really
excellent question so thank you for
asking me that chairman Vose and I I
think the answer is that I would not
suggest that we open up the Wild West
it's important for uh every meter that's
used for electric service be so-called a
so-called utility grade meter so there
are technical technical standards
because obviously we need our electric
service to be accurately and properly
metered and it would be I think
appropriate for the regulator it would
either here be either the department of
energy or the puc to actually scrutinize
which specific uh which specific meters
are authorized for use in New Hampshire
and since you asked about this
um
one of the reasons for taking a look at
the meter Monopoly is the Advent of
electric vehicles because electric
vehicles are great grid resources right
they're big batteries they tend to sit
in our driveways or parking garages for
about 90 plus percent of the time and
while they're idle while we're not
driving them they are potential grid
resources and the auto manufacturers
either are or can include utility grade
meters right in the cars
so to follow up on that question
foreign
purchase of any utility grade meter fall
on the customer
and if it did wouldn't that eliminate
the uh
the buying power that a big organization
like a utility could have to lower the
cost of those meters
well I I thank you for that question too
uh and I think I have two different
answers I mean my first plenary answer
to almost every question I get is that
at the end of the day there's only one
wallet in the room and that is the
wallet in the back pocket of the
ratepayer so no matter what we do in
order to regulate energy
it's only customers who are going to pay
all the costs eventually every company
that provides any part of this service
to customers is going to expect to
recover its costs from those customers
but in response to your specific
question I'm not necessarily saying that
the customer has to be the owner of the
meter I'm saying that we should give the
customers choice you might you might
want to well you might you might live in
a community power aggregation community
and your community power aggregator
whether it's the community power
Coalition of New Hampshire or some other
aggregate aggregator it ought to be able
to supply you with the meter that's what
I mean by the utility shouldn't have
them on Monopoly maybe cpcnh has I'm
sure if you brought Cliff Below in here
he could tell you a great idea for how
you know his organization should deploy
the meter and they can use it to do all
kinds of cool things that aren't
provided by the utility and then they
can report the usage data reliably to
the utility and then either the
Coalition or the utility will render the
bill so that the utility actually gets
its money
thank you and I want to apologize to the
members of the committee I violated one
of our sacrosync committee rules which
is uh to talk about things that are not
directly related to the bill which I
just did but it was such a fascinating
question to me I just had to ask it but
I will remind members that we're here to
ask questions related to the bill
thank you Mr chairman so
um
metering although I'm not part of the
bill is one of the issues that you
brought up that needs to be addressed
and the implication of your discussion
was that if we had utilities not owning
The Meters we're going to get a
reduction in cost yet you raised the
costs default costs of the of the three
utilities eversource was lowest
Liberty and utility were the highest
they're the ones that have the the have
the the new technology in the meters so
how do you display
um reconcile what seems to be your your
point with the facts uh thank you
representative that's another really
good question and the answer is that the
cost of the meters is not recovered
through the default Energy service
charge the utilities are recovering
their metering costs in their
distribution charges so the fact that
the companies are doing different things
in the metering realm has no bearing on
the costs that they are charging for
default service that's really a function
of their interaction with the wholesale
market and so the reason for example the
Electric Co-op has advanced metering
they led the way with Advanced metering
infrastructure in New Hampshire but
that's not the reason their price is low
the reason their price is low is that
they are actively managing their default
Energy Service portfolio and you heard
the word laddering this morning that's a
big part of what that kind of active
management uh entails I hope that was an
adequate answer but you're about to ask
a follow-up so maybe it wasn't follow-up
follow-up because it goes to what you
just said the the co-op is allowed to
ladder yet you heard Mr locata say that
the utilities are not allowed to do that
they are required by puc regulation and
I heard statute I didn't realize that
right that that order came out of the
statute
but if that is indeed the case what
you're proposing is not possible
well I want to give eversource it's due
here because uh first of all the statute
RSA 374f does not require a particular
method of procurement the method of
procurement that the utilities are now
required to use was imposed on them by
puc order and and I'm not this is no
criticism of the three Commissioners who
were here this morning this happened way
before they appeared on the scene at
least way before they became
Commissioners and so the previous puc
actually several pucs ago told
eversource over its objection I think
the record will show that it had to do
its procurement this way they wanted to
be a more Vigilant market player and
they were told they couldn't
so if you want to blame somebody it's
the old puc and that has the advantage
of being nobody that we're able to uh
criticize now here right in the room
thank you representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you for taking my question I would I
want to maybe get back to the default
service rate I'm not sure I'm going to
with this question but you mentioned a
risk premium
that where that rate payers are paying
is that something that is built in to
the default service rate by the
utilities or is that where does that
risk premium come from uh that risk
premium is embedded in the bids that
wholesale suppliers provide to the
utilities in response to their rfps
every six months because really what
restructuring does is it takes a pile of
risk and it reallocates it takes it off
the back of rate payers essentially and
puts it on the back of these uh
competitive wholesale suppliers and in
order to uh agree to take on the risk
they include a premium in the bids that
they make
follow-up if I make
is uh is that risk premium differ
according to utilities or is that
something determined by the puc the puc
doesn't determine the risk premium that
is entirely up to the bidders and
remember what we're talking about here
is a market process right it's a
competitive bidding process so uh nobody
but the bidders knows how they decided
on what their bids would be I mean I I
see some confidential information about
the bids they're a little more granular
than gets talked about here because they
actually propose a series of monthly
prices that are then aggregated and you
can see that you know that the different
bidders have different ideas of what the
right monthly price is and that reflects
their prognostications about what's
going to happen in the Electric market
in the six months covered by their bids
and they also have to worry about
default Energy Service migration because
people have the right to go away leave
default service and either go on
competitive Supply or if they're in a
community power aggregation Community
they have the right to participate in
their Community power aggregation that
is another form of risk to these
wholesale suppliers
okay
before I call on representative munz for
another question I'm going to make an
announcement that I think all the
members will be interested in hearing
this announcement comes from the
speaker's office
due to the severe weather we are
currently experiencing speaker Packard
is recommending that legislators who are
parked at the storage Street Garage
park closer to the state house and the
lob before the temperature drops further
and the wind picks up
if you are parked at the store Street
Garage today please feel free to take a
break at your convenience to go move
your car closer
we currently have space in the upper lob
garage which is accessible via Capitol
Street
and in various Street spaces around the
complex which are identified by the
yellow legislative bags Protective
Services can assist you in finding a
space if you have any trouble
so this is a service that the speaker's
office is offering to members feel free
if you want to get up and leave and go
get your car and move it closer we will
be here quite late tonight we have an
executive session starting at four
o'clock
we have four five bills rather on the
schedule and a potential sixth Bill
might be added so we could be here till
six o'clock and I don't know what the
weather will be like at six o'clock but
apparently it's going to be bad
so
um
that offer has been made feel free to
use your own judgment to decide whether
to take uh advantage of it or not
okay now representative munz let's try
to make this the last question on this
bill or for this uh testifier because we
have three more people who want to
justify thank you Mr chairman I I had a
wonderful follow-up to Chairman boss's
question about meters but in deference
to the rules I'm not going to ask that
one my question hopefully is pretty
straightforward if we want to we the
legislature wanted to enable
uh eversource to go out for bids on a
more frequent basis than every six
months would we need to amend RSA 374f
my answer is that is likely the place
where you would want to insert language
to that effect yes you you wouldn't need
to amend because right now the puc has
the authority to tell the utilities to
do that and I I think that's the nature
of their investigation but you know I'm
frustrated because there's a lot of
delay here nothing has happened yet the
next procurement period is looming upon
us because those rfps have to go out
really just a few weeks from now and so
we're not going to change anything in
connection with the next six months so
we're really not looking at any change
until next February a year from now I'm
frustrated and so that's why I'm
suggesting that the legislature maybe
actually do something like what you are
at least implying you could do
quick follow-up quick follow-up
um
so
if we don't necessarily have to amend
that RSA what do we need to do to do we
need then need to change the the powers
or authorizations that the puc has
you could do it any number of ways I
think the recommendation I would make if
I were to put my drafting cap on would
be to insert some language in RSA 374f
that tells the puc here is how we the
general court want the utilities to do
this I think it is an occasion for a
rather
muscular
definition
muscular exercise of public policy
Authority by the legislature thank you
okay thank you I think we need to move
on at this point uh so I'm going to ask
for the next presenter to come forward
and that's Kristen Coke from the
business and industry Association thank
you Mr chairman it's been a pleasure
thank you
oh Kristen I've known a lot of people
who had the last name Koch in my
lifetime some people pronounce it Coke
some people pronounce it Koch what's
your preferred pronunciation I pronounce
it Koch Koch okay thank you I apologize
for missing that the first time oh
that's okay well if you ask my German
relative they would pronounce it
differently too okay
welcome thank you
um so for the record my name is Kirsten
Koch director of public policy for the
business and industry Association also
known as Bia come before you today to
register at bia's opposition to House
Bill 633 and we oppose this bill for
three reasons first reason is because it
would constitute an unconstitutional
taking of a private company's property
without just compensation I think the
previous speakers have touched on that
and elaborated brilliantly so I will
keep it brief our second concern with
the bill is that it directs the Attorney
General to take legal action against a
specifically named private company
that's in good standing in the state of
New Hampshire and we believe this bill
is a deliberate attempt to intervene the
judicial process it sets this Broad and
damaging precedent undermining the
rights and Liberties of New Hampshire
businesses it's really a red flag for
the business community that you know a
piece of legislation can just direct
judicial action and our third concern
is that mandating a customer cat for an
electric Distribution Company would not
necessarily lower costs for ratepayers
um you know each utility has their own
designated Service Company they don't
compete with each other in this way so
there's no evidence that a greater
number of smaller utilities would
necessarily lower cost for rate payers
we would respectfully ask the committee
to find House Bill 633 in expedient to
legislate as a tier so thank you and I'd
be happy to try to answer any questions
seeing none I thank you for uh
presenting us with your testimony thank
you
and thank you for providing written
testimony as well appreciate that
next up I'll call on
Wendy hunt from the Nashua Chamber of
she had to step away so
we'll hold on to that one for a second
she did submit written testimony each of
you should have a copy of her written
testimony
no no that's her she gave us one from
Manchester and Nashua and in
first
well she represents the Nashua chamber
is this not her her testimony then from
she signed it
she's the president and CEO
so
okay
all right we got that
so next up is Bill Hall from Durham
who's representing himself and he
uh
and we recognize
German boss
um
I do
okay
um yes I posed the bill for many of the
reasons stated here today and so I won't
go into them uh one thing I did observe
after being an electrician for 40 years
uh the meters have a number of roles and
it's very important for the power
company to own all for a power company
to own the meter own the socket and own
the wire down to it you'll sometimes see
multimeter places where there's a
stainless steel ring around the meter
with a special lock there are all kinds
of reasons administrative reasons for
that I didn't want to get into that
though uh I'm going in a slightly
different direction and uh and I'll I'll
try to be very brief
uh all of the things that have been
discussed here
are on one side of the issue
there's another side of the issue of
getting the power here
and this last summer uh the uh
uh governors of all the New England
states all six of them had a meeting
and they came up with two pages and a
half two pages of recommendations
and they sent it to the Secretary of
Energy with all their signatures and a
couple of points about how to keep the
prices low now this one they saw this
coming this this is dated July
they got back a return from the
Secretary of Energy
uh
which is uh
in my opinion two and a half pages of
nonsense they have no intention of
helping us whatsoever and I defy you in
the last six months to point out how
the result of that letter
uh on October 27th
eversource sent a letter
uh the head of eversource for New
England
a very good letter
and in it
he describes how to keep the electric
rates down none of this nonsense between
how they
how they bid it or anything else which
is very important and some of the things
that were said here have have
really have to be borne out really have
to take a look at but what Nolan said
was four bullet points this one on page
two
three more bullet points on page three
he sent it to the president of the
United States
every single legislator in this state
should be demanding action on this the
other five states and our delegation as
far as I can tell our delegation in
Washington hasn't lifted a finger to
help the people that elected him well
the people that pay for these rates with
their wallet in their back pocket
oh and by the way
we've got to take this seriously because
remember the legislator four years ago
legislature four years ago bankrupted
the power cut public service over the
Seabrook Nuclear Plant
notice to see the nuclear pad has been
the most productive plant of any nuclear
plant in this country probably the world
two it costs twice as much because we
got one plant but we paid for two all
the infrastructure for the second plant
and all the equipment showed up in
Seabrook we just didn't put it all
together and get power from it so our
electric rates went to the highest in
not only New England but all of the
associated States particularly Long
Island New York and um uh it was a
rather painful experience and so I don't
want to see the legislature going down
the road of where they're going to start
doing things that could be uh not in the
best interest Public Service one last
thing
uh in my area uh public service has done
a wonderful job of upgrading their lines
putting in Hendrick's cable the TR the
transformer in Madbury the lines to it
they've done a lot of work the one thing
that needs some attention possibly
legislative attention
is to make sure that towns are not
difficult in about the trimming
the power company has to go on Scenic
roads has to go to the planning board
which they did in Durham a friend of
mine in Durham Point who was 80 uh 90
excuse me and I went and we got a
unanimous vote out of the out of the
planning board to cut do the The Cutting
on Durham Point Road they started
cutting the administrator unilaterally
sent him home he doesn't have the
authority to do that that's State
Statute that's by the planning board uh
recently he was on channel nine and uh
uh there were he said there were 50 line
trucks in Durham and half the town was
without power because the branches were
coming down on the wires so that is an
area that needs attention the power
company has has now spending 50 000 50
million dollars a year and a hundred
tree Crews to try to keep this from
happening if they start getting hit
financially these are the things that
are going to be hurt was the trimming
and the upgrades
thank you Mr Voss
okay thank you for your testimony Mr
Hall do we have any questions for Mr
Hall
seeing none I want to thank you for
being here
making the Trek over from Durham we
appreciate your presence
I have no other pink cards except for
that by Miss Wendy hunt but apparently
she's not going to make it back so we're
going to uh
forego her
opportunity to speak is there anyone
else who is in the audience who has not
had a chance to speak who would like to
seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 633 and ask
representative closure to give us a
report on the blue sheet
thank you chairman Bulls
House Bill
633 FN
blue sheet was
none in favor
for opposed
online
it was 33 in support
59 opposed one neutral
thank you
okay thank you so let me get a sense
from the committee how many people would
like to take a break so you can go get
three okay I will open the public
hearing on House Bill 139 and
call a break for 15 minutes
I think that would be enough
to run fast okay
you'd be better off to run anyway
because you can generate some heat that
way
all right I'd like to resume the public
hearing on HB 139 and I would like to
introduce representative Thomas Corman
who will introduce the bill for the
prime sponsor representative Jackie
cretienne who is still recovering from
uh a broken ankle I suspect so
representative Corman please introduce
this Bill thank you Mr chairman for the
record I am Thomas Corman a
representative from
Grafton 15 which is Ward 3 of the city
of Lebanon and yes I am filling in for
representative cretian who unfortunately
can't be here
so this is about HB 139 this is a bill
intended to address oversights in HB 315
from last session amending RSA
362-a specifically section 1A
and there are two changes that this bill
would do
the first is allowing neighboring
municipalities to share projects under
net metering so that if two towns or
more than two towns or municipalities
wish to collaborate on a project that
has net metering they can you can
imagine a situation where you have a
large municipality that would have a
high electric load but maybe little
space in which to put something like a
solar array
we wants to put one and there's a
neighboring municipality with a lower
population a lower load but has space
the idea is that they could actually
combine forces and have uh be one
Municipal host together
uh the bill also clarifies that the
entire State of New Hampshire housing
authorities peas and quasi-public
entities such as public colleges
universities or community colleges are
considered political subdivisions for
the purpose of eligibility for these net
metered energy projects under the five
megawatt cap
now it turns out that a bill clarifying
what a municipal host is was introduced
last session is SB 259 it was bipartisan
in both the House and Senate it had 11
Senate sponsors the primary Senate
sponsor was a republican uh and it
passed the Senate there was an interim
study and somehow it died after that I
wasn't here so I don't know the
particulars of it
that's really all I have to say but I
also want to head off one question that
might come up which is when we look at
the bill what the bill is doing is it's
striking text in lines six seven and
eight this this
parenthetical line a municipal host
shall be located in the same
municipality as all group members if the
facility began operation after January 1
2021 and I actually asked representative
cretian you know do you know why that
was in there and she did not and I don't
I don't know why that would have been in
there but it seems like it makes sense
to remove it and with that I'm ready to
attempt to answer questions
representative Bernardi will
give you a question
so you can attempt to answer it
thank you Mr chair
um so this bill I think suffers from one
of the same questions I had last year is
defining what a qualified Housing
Authority is because that could be
almost anything and even more broadly
what is a quasi-public entity I think
these terms being undefined is a major
defect in this bill and I like
explanation of
how we deal with that
thank you representative Bernardi so as
I mentioned uh examples of quasi-public
entities would be things like public
colleges universities community colleges
so entities that are run under the Aegis
of some Public Authority but aren't
necessarily a city or a town or an
agency thereof
follow up
follow up so I agreed a lot last year
that was a similar comment yet
definitionally it was not in the
proposal and therefore legally
someone trying to apply this law could
come up with their own definition of
whatever they thought these were so that
I I see that as a defect how would you
correct this thank you
um I'll make note of that for possible
amendment I would discuss it with
representative cretian
thank you
further questions for representative
Corman
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you um you just
definitely defined quasi-public do you
have a definition for Housing Authority
do I have a definition for Housing
Authority I do not okay um that's not
really my area of expertise
representative nodder has made some hot
chocolate and particularly those of you
who recently were in the cold if you uh
but like some hot chocolate please Avail
yourself before it gets cold
[Music]
and we thank representative Nutter for
being so thoughtful to all of us
Mr chairman
yes representative Munds I do have to
ask will we will we be given special
dispensation
um you know regarding the rule of now
open containers on our desk
yes we're going to make an exception due
to the weather
thank you
thank you thank you anybody else want
some
while everyone is availing themselves of
the
um
hot chocolate
I will just mention that you
representative Corbin Corman questioned
the parenthetical
the the phrase was subsequently stricken
by this by this proposed legislation the
reason it was put in there was to
prevent and uh expansion of
uh net metering facilities across the
state
um
it was felt at the time that the that
the legislation was originally written
that
the expansion of net metering needs to
be very carefully managed
and by allowing
municipalities to cross Municipal lines
it could accelerate the expansion of net
metering too quickly
which would be detrimental to ratepayers
long term so that's the reason it was
put into the legislation to begin with
thank you chairman Bose I would note
though of course that there's still the
five megawatt cap per Municipal host
maybe I didn't unders explain it
adequately so yes there is a five
megawatt cap
but by restricting it to
the municipal host to the single
municipality it would restrict the
number of towns that could expand to
five megawatts so in that way it
prevents a rapid proliferation of net
metering
which could be detrimental to rate bears
okay do we have any further questions
um if I may yeah um it's unclear
entirely how how detrimental net
metering is to rate payers there are
certainly some places where where it's
an advantage in that it's the the
electricity is now being produced closer
to where it's being used and that cuts
down distribution and transmission costs
and of course we're all interested in
having the electricity produced as
locally as possible
well they recently completed value of
distributed energy resources study
indicated that 1 to 1.5 percent of costs
for net metering are shifted to non-net
metering customers and other Studies
have shown that that relatively low
percentage is the direct result of a
relatively low penetration of solar
within the electricity Marketplace as
that
penetration grows so does the percentage
of cost shifting
and some Studies have shown that for
example once solar gets up to be 15 or
20 percent penetration in the grid the
cost shifting would be comparable and
that's a burden that we want to make
sure we manage very very carefully so
that rate payers are not unduly burdened
in the future
you have to remember that people at the
lowest end of the income scale
are hurt more than anybody else by an
increasing cost of energy
as much as 40 percent of a low-income
person's
income goes to pay for electricity heat
and transportation fuel so it's it's
incumbent upon us as legislators as we
try to deal with these issues to make
sure we don't hurt the most vulnerable
of our constituents
we have to manage the growth of these
okay
so you know further questions for
representative Corman
I'll call the next
person who would like to give us some
testimony on this bill and that's the
department of Energy's Griffin Roberge
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee Griffin Roberts again from New
Hampshire Department of energy I'm the
state energy program manager the
department is respectfully opposed to
House Bill 139 as introduced the bill
does as uh representative Corman
indicated makes changes to the municipal
host statute as folks on this committee
might know the statute permits a
customer generator or a municipal host
of more than one megawatt but less than
five to serve as a group host for a
variety of members that consist
exclusively of political subdivisions
those political sub the term political
subdivision is defined on lines nine to
twelve and Municipal hosts themselves
may be publicly or privately owned
um as I reference political subdivision
is defined as the state of New Hampshire
or any City Town County School District
chartered Public School Etc the statute
obviously was created under house bill
315 in 2021 and was modified uh by House
Bill 1258 last year to include the state
of New Hampshire as a political
subdivision
um House Bill 139 proposes to remove
language on lines six to eight that
require a municipal host to be located
in the same municipality as all of its
group members if that facility began
operation after January 1 of 21.
um in essence this change as is proposed
in the bill would allow for new
constructed uh generation serving as a
municipal host to have group members
outside of the same municipality as a
host so
an example you got a three megawatt
array in Bow they could potentially uh
take on group members in neighboring
communities provided obviously that
they're all within the same franchise
territory
um as we noted on House Bill 161 we do
want to stress to policymakers that
sizable changes to net metering statute
may not be warranted at this time as the
puc currently has an ongoing docket
under de
22-060
to consider changes to the current net
metering tariff structure including
compensation to customer generators we
again would suggest that policy makers
let this process and the docket play out
through a full adjudication with
interested stakeholders before making
any substantial changes to the state's
net metering statute
further down below the bolded language
on lines 10 to 11
it expands the eligible entities who
could be considered political
subdivisions or group members again
under the statute as it did last year
doe does want to express concern with
the use of the phrase quasi-public
entity the phrase is not defined
anywhere in statute and it could
certainly present confusion to the
department as we review Municipal host
applications to the department which we
have to approve
further Clarity I think would be needed
there you know is the entity receiving
Public Funding is it privately owned but
serving a public purpose
um you know in that different parties
could make different arguments as to
what quasi-public entity means some
other considerations is housing
authorities
um and I I'll I have to fall on the
sword here I just did a quick Google
search back in the room looking for the
number of housing authorities this bill
might apply to the number I came to was
17 but I may be off on that and then the
other thing I wanted to raise is it's my
understanding and I certainly welcome
any feedback from anybody who lives in
the Seacoast area peas Development
Authority I believe stretches across the
municipal boundaries in both Portsmouth
and Newington uh okay
noted
um so if that's the case obviously if
the language on lines six to eight
um were to go for the long with peas
Development Authority I imagine that
there would be an accommodation for
municipal uh for political subdivisions
to cross those boundaries between
Portsmouth and Newington however if line
six to eight
um that deletion on line six to eight
does not occur in peace Development
Authority is retained in there that
would likely create a little bit of
conflict again because you have
stretching across Portsmouth and
Newington
um
beyond that that really concludes my
testimony oh and for context as I
mentioned Municipal hosts need to be
registered with the New Hampshire
Department of energy since the bill
passed there are 10 registered Municipal
hosts in the state
um and I'm happy to take any questions
that folks have
excellent testimony questions
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair uh you
mentioned that the puc is going to be
creating a report or a decision on on on
this can you can you tell me when that
is expected sure and thank you for the
question I believe
um
I believe
um the puc released a an order or a
notice the other day kind of outlining
their schedule as to
um the various events that will occur in
their adjudicative proceeding I can
certainly follow up with the committee
on that I don't recall the dates off the
top of my head follow-up
follow-up but but yet you're you're
asking the legislative
um
body to hold off on any kind of a
decision or action sure and thank you
for the question so
um obviously policymakers can do as they
wish obviously if uh if committee
members or policy makers feel that this
bill should go for it as is that is
their prerogative obviously it's just we
would uh respectfully just urge uh
policymakers to consider letting that
process play out before making uh
representative Kaplan has a question
yeah thanks for taking Mike uh thank you
Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question
um I'm just a little bit curious about
the uh the difference between uh the
geographic range of of Municipal house
and the um
the argument that that would
that would increase the the penetration
of of say solar into our our power
system I mean
it's how is that possible if it's a five
megawatt cap I'm just kind of returning
to the point that that the
representative was making sure and and
thank you for the question I think the
language on line six to eight indicate
that a municipal host shall be located
in the same municipality as all group
members if the facility began operation
after January 1 of 2021 so under the
current statute
all member unless your facility uh if
you're still if your facility began
operation after that date you can only
serve group members within the context
of your municipality so if I'm a
municipal host and I'm in BO I can only
serve group members if they're located
within the municipality of Beau
um you might have had more Legacy I
guess you could say customer generators
such as Hydro facilities who existed
well before
um January 1 of 2021 who under the
current language have the ability to
serve members outside of Municipal
boundaries the department was not in
creation around the time that this this
bill came about but it is my
understanding that the language on six
online six to eight were meant to be
somewhat of a limitation of pending the
outcome of the vder study in the puc's
adjudicated proceedings I hope that
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
for uh trying to help us understand all
this
um I I may have read this incorrectly
which is entirely possible
but I as I understood it what we were
trying to do here was provide a a group
say
um the city of Manchester
um who wants to have a net metering
facility but doesn't have the land in
their town in their City yep to place
that facility someplace outside of of
their of their town make it you know
excuse me you know rent rent the land
enter into a contractual Arrangement and
have the facility be there but it would
still only provide support to the people
that are part of that group sure it's
not trying to expand the group it's just
trying to give
give
municipal or give give groups the
opportunity to
give them more flexibility where they
can locate the host sure so thank you
for the question I'll unpack that a
little bit so in regards to the
Manchester example under the 10 that are
registered in the state Manchester does
have a municipal house registered in the
state as well as Milton Berlin Gorham
Hillsborough Canaan bosquin Hooksett
Penacook and Durham
um regard I think the easiest way to
kind of view the statute is when the
municipal house became active was it
before January 1 of 2021 or after
January of 20 or January of 2021. if you
became in operation before then you have
the ability to reach out to group
members outside of your Municipal
boundaries if you come into operation
after 2021 after January of 2021
it the language I would agree is is
limiting in a way but it requires that
if your Municipal host and you become an
operation after a January of 2021 you
can only serve members within the
immediate boundaries of the municipal of
the municipality that the host operates
in so again citing say Manchester as an
example and don't write this down or
anything like that I have to do further
specify on specificity on who their
exact members are but hypothetically you
if Manchester has say Hydro facility
that existed prior to January of 2021
they could have group members that are
in municipalities outside of the
immediate Manchester boundaries if it
was a solar array that came into
operation in Manchester after January of
2021 it could only serve group members
within Manchester itself I hope that
makes sense
that makes sense but I don't think that
was what I was what I would where I was
going with this and again I may be
misinterpreting this but I I
you keep you keep talking about being
able to bring in more members yep you
know surrounding cities and towns
surrounding Manchester
my understanding was that
what we were trying to do was just allow
a
um
a group that already exists with this
with a with a defined number of members
the ability to locate their facility
outside of the confines of the the the
the groups or the the groups that are
part of the towns that are part of the
group okay now I I'm sorry I think I did
misunderstand your question so I
apologize for that but um I I guess I
would
I would agree that that was maybe that's
maybe the legislative intent here in
this language is to allow maybe more
easier citing for say solar arrays that
are looking to come into operation now
um I would agree that's probably the
thrust of this language at least from
the Department's perspective is that we
would respectfully view that as a
sizable change to the statute and we
encourage policy makers to consider
letting the adjudicative proceeding work
I ask one more follow-up
uh it's okay if we have time after I ask
my question
so I have a question as well oh and I
just received another pink card so we're
going to have one more uh individual who
wants to speak on this bill
my question is
isn't political subdivision a fairly
well-defined term within uh legislative
the legislative Realm
I would agree with that sentiment as
political subdivision within the context
of this statute is defined online's 9 to
12 in the bill
so the dictionary defines political as
relating to the government or the public
affairs of a country
relating to the ideas or strategies of a
particular party or group in politics or
that would seem to preclude
housing authorities quasi-public
entities the peas Development Authority
it's it's hard to imagine how those
could be considered to be public
subdivisions now I understand that you
can Define it to be whatever you want it
to be
but
there's what you can do and what you
should do and redefining words and their
meaning
can have under unintended consequences
political subdivision is a term that's
used in a lot of different places in
legislation if we redefine it here could
that have an unintended consequence to
legislation elsewhere uh thank you for
the question I I'm not entirely uh oh
I understand what you're asking but I
would just note that obviously for the
purposes of just this statue the
municipal house statute the term
political subdivision is defined just
for this statute whether or not the
committee wishes to open up what
political subdivision means to include
other entities that might not
necessarily be viewed through the lens
of a political subdivision
um and I you know such as private
companies or quasi-public entities
housing authorities you know
big box stores what have you that's
obviously a prerogative for the
legislature to to make
um but you know I over time you know if
certain changes are made and we continue
adding you know different entities
within the definition of political
subdivision I you know I would admit an
argument could be made that it is
warping the definition of what a
political subdivision is
okay thank you
so you know further question oh you did
have one more question no okay so you
know further questions then we do have
one additional person who would like to
testify on this bill and that is
Clark Fenner
representing Synergy solar of Rye so
thank you Mr chairman for uh allowing me
to speak I wanted to address
specifically regarding this bill lines
six through eight
which are
related to the removal of the statement
of restricting the municipality to only
serve members within the boundaries of
that municipality
there's two things that I wanted to
comment regarding your statement that
that was put in there specifically to
restrict the explosive growth of solar
within the state thus affecting the rate
payers there's two things that come to
mind here one is the fact that
there are even with five megawatts as a
limit
the ability to interconnect a solar
project into the grid is a complex
entity it's like it's a complex effort
the original grid was designed for
centralized generation sent out to
substations through transmission and
then local distribution
that concept and the way that the grid
was designed
particularly in New Hampshire is such
that distributed generation
is a difficult thing to accomplish on an
economic basis for solar projects
the ability to interconnect
a one megawatt netbeater project now and
we've done a number of them throughout
the state over the past four or five
years
the cost of interconnection continues to
go up particularly with inflation cost
of diesel the cost of the
interconnection equipment has
skyrocketed and increased the cost to
build these projects by between 40 to 70
percent depending on what
interconnection issues are required
that being the way it is
even with five megawatt uh projects
you're you can't see explosive growth
just due to interconnection cost issues
um the the grid is just not designed for
it we have to go through a process which
we uncover these costs that end up being
anywhere from you know 200 000 to a
million dollars which kills projects and
this happens on a regular basis
relative to the language about keeping
all
members of a municipal project within
the boundaries of a given municipality
when this was originally conceived of
it goes back to when there was a general
five megawatt increase that was
contemplated it was passed on a
bipartisan basis by the House
Republicans senate senate Republicans
and Democrats and vetoed by the governor
twice
um ultimately
the governor agreed based on pressure
from 12 Mayors throughout the state
he agreed that okay you guys want this
will allow for the expansion of five
megawatts from municipalities hence the
creation of this
in reality what's happened
is that this bill supports about five
municipalities here in the state
with that statement in there
the load that was talked about
there are only the largest cities within
the state have got the load
that can satisfy five a five megawatt
project or even smaller within their
boundaries
and those cities are
Manchester Concord Nashua possibly
Portsmouth
maybe Franklin
all the rest of them are excluded from
this bill
and I don't believe that's what the
governor or all the other Mayors had
intended
it should be an equitable application
across the state by removing that
statement the lines of six through eight
now you can apply it across the state
because as was pointed out before you've
got certain States
that are up in the mountains they don't
have the landscape that is solar capable
too much shading too many Wetlands
mountainous
Etc you could never cite any uh solo
there if you wanted to
however next to them may be a
municipality a smaller one uh maybe
several of them which have got some land
would love to produce it they have no
load so I've got to spread that load
around
a good example we're doing a project on
a landfill in Laconia getting ready to
go it's only three megawatts Laconia is
not a small City and we are struggling
to sign up enough
off take from within that municipality
to satisfy that project and the city
really wants it
and it's a republican City so when you
look at the application of this across
the state
and the fairness to the smaller
communities as well as the that have got
the land but no load and as was pointed
out you've got other municipalities have
got the load but no land
this allows for an equitable application
and again you've got the limiting issue
as far as explosive growth relative just
the interconnection issue itself
to give you an example
in the state of Maine
that fought net metering for years under
once Governor Mills was elected
there was a land rush up there everybody
looked at it farmland
lots of what appeared to be distribution
lines
they received over two gigawatts of
applications
and
you're going to be lucky to see
maybe 800 megawatts get
uh interconnected up there
strictly an interconnection issue
projects applied particularly five
megawatt projects applied
they were doing cluster studies to
determine can the transmission system
handle it transmission system can't
handle it
these guys want to build these projects
they're have they're looking at
individual interconnection charges just
for transmission upgrades of between
five and six million dollars and these
upgrades taking between five and seven
years those projects are dead so I think
a lot of the fear-mongering about the
state being covered in solar panels and
and destroying the the landscape in the
state is is unfounded
it's not based in reality
and as much as and the effect is that
we've got utilities that aren't are
terribly friendly to the effort either
but
the functioning of actually getting
these accomplished
it's expensive it's time consuming and
um I think that between as I mentioned
the cost of interconnection and the
application of this particular bill on
an equitable basis across all
municipalities not just five
it's something that should be considered
and that's why I do support this because
I believe that it's fair
okay
okay thank you very much can I ask you a
couple of questions to help me
understand this issue thoroughly
if a given municipality can't support
five megawatts of load
why can't they just build a smaller
system
or one megawatt or 1.5 or whatever
thanks for the questions very good one
um a one megawatt system costs the same
to interconnect as a five megawatt
system
and the cost of that interconnection as
I mentioned is just continuing to
Skyrocket to the point where one
megawatt projects are becoming
I know we're not supposed to debate
people when when they speak to us but my
follow-up question would be how can it
be possible for a five megawatt system
which requires 25 acres of land to cost
the same as a one megawatt system which
only requires five acres of land
is a 20 acre difference there and as we
all know land is expensive
how could how could you make the the
claim that they both cost the same it's
thank you for the question and it's not
the um it's not the
functioning of the project itself
uh the land cost Etc because the land
itself these these generally get paid a
lease rate uh that's based on output of
the project how much how much revenue it
generates
the larger one of the largest expenses
that we incur when we're building these
is not the it's it's the actual
interconnection equipment line upgrades
Etc uh in some in some cases substation
upgrades necessary to interconnect any
power to a substation which was never
designed to take any power into it the
initial grid was designed for the power
to flow out in One Direction now that
that power's got to flow in two
directions and so the fuses the one of
those reclosers the air brake switches
Etc all of that between the site of this
the project and the sub substation at
least have got to be replaced and
depending on how far from the substation
it is the uh the cost of that can run
into the millions of dollars and
um when you're looking at the amount of
power that and revenue that's generated
by a one megawatt project versus that
which is generated by a five megawatt
projects you've got five times the
revenue
to amortize that cost over versus just
one time so depending on the cost of
that
you can completely be eliminated from
doing a project at one megawatt whereas
if you're generating five times the
revenue and we've got from a solar uh
net metering standpoint we've got low
Revenue coming into into these projects
in New Hampshire compared to say
Massachusetts that's a whole different
animal but um
um it's it's purely that issue it's it's
a revenue uh recognition issue five
megawatts versus one whereas your cost
it's a good explanation thank you
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman so I I'm
following this interconnection issue
that you're saying that's the Big Driver
of cost here yes it is uh so
the example you gave of of
four or five communities that you know
may have population density but not the
land and vice versa I
tease that out a little bit for me on on
the interconnection now because it seems
the same interconnection issue applies
so how's that work thank you for the
question actually I may have convoluted
uh uh two different issues there the um
the issue regarding
sharing effectively uh Municipal load
amongst multiple communities uh for a
single project for instance the one I
stated which was Laconia and if we had
the ability to go out to uh Meredith and
gillington and other you know
surrounding towns that would like to say
that we're getting our power effectively
from the Laconia landfill project they
would be able to do that and they would
have a desire to do that the issue about
interconnection cost is strictly a one
to five megawatt issue it doesn't have
anything to do with the the uh
spreading of the of the load amongst
multiple communities okay got it thank
you sure thank you sir
and someone who serves on a planning
board and Deals constantly with land use
issues and disputes
if one of these projects was to span
Municipal boundaries
would that open the door to political
disputes between the governing bodies of
the respective Towns over
ownership of the project the provision
of benefits of the project uh
land use jurisdiction over the project
Etc
thank you for the question uh Mr
chairman I think that I
I haven't seen that issue
um coming up of having a single project
stand multiple municipality Municipal
boundaries we try to avoid that
completely in fact even when we have a
a single project where the land may be
owned by uh or maybe subdivided into
multiple parcels
and
usually owned by the same entity what
we'll generally do is go through a lot
line adjustment so that the project
remains on a single parcel of land and
in this case within a single
municipality so I don't see that I
understand the issue relative to peace
Development Authority where you may be
spanning
Portsmouth and Newington and that's a
good question and I'm not probably the
person to answer that
saw a hand up over to representative
Kaplan has a question
all right thank you Mr chair and thank
you for for being here and presenting
um you mentioned that there are
currently five cities or five
municipalities that are capable of
taking advantage of the laws that now
stands uh so that would be a total 25
megawatts of solar
if if roughly if there was only
um
in terms of of the amount of load we'd
have to when we get involved in uh
analyzing a given project and what the
municipality can actually handle before
we design the system we went through
this with as I said with Laconia where
we had to be very cognizant about how
much load can they actually take
or or present and
subscribe to the project so that we
don't over build it
um
and so we have to go through their last
three years of power usage and take into
account in this particular case the
coveted years which was power usage was
down and we had to balance it out such
that we knew that over the next we could
estimate over the next 10 to 20 years
that we would still be able to maintain
um that Municipal load specific for that
project and you know you've got cities
that are going through Energy Efficiency
programs trying to reduce their power
load they may be using so much today but
maybe a little bit later they're going
to be using less but they're going to be
expanding the school system so possibly
it's going to go up it's there's a lot
of moving parts so my question is if if
this if you need a follow-up yeah I
guess his fault uh if if we did pass
this this bill do you have an estimation
of how many more projects would be
viable in New Hampshire uh thank you for
the question I I don't have that number
okay in addition to the fact that it was
mentioned earlier that
um there is a net metering docket that's
in process and we've been advised to
wait until that's finished uh it should
be also noted that there is also an
interconnection study docket that's in
process we should probably wait until
that's completed as well
all right seeing no further questions I
want to thank you Mr Fenner for being
here I appreciated your your insights
and your information thank you very much
and having no more pink cards on this uh
on this bill I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill
and
I will then yield the gavel to
representative Thomas since I am the
prime sponsor of the next bill so
representative Thomas take over and open
representative do you have the blue
sheet for the previous bill
uh yes thank you all
I'll spill 139
the blue sheet there was
two in favor none opposed
online there was
106 in favor three opposed
okay we'll open up public hearing on HB
219 I believe yes 219 and our Prime
sponsor representative votes
ready to speak
thank you Mr chairman
for the record
representative Michael Vose representing
Rockingham District 5 the town of Epping
serve as chair of this committee
I'm here today to introduce House Bill
219 FN
which is a bill that
repeals or moves several RSA chapters no
longer associated with the with
Administration by the department of
energy of the Public Utilities
Commission or the Public Utilities
Commission and establishes the
legislative committee to examine to
examine other statutory provisions
I filed this bill on behalf of the
Public Utilities Commission
they sent me a relatively extensive list
of
rsas which they feel are no longer under
their purview
a fun fact about the Public Utilities
Commission back in the 1880s and the
1890s
the puc
regulated railroads in the state of New
Hampshire
there were no electric utilities back
then
there were some Telegraph lines but
mostly there were railroads and so the
puc was fairly heavily involved with
regulating railroads back then
well they no longer regulate railroads
and as all of you will recall two years
ago
the Public Utilities Commission was
broken up into a much smaller puc as we
learned this morning and a department of
energy
and after that breakup happened
it was necessary for both organizations
to develop rules
for the operation of their
respective regulatory regimes
and during the course of examining and
planning the process of rewriting rules
the POC discovered that they had a whole
bunch of
statutory obligations that they really
shouldn't have
so they asked me to file this bill to
repeal
numerous
pieces of existing legislation
so I sent the list to the office of
legislative services
and the drafting attorney who began work
on the bill
contacted me and he said are you sure
you want to repeal all these because
some of them look like they might still
need to stay in existence
however they may need to be transferred
from the Public Utilities Commission to
the Department of Transportation or
so he and I went through the list and we
identified what we thought were likely
candidates for repeal
and then at his suggestion
at the at the end of this bill on page
four section four page 9 line 15 you'll
notice that the bill creates a study
committee and the study committee is
charged with examining
several other
uh
potential rsas to see if they should be
so the study committee is part of this
bill
now since that time I've been contacted
by a variety of sources
and I've been told that
if you look at the first page of the
numerous rsas are listed as being
repealed
RSA 372 is
about laying out railroads
RSA 373 is about Crossings stations
fences cattle guards Bridges and Bridge
guards
RSA 380 is about railroads and fire
damage and prevention
RSA 228 is about railroad police
and RSA 382 is about maintenance of
parks by railroads and bus lines
I've been advised and I think you'll
hear people testify after me that these
particular rsas should probably not be
repealed but instead should be
reassigned
or or redrafted to be part of a
different department the responsibility
of a different department for regulation
so it's very likely that we'll need a
an amendment to this bill to move those
bills under the purview of the study
committee
to have them figure out just exactly how
to deal with those bills
that will be in addition to the bills
that are already listed
on
page nine
uh
lines 28
or 27 through
30. RSA 362 e RSA 367 RSA 368
I would propose it will need to add 372
now the fiscal note that's attached to
this bill
is lengthy but it's totally inconclusive
because all it is is a
copy
of all the fines
that the various rsas mentioned in the
bill
could it potentially
provide for violations
there's no way to know
how many of these uh
violations would actually happen
there's no way of knowing how much
revenue would actually be collected
it is a nice list I guess to have of
possible
fines that could be levied against
people for various uh offenses in the
state but it's not really relevant to
the bill because there's no way of
knowing how
so that's the substance of the bill
um
Michelle bunemeyer from the puc is here
she will be testifying after me I
believe there's someone who's going to
be testifying from the Department of
Transportation as well so there's lots
more information that we'll be able to
glean about this bill
I think it's worthwhile to go forward
with it
in some fashion but obviously it'll be
need to be amended before we come up
with a final
Bill to present
for executive session and so that's my
introduction to the bill with that I'll
be happy to take questions
from the committee
thank you chairman Vose uh my only
comment is that
you take on quite an undertaking here
it's uh
it's sort of like uh pulling one string
and finding out there's more attached to
it
but I'll take a first question from
thank you uh Mr chair or acting chair so
Mr chair
um
you you you mentioned I think five of
the original uh
bills or RSA sections slotted for repeal
now should go to the study committee I
would just asked
uh do you are you confident that any of
the rsas that you've got slotted for
repeal shouldn't have a second look
just turn this all over to a study
committee and say look at this whole
basket and tell us what you think
good question and the answer is I'm not
sure that
the remaining bills that were that I
didn't mention from section one RSA 377
3s RSA 379
um RSA 376 actually RSA 376 is probably
the one that should be uh repealed
because it's reconstituted as chapter
359 u in the uh section two of the bill
that starts on line 17 and proceeds for
the next half a dozen Pages yeah so that
is the one bill in section one that I
think is we can fairly confidently
predict that we can repeal the others
I no longer I haven't been notified that
they shouldn't be repealed at this point
but
I couldn't say definitively that they
shouldn't so it is possible that they'd
have to be added to the study committee
by the way I neglected to remember to
mention when I handed over the gavel but
and I think all morning we didn't have
uh Miss uh representative Munds has a
question
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
chair for taking my question
um I I assume that if we were going to
turn this into a study committee bill
then none of the none of the rsas would
be repealed by the effective date of
July 1st 14 that would all be after the
study committee the study committee
would make a recommendation on when the
repeals would go into effect
yes that is correct thank you
representative daughter has a question
yes thank you look regarding the
Antiquated rsas
um I recall several terms ago as having
a discussion about an Antiquated RSA
that it was illegal to watch a train on
watch a movie on the train on a Sunday
I don't remember us ever repealing that
but I'm going to guess that we did can
you confirm that
I have no idea I don't I don't remember
representative Wendy Thomas has a
thank you I just am going I'm going to
reinforce the the what seems to be a
common uh discussion here about the
study committee
it seems that with the bill you might be
putting the cart before the horse
because if we repeal some of these and
if we pass the bill and then set up a
study committee and then the study
committee makes the decision that some
of these should not have been repealed
then that means another another bill
needs to be drafted correct
yes that is correct that's why I said
I'm not confident that the bills that
I have identified for repeal here should
stay on the list okay I'm hopeful that
testimony will hear after mine will give
us we'll shed some some light on that
representative partial your question
thank you chair and uh I have a question
on the study committee
and membership
and the question is basically if we had
a study commission instead of a study
committee would that welcome greater
participation by the department of
energy
foreign
I suppose it would yes
well reasonable suggestion I also
noticed that there's no mention of any
members of the sdna being part of the
contingent of four members from the
House of Representatives I I might like
to see that added as well
follow-up
I would only urge you to consider as
much but I suppose while we're at it
perhaps there needs to be somebody from
the Department of Transportation on here
as well I don't know they were building
question please and thank you chair uh
thank you for taking my question chair I
had this so I waited to the end
um talking to a constituent now on
I always say 372 regarding upkeep of
railroad fences on his property to keep
the cattle in so actually I'm active
with that now so that one should not be
repealed so that's one example thank you
yes
RSA 37
373 should not be on the repeal list
thank you
I
I think I have a question for you um
just
curious if any of these repeals of the
railroad regulations here would they
have any effect whatsoever on any of the
good question have no idea possibly
somebody behind me can shed some light
on that question
okay thank you
without seeing no other questions thank
you very much for your very enlightening
con uh testimony chairman Vose and I
start again my name is Michelle
bunemeyer I am a staff attorney at the
Public Utilities Commission and I am
here to testify regarding section one of
the bill
and representative Bose is correct that
we had submitted a list of bills not
necessarily to be repealed just that
they didn't have anything to do with
Current public utilities regulation so
our purpose was just to suggest a
possible cleanup of title 34 which is
entitled Public Utilities but it does
contain a number of statutes that do not
relate to the current regulation of
Public Utilities such as the railroad
statutes
um
the authority to regulate railroads has
been primarily vested in other agencies
and not the puc
so the puc proposed this bill as a way
of eliminating various extraneous
statutes from chapter from title 34
which are no longer related to Public
Utilities regulation
so we are in favor of the first section
of the bill which I understand may be
amended but we take no position on
thank you for your testimony
oh seeing none thank you very much
last pink card I have unless anyone
fills out any others is uh Mr Brier from
the Department of Dot
transportation
did I pronounce that correct
spot on Mr chair that was perfect thank
you
as as the chairman stated I'm Andre
Brier a Deputy Commissioner Department
of Transportation I'm joined here with
Miss Shelley Winters who's the director
of Aviation Rail and Transit I think
chairman Vos uh very succinctly and
correctly noted uh the objections that
we do have I would even uh say that if
those sections do get referred to the
study committee we will withdraw our our
opposition uh because that's that's why
we're here we do have a letter that you
see before you
from uh chairman Jim jalbert from the
New Hampshire Transportation Council who
recommends a course of action identical
uh to what chairman Vose laid out to you
so as long as those rsas are not
repealed
we're fine with the bill that that's our
only objection it would have the effect
of eliminating our ability to regulate
rails in the state so we were obviously
concerned about that
but
we are fully supportive of the notion
that these should fall under rsas more
appropriate to the Department of
Transportation
representative man's the question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in
um
is is dot responsible for railroads now
we are sir
follow-up follow-up
so given that you're responsible but the
legislation says the puc is responsible
that's a little bit of a problem isn't
it
it is and it's it's a relic of a former
um administrative configuration
whereby
we were linked thank you
representative Winnie Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um regarding an earlier question do any
of these rsas cover our rail trails at
all
so by implication when you talk about
Crossings you know we maintain all rail
trails are on uh I won't say that I'll
say most rail trails are on inactive
state-owned track
um so we maintain the trackage uh
corridors in the event that at any
future Point rail is re-established
that's why dot retains ownership of
those corridors
we do have they are managed portions are
managed by other agencies but uh but but
remember so representative partial
yes thank you chair and thank you for
taking the question thank you for being
here today could you tell me we have a
10-year plan which includes uh rail
service along the I believe it's called
the capital Corridor we were just
testifying to that effect okay and uh if
these particular uh Clauses were
rescinded
um could you see that having a direct
effect on the capital quarter almost
certainly uh the capital quarter itself
as Ms Winters and I just testified we
completed the preliminary design uh
phase of that project just this week so
that was 31 January our consultant
provided us a draft report we'll be
providing that to the legislature in the
in coming weeks
um this you know these rsas here uh you
know while they're not
the totality of our authorities uh it's
a big chunk of authorities to maintain
and regulate railroads that are
represented by these rsas we do have
uh I have a question just for clarity so
okay one second I'll finish my question
uh was testifying that uh she had no
problem with Section one would would
section one also be included in any uh
study that that you would approve of
yeah well if section one includes uh
Roman one then yeah those are those are
all rsas that we'd be interested in
referring to the study committee
okay thank you
yeah this Line's essentially on the
legislation lines two through fifteen uh
all of those rsas we need to uh to
reassign
representative munz as just as your
second question
thank you Mr chair so if we know if if
if you know that these rsas
are
um
your responsibility why do we need a
study committee can't we just re-codify
them as we did with the with RSA 372
we do have recommendations where they
could go yes sir uh we we could provide
you those answers if you'd like to
directly do that
um there could be I I guess my only
caution there would be
there are other agencies potentially
involved with this that that may benefit
from a study committee
yeah Department of Safety being primary
with railroad police we of course do not
uh maintain law enforcement Authority on
the railroads so that would be a
department of safety so I wouldn't want
to speak for them uh in that sense a
um so so like we said earlier a
commission might be the best way to go
because then we could make sure we got
involved active involvement from all the
necessary government we certainly
endorse that yes sir thank you
thank you very much so you know other
questions uh thank you for your
testimony I appreciate you coming down
here for that thank you for your time
we do have a a
additional speaker Mr Peter bragner from
Bragdon yeah
sorry I wasn't before my time
from CSX Railways welcome Mr Brighton
thank you Mr chairman I prefer to call
it recovery recovering Senator it's
probably a better way to face it so good
to see some of my friends from uh
Merrimack here in the former District
11. uh for the record Peter Bragdon uh
senior policy advisor with pretty
strategies uh here representing CSX
Railways and just here to support the
Department's efforts on especially
section one of the bill uh which seeks
to repeal a number of statutes CSX
Railways recently completed the
acquisition of Pan Am Railways and is
fairly new to the state and uh who knew
that the Public Utilities Commission
statutes affected railroads like this so
we found out about this bill a week or
two ago and really haven't had the time
to study exactly how these particular
pieces being repealed might affect us so
it's our understanding that the goal is
to take these repeals and turn them into
a study commission we we fully support
that gives everybody time to figure out
okay exactly what is needed what needs
to stay and What needs to disappear so
supportive of that effort and echoing
the Department's comments
thank you Mr Brighton do I see any
questions from anyone
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you for coming down here
any other
speakers seeing none uh
declare this test this testimony for
Bill 219 I think it is closed
Mr representative laplosier can we have
okay thank you chair
House Bill 219 FM
the Belushi had no
um sign-ins
online there was one support and one
neutral
okay we will have a short
break
because we will be going into executive
session here shortly and the chair will
be taking over
Charlie
today
afternoon
yes
hard executive sessions at 4 pm
I have a couple of
introductions to make before we get
there
so we have six substitutes today on our
committee
three on the Democratic side three on
the Republican side
substituting for Michael Harrington
today is representative David love
welcome David
represent substituting for
representative Troy murner is
a representative Arnold Davis
welcome Arnie
represent a
replacing representative John lewicki is
representative Carol Brown welcome Carol
represented replacing representative Kat
McGee is Jessica Grill welcome Jessica
representative
Jackie cretian is being replaced today
by Carrie Speer welcome back Kerry
and
representative Ned Reynolds is being
replaced today by Heath Howard
welcome Heath
thank you for being here today for this
executive succession executive session
sorry it's been a long day
so we're going to actually and it's
going to be a longer day because we're
actually going to exec seven bills in
the course of the next hour two hours
however long it takes
we're going to start with a couple of
bills that we heard earlier today
I have negotiated with the ranking
member and she has agreed that we can
exec these bills today so we will exec
first house bill 211 then house bill
then we will move to our published
executive session calendar and exec
representative love is retrieving copies
of the bills he's not leaving the
building
so I'm going to open an executive
session on House Bill 211 and I'm going
to recognize representative Doug Thomas
for a motion
thank you Mr chair I motion to OTP uh
Bill HB 211 as I mentioned very briefly
it's a housekeeping Bill and uh no
further explanation is needed
chair recognizes representative Bernardi
the second the motion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll and
the motion of ought to pass on House
foreign
Thomas
yes
Janine nodder yes
David love yes
Arnold Davis yes
Carol Brown
yes
Lex barajny yes
James Summers yes
uh Rebecca McWilliams yes
Gary Speer yes
lucious parcel yes
Tony Kaplan
yes
Chris muns yes
Henry Noel
yes
Wendy Thomas
yes Thomas Corman yes
Heath Howard
yes
uh and chairman Vose yes
so our vote is 20 to zero
by a vote of 20-0 House Bill 211 passes
out of committee with the recommendation
of
ought to pass
without objection we'll place this bill
on the consent calendar
seeing no injections it will go on the
consent calendar representative Thomas
please write a committee report and have
it to me by noon on Monday
Mr chair yes uh it's me Rebecca nope
over here me Wendy Thomas oh Wendy
Thomas yes representative Wendy Thomas
um
just to clarify
representative Doug Thomas is writing
the report
yes I know I'm sorry but
representative Doug Thomas will write
the the committee report Thank You by
noon on Monday
and with that we'll close the public
hearing on House Bill 211. thank you
members now we'll open a public hearing
on House Bill 633 and the chair
recognizes representative McWilliams for
a motion
uh Mr chair I move that we uh itl this
bill
chair recognizes representative Thomas
for
a second the bill second the itl it's
been moved and seconded that we itl
House Bill 633 is there any discussion
representative McWilliams
for the record I'd like to say that I
believe that this bill bill was well
intended I would like to think the best
of the Bill's sponsor and thank him for
presenting and bringing this to our
attention however we heard quite a bit
of testimony that it would not be
possible constitutionally to do what the
bill sets out to do and so therefore I
don't think there's any way that we can
work with it but we do appreciate the
bringing the bill and the discussion
that came out
thank you excellent comments any
additional comments on this bill any
additional discussion
seeing none I asked the clerk the cost
call the roll on the question of itl for
House Bill 633
Doug Thomas
yes Janine knotter yes
David love yes
Arnold Davis yes
Carol Brown yes Lex brezhny yes
JD Bernardi yes Tom Peluche yes
James Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Jessica Grill yes
Gary Speer yes lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris munz yes Henry
Noel
yes
Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes Heath
22-0
by a vote of twenty two zero House Bill
633 is judged to be worthy of itl and
without objection will go on the consent
calendar
seeing no objections so ordered
and representative McWilliams will pin
the committee report and have it to me
by noon on Monday
I may delegate that but yes Mr chair
we'll take care of it thank you
and with that we'll close the executive
okay next let's open a executive session
on House Bill
630 Dash FN establishing a revolving
clean energy accelerator Fund in the
department of energy the chair
recognizes representative Tom closure
for a motion
thank you chair I'd like to motion to
itl House Bill 630 FM I would like to
speak on my motion chair recognizes
representative berezny
I second that motion
chair recognizes representative cloje
uh this bill was a vehicle to accept the
federal funds
we we the committee half of the
committee more than half the committee
spoke an hour on this bill about
financing
unknown Federal mandates
but
we did not spend any time on any of the
projects any of the energy projects
listed there this is more of a finance
bill there was no fiscal note
and I do not believe we should be able
to pass the bill that we don't know what
the cost is which is my main reason
for it owing this Bill thank you
further discussion on House Bill 630
representative McWilliams
thank you Mr chair
um as part of our discussion on House
Bill 630 there were some concerns raised
about
um if there would be any administrative
costs that were shifted onto the state
rather than could be used from federal
funds for a green bank and so um I know
that's not germane to this current
discussion but uh Mr representative
Harrington and I worked on an amendment
to make sure that uh to the extent
possible all federal funds would be used
to cover administrative costs including
hiring somebody who needed to work for
Des to manage it if necessary so if this
motion fails I'd be happy to bring
forward an amendment but for the record
the goal here is not to cost a dime to
the state but rather to be able to
direct how money is spent that comes
from the FED to the state of New
Hampshire as part of the infrastructure
reinvestment act I want to be very clear
that this is about guiding and
controlling the money rather than
leaving it to non-profits and other
smaller agencies who may go for small
parts of it whereas our department of
further discussion on House Bill 630
representative muns thank you Mr chair I
just would like to follow up on what
representative McWilliams said to and
remind everyone that we heard testimony
that there is 27 billion dollars in
federal money that's going to be
available for projects such as this and
this would give us the ability to make
sure that New Hampshire doesn't lose out
on any of that funding
representative Thomas has a comment
or sorry representative Bernardi has a
comment
yes uh uh the department of energy would
get this money no matter what and
Department of energy could can move this
to uh one of several financial
institutions already exists so we're not
going to lose any money by not adopting
this bill we don't need to create a new
representative munz has another comment
thank you Mr chair
um I I thought what I heard from the
Department of energy or uh I'm not sure
if it was the department of energy but
one somebody that testified that the 27
billion dollars was available
specifically for Green Bank funding
foreign maybe it would be appropriate
since we have a representative of the
Department of energy here to ask him
that question
could you clarify for us we have some
confusion here
Mr Roberts about whether or not
the department of energy can accept
any or all of this money without the
thank you members of the committee uh
Griffin Roberge from the New Hampshire
Department of energy I was not here when
House Bill 630 uh was uh had its public
hearing our policy and programs division
director Josh Elliott was I know he
followed up with the committee uh with
an email I think Thursday morning
detailing the three different buckets
that are available through this uh large
program that's managed out of the IRA
um they're a bear with me There's 7
billion available for zero emission
Technologies that's open to States
municipalities tribal governments and
eligible recipients and I'll we'll go
back to eligible recipients here in a
moment there's about 12 billion for
general assistance and 8 billion for
low-income low-income and disadvantaged
communities an eligible recipient in
those three pots is viewed quite broadly
it can include a non-profit organization
that can design and provide cap Capital
leverage private capital and that type
of thing
there are suggestions that state created
entity contemplated by this legislation
could be eligible to apply to some of
these buckets but until more Federal
guidance is fleshed out for these
programs there is nothing definitive at
this time the IRA for context was signed
into law in August of last year and they
are and the federal government
specifically the U.S department of
energy and the EPA are still developing
a lot of guidance on these programs
regarding whether or not this funding
could be used for staff the federal
statute does not go into detail about
every last eligible use for the funds in
fact the language enabling this program
is just over two pages long so a lot of
this needs to be fleshed out with rules
and federal guidance issued by the
federal agencies themselves
reading from Josh's email by virtue of
this program being created through the
reconciliation process only Provisions
related to the Appropriations were
allowed to be part of the language of
the bill so there's much left to the EPA
to fill in the blank when it comes to
drafting guidance documents all the
wording presumes that there will be
administrative costs incurred by the
recipients for these grants
but given but uh yeah I guess in that in
that
to be quite broad with it is that a lot
of guidance still needs to be developed
before we can anticipate how these funds
may be used
representative Thomas has a question uh
yes thank you Mr chairman I I was going
to make this statement but I'll just do
it for your concurrence uh the the
figure 27 billion has been
swept around here tonight that's not
coming all to New Hampshire right no
that it is 27 billion dollars made in
appropriation
across the board not not 27 billion
explicitly coming to the state of New
Hampshire no I think I'd be a little bit
more panicked if that was the case
that would engender a lot of
administrative yeah and I'm sorry let me
clarify a panic just a lot of stress I
would say uh managing 27 million I'm
sorry uh but I will acknowledge that um
uh uh again um I know our division
director also did uh send an email to
um the product sponsor representative
McWilliams as well
um I'm only just now reviewing that
email here now but I'm sure
representative you might be able to
speak more to that
um
in detail I don't mean to push it back
representative McWilliams do you have
anything further to my advantages I I
must have missed an email I'm sorry
about that uh I'm looking for
something from Department of energy and
I'm not seeing it here if if I might if
it helps at all it was sent Tuesday the
31st at 2 29 if that helps at all that
well we wait for representative
McWilliams to locate uh and review that
email I will say that here we go
based on
past experience in
the federal government providing These
funds it doesn't seem to me that it
would be a danger to
postpone any activity on establishing a
green bank for a year because it's very
likely the federal government won't get
around to providing any funds within a
year's time anyway as slow as as things
work over there so I don't see any risk
in
foregoing this bill this year and if we
need it next year we can always bring it
back then
representative Wendy Thomas do you have
a question thank you Mr chair um just to
comment on what you just said I thought
during the testimony we heard that if a
vehicle wasn't set up that it could
possibly
affect our requests
for the money
so um
so I'm thinking wouldn't it be prudent
to set this up in anticipation
of receiving the money
I suspect we'll have plenty of time to
do that later by the time they get
around to dishing out the money
that would be my judgment
representative McWilliams
thank you chair and thank you Mr Roberts
um I I did receive
it he had several edits that he
made to the base Bill and so those edits
were integrated into this amendment that
I mentioned previously
he wanted to be very clear that New
Hampshire Department of energy needs to
stay consistent with Federal funding
terms and conditions which his edits are
Incorporated and do that
as well as making sure that if the
federal fund will allow grants the
department of energy can make grants so
really it's about deferring to the
guidance that we're still waiting for
but in terms of timeliness I want to
stress that we did hear testimony from
Mr Evans Brown in regards to timing of
the grant funding from the federal
government specific to this bucket Our
concern and my my very strong concern
here is that if we itl this bill we will
not be able to bring it back until
probably January of 2024 and so if the
funds are available in September of 2023
we may be missing a first window we
don't know that but it puts us in in a
difficult position where we as a
legislature operate seasonally whereas
the federal government has these rolling
deadlines that tend to get bumped and
moved but also the deadline is the
deadline is the deadline so we can't try
to do something special for a deadline
because we're only really operating
January to June as a legislature so from
a prudent perspective to safeguard our
our taxpayers dollars that we would like
to get back to New Hampshire since
they've already been paid and they could
come back through the federal IRA
I think it makes sense for us to try to
hang on to this bill and not just kill
it quite yet because something could
happen and it would be nice to have
something for us to put the money in if
that happens and if we do receive
guidance in the next couple of months we
would be ready to receive some money
representative Bernardi has a comment
it's my understanding that the doe New
Hampshire doe could accept these funds
and there is already existing financial
institution within New Hampshire that
administers funds that come from uh the
federal government that could be used as
a vehicle to administer them so
functionally we're set up or we're not
going to lose anything we don't need to
additional comments representative
Thomas
Doug Thomas Doug Thomas
yeah just to add on to uh representative
uh Bernardi's comment I believe I also
heard in testimony that although more
convenient with green banks that there
were other uh financial institutions
that could handle some of these funds as
well so we have a couple of options uh
right now if should there be an
emergency where we have to accept funds
right away there are some options here
as well
foreign
representative partial
thank you chair and I would like to ask
a question of Mr Roberts do you believe
the uh Department of energy is indeed
ready to receive these funds and can you
name some of the organizations that are
prepared to disburse These funds sure uh
thank you very much for the question so
um backing up just a little bit
obviously it depends on the various
program guidance but um with for example
stuff coming out of the infrastructure
Bill there is no need for a state stat
for state legislators to enact a program
to receive those funds so for example
like during our presentation
earlier when I went over some of the
federal funding pots those are funds
that we can manage ourselves at least
with the current guidance that's
available regarding this funding
opportunity again it would depend on the
type of guidance that's given out if the
thought is to
um for the Department to issue loans and
to leverage private capital and that
type of thing that's not something that
we can do with current resources that we
have we do not administer or any loan
programs on our own we usually work with
other third parties I think I'd be
reluctant at this time to identify
specific parties that we would work with
on a
on a funding pot that we don't know
quite a lot of clarity on but if the if
the responsibility was to take these
dollars and set up some type of
revolving Loan Fund or to leverage
private capital I imagine you know
organizations like the BFA or the cdfa
come to mind but I'm not
I'm not putting them on the wall or
anything like that
follow-up thank you
um I believe there's something like 28
States already have been correct me if
I'm wrong that have instituted uh Green
Banks revolving loan funds and many of
them are Republican states do you could
you can you tell me about that or are
you aware of any of this I could not
comment on that right here and now um I
I will just acknowledge that I believe
some states do have green Banks I
couldn't tell you how they function or
in what states they operate in neither
could I yeah that's fine I appreciate
the ask though foreign representative
to read something into the record in
how the concern here is really what do
we do with the funds that are coming
from the IRA and so if we enact a green
Bank
then we are applying with our Green Bank
to receive the maximum number of funds
and we are also directing exactly where
those funds go through the green bank if
we do not do a green bank then Mr
Roberts is correct that the department
of energy can be one of the participants
in New Hampshire who goes after the
money but there will be others there are
non-profits the Community Loan Fund
could go after some of the money um the
so there are other sort of competitors
not that they need to be competitors but
the money would go to different pots and
it would be administered according to
the applicants
proposals and so really what we're
talking about here is being able to
maintain at a state level biggest bang
for your buck through a green Bank as
opposed to the Department of energy
Department of energy being one of many
applicants for the same pool of money
often times trying to do overlapping
things
thank you
seeing none I'd ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of itl for
yes
no
the vote of 10 to 10 means that the
motion fails so if itl is uh off the
table I'll now recognize representative
McWilliams for a motion
uh Mr chair I'd like to move that we
adopt
Amendment 0309h which I will pass out
which is an amendment to House Bill 630
okay so the motion is ought to pass and
HSN house
is there a second for the motion
representative Munn seconds the motion
so
we have a motion about to pass
with an amendment
0309 H is there any discussion
I'd like to speak to my motion
representative Munn seconded the motion
representative McWilliams is recognized
to speak to her motion thank you very
much chair Bose
um as we discussed with the underlying
Bill discussion there were a couple of
changes that we as a committee and of
course the department of energy had
asked if we were to move forward with
doing a green Bank
the first is that every reference to
revolving clean energy fund has been
replaced with revolving Green Bank to
make it very clear that this is to match
the requirements of the IRA in addition
uh there were some suggestions and I
will now read them out very specifically
from the Tuesday email from Mr Elliott
at the department of energy he was
concerned about making sure that we
followed the requirements of the federal
program in order to receive the funding
and not be inconsistent with what was
what was being requested versus what
we're capable of doing so I'm just
pulling up the email again my apologies
also representative Harrington and I uh
worked out I'm going to find the exact
reference here
we worked out that we wanted to make
sure that we could use the fund money
from the federal government in order to
pay for
um
the salary of someone who may need to be
hired from Des to do Administration for
the fund and I would say that we heard
testimony that the current amount of
federal funds that we're looking at for
many of these program items is somewhere
between 80 and 90 thousand dollars
assuming not every state applies for the
funds we would expect more I'm sorry I
said 80 90 000 and I made 80 to 90
million so how do we expect that the
total number is somewhere north of 80 or
90 million but we really don't know
exactly how much because it depends on
how many other states apply but that is
not chump change that's significant
money that we want to make sure that if
you come back to the state from our
taxpayers
um
so let me see if I can find the
provision that representative Harrington
page three I believe page four thank you
say that again all right 32 and 33 on
page four
to sustain operations the department may
use capitalization funds financing fees
interest repaid loans or other types of
funding the department May immediately
use federal funds as permitted upon
receipt to pay for administrative costs
related to administering the green Bank
fund and we did hear testimony that
generally these federal funds come with
the provision that you can pay for
administrative costs for a certain
percentage of the total funds received
so that is an expectation and we're
enabling that so that department of
energy can do that
let me just jump back to the email
regarding requests from the Department
of energy very specific to being able to
use this money in keeping with the the
federal guidelines rather than jumping
all around and doing anything we want
and then getting in trouble later on
page two
um we're looking at
well it looks like we got a spacing
issue here
we added and consistent with the terms
and conditions of any federal funding
I'm just looking for where that actually
landed it looks like there was a spacing
issue
uh that's just a provision to stay in in
keeping with
um If the Fed says we can do it we will
line 30 page two there we go line 30
consistent with the terms and conditions
of any federal funding
um
next edit was on the previous page four
line 11.
we just added allowing us to receive
grants and and there was a renumbering
edit so if if grants are allowed it
means that the federal funds will allow
grants so the state can make grants I'm
just looking for where that actually
landed
probably slightly further down because
all right line 17 grants added to
numbers one two three four number five
is allowing grants in the form of Grants
it looks like we missed a space but
that's fine
um next one uh
page four lines 25 to 26 previously
we added in the language to sustain
operations which I already addressed
this was specific for
um allowing
capitalization funds financing fees
interest repaid loans and other types of
funding
so we addressed that one um and then
finally page four previously line 30
we added new language section
e and this is now on page five line five
new section e the department may enter
into contracts with third parties for
the management of funds and programs so
that will allow the department of energy
to work with someone like the Community
Loan Fund if they choose to to
administer and use their staff who are
experts in managing this type of
revolving funding rather than Department
of energy which tends to be a little bit
more policy a little less money
management so that's a review of the
amendment
foreign
comments on the amendment on the bill
representative closure
uh thank you chair
probably to representative McWilliams on
your on the amendment page three
line 14
to 15.
I'm I'm looking for an explanation on
financing Pro Finance program designed
to drive private Capital into Market
gaps that and may I explain
this is a one-time funding
of the money that we get
and it's going to
Drive private Capital into a place where
they're not normally would been
otherwise it wouldn't be a gap
I have a concern of after the funding's
over we're picking and choosing
um
winners because
I'm visualizing a gap where Private
Industry Capital does not want to go
what happens after the fact no more
funding to maintain that thank you
is that a question or is that just a
comment
it was uh
a request for an explanation from the
meaning
representative McWilliams can you
answer the question
sure that's a great question thank you
um when we when we heard testimony on
this one of the things that I brought up
as a current market Gap is um electric
vehicle charging stations we know right
now we're just not seeing a lot of
supporters stepping up with private
capital in this moment in New Hampshire
for EV charging stations so that would
be the low-hanging fruit immediately I
just want to reiterate that the
intention of this fund is to issue loans
and to collect some interest on those
loans so the idea is very similar to our
ongoing water issues fund that the state
has to address problems with cities and
towns that have contaminated water or
folks who need to get a new well they
take out a loan and they pay it back to
the states with interest so that the
fund continues for water that's the same
intention here only with
green type projects and so the fund
continues because the loans get repaid
with interest and certainly there's the
opportunity for other vehicles besides
the FED to fund the loan the entire
green bank if they choose to it's an
open-ended if they wanted to they could
direct an investment into it it's hard
to say how it will actually play out
this is really meant to be enabling and
so I want to call I want to draw your
attention to
um the provisions where we talked about
priorities
um because I think that's important for
the long term for the way that the fund
is actually managed
um
so we're on page four line 23 Romans 7.
and so the number one provision was to
mitigate greenhouse gas emissions that's
what if Des is I'm sorry if Department
of energy if doe is administering the
fund their goal is to mitigate
greenhouse gas emissions and maximize
reducing greenhouse gas emissions in the
state to the greatest extent possible
for every dollar deployed by the fund
and then the second piece was ensuring
40 of investment activity from the fund
is directed to serve vulnerable
communities so those are really the
priorities of the fun and Fund in
perpetuity
um although I see I see your point about
directing to private capital and that is
certainly a listed sort of Mantra of the
entire
additional comments representative Doug
Thomas thank you Mr chair
um I understand what the amendment and
the base bill is trying to do
but I'm still uncomfortable and I
haven't heard convincing testimony from
uh the the previous testifiers as to why
we absolutely positively have to have
this instrument uh if some monies came
here
um and not being a loan officer or a
lawyer I I really don't know
um what we're getting into here so I at
this time I I couldn't support this
amendment uh because we we just don't
know enough and as the the gentleman
from the UE spoke we still don't know
all of the details yet coming from the
federal government and it this just
might be premature this might be a great
document but it just might be premature
so I I feel uncomfortable and I don't
think I can support that
additional comments representative muns
thank you Mr chair
um
to representative Doug Thomas's point I
mean we we don't know I mean that that's
um I don't think there's anybody here
that you know on you know believes that
we have a clear understanding of exactly
how this money is going to come to the
state of New Hampshire
you know I guess I look at this the
reason for doing this is out of an
abundance of caution to make sure that
you know if there is the opportunity to
get this money that we have
um a chance to do so rather than being
in a situation where we potentially
could could lose out on on funding
because we don't have an appropriate
vehicle to accept the funding so it's
it's you're you're absolutely right that
we don't know
um and I think we're doing this trying
representative partial you had a comment
I did thank you chair
um along similar to lines uh I'd like to
ask what is the not knowing the federal
government's guidelines or knowing
Federal government's timetable for
releasing funds
how would you compare
the worst case scenario of enacting
enabling this bill now rather than the
worst case scenario of waiting a year to
is this a question are you asking us I I
would like to I would like to hear
um the potential if we do wait a year
could we potentially be losing out on
funds the short answer yes
potentially well we're talking about one
big bucket with one goal of how we would
spend the money rather than a couple of
small throw bologna at the wall buckets
that may or may not work out and we
don't know so I think it would be really
easy for finance to make the decision
about this because I assume they would
be the next committee to review this as
the guidance is issued rather than
saying let's wait a year and then all of
representative partial I would react to
your question
by pointing out that
if you wait until the federal guidance
is promulgated
to the state
you can craft programs
that conform to that guidance putting a
program in place before that guidance
comes down
might actually put you at risk of
missing out on some of the
Revenue that's available simply because
you haven't created a program that
conforms to the guidance
this led this amendment
while generally better than the original
bill
still does have some
inefficiencies and in fact introduced a
new inefficiency
on page five line five when it
added the statement that the department
may enter into contracts with third
parties for the management of funds and
programs
that's just inefficiency I mean
that ends up using program funds for
administration when they that money
might better be used for programs
themselves I think it makes sense to
wait until you see what the guidance is
from the federal government and then
design programs that that allow you to
maximize
your return
on the on these programs based on that
guidance
so I think it's time to to wait on this
particular
type of legislation
any further comments representative
closure
and thank you chair um May I address
yes go ahead and thank you
um
with the other concerns I have I just
want noted that representative
McWilliams did alleviate my concern for
that Gap
okay good
any further comments representative
McWilliams
thank you chervos I I want to say that
in principle I absolutely agree with you
and if we did not only meet from January
through June if we were meeting year
round we could absolutely respond to
federal guidelines but because we are
constrained as a legislature we only
have six months
we have to do the best we can with
foresight and be ready rather than
respond to federal guidelines 12 months
out of the year and so we're kind of
stuck in this pickle but I do understand
what you're saying and I think that in
principle it makes sense to respond to a
federal RFP with exact language we're
just not in a position to be able to do
that and so I don't want to miss out on
the opportunity because we don't meet
year-round thank you
thank you further comments
representative partial
yes my understanding of this bill is not
that it is actually appealing uh to an
RFP but it will enable the department of
enable us to do is do as much when we
know what the guidelines are as soon as
we know what the guidelines are
so it's not really so much
a program as much as it's enabling tool
and the step towards creating a program
am I reading this correctly
oh thank you
okay seeing none I would like to ask the
clerk
to call the role on the question of the
adoption of amendment 2-0
23-039h
Doug Thomas
no
Janine naughter no
David love no
Arnold Davis no
Carol Brown no
Lex barajny no JD Bernardi no Tom
blochet no
James Summers no
Rebecca McWilliams
yes
Jessica Grill yes
Carrie Speer yes
it was just partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes
Chris munz yes Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Gorman yes
Heath Howard yes
chairman Vose no
10 to 10.
so the motion to adopt Amendment
0309 H fails on a tied vote of 10 10. we
can assume that
the motion to pass the
original legislation unamended would
also fail
so we have two options here we can take
this bill to the house floor without
recommendation
or we could retain the bill
is there any appetite for retaining the
bill
there I'd move to retain the bill
representative McWilliams I'd move to
representative McWilliams moves retain
it's been moved and seconded
representative Corman seconded the
the motion so we have a motion on the
floor to retain this bill
is there any discussion of that motion
representative closure
uh thank you chair this question may be
to the chair
if this bill is retained when can we
next bring it up to discuss it again
it's good we can bring it up this fall
and discuss it it there is a deadline
that will be published in the calendar
it's roughly November
for reporting out of retained bills
if we reported it out uh at that time it
would go to the house floor in January
and then would proceed through the
process from from that point forward so
retaining the bill really probably
doesn't gain us much because we could
bring fresh legislation forward in the
fall
and it might be more appropriate
legislation because it might be Guided
by the guidance from the federal
government so retain actually doesn't
really buy us that much
representative munz which is the
question for the chair if we retain the
bill can we work on it over the summer
yes
thank you
further discussion on the motion to
retain this bill
representative Thomas Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair uh if this
bill is retained would we be
um able to direct other
committees to look at this bill or are
we relegated to just within this
committee
it would just be within our committee
and if we should retain the bill and
then move it forward in November when it
got to the house floor because it's an
FN bill it would still probably have to
go to the finance committee
representative McWilliams
I just want to make a pitch for
retaining because we are able to meet
discuss and potentially amend it before
it's reported out at the end of the year
I do think that we could receive some
very interesting Federal guidance uh say
September October we could meet together
and tweak it and then vote to send it as
amended in November to the house floor
so I think that there is a real
opportunity here to extend our session
instead of January to June and get that
November Golden Nugget if that's the way
things play out and I do think out of an
abundance of caution it behooves us to
be careful with our taxpayers money and
if it's 90 plus million dollars it's
worth hanging on to for a little bit
thank you
foreign
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of retain for
house bill 630.
Doug Thomas
no
Janine nodder no
David love no
Arnold Davis no
Carol Brown no
Lex barajny no
JD Bernardi no Tom closure no
James Summers no
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Jessica Grill yes
Carrie spear yes
lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes Henry Noel yes Wendy
Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes
Heath Howard yes chairman Vose
no
10 to 10.
so the motion to retain House Bill 630
fails on a vote of 10 to 10. therefore
this bill will have to be reported out
to the house clerk as without
recommendation
so we'll need a
calendar report for the side of ought to
pass
representative McWilliams will you
provide such a report I will thank you
and we'll also need a calendar report
for the motion of itl
representative closure will you provide
such a motion or such a report
uh yes I couldn't do that chair
okay excuse me I have a question to the
chair we're recognized for a question
is it possible or is there
um
a way to fast-track this bill along with
the other ones that
come up first in the house to be heard
that's up to the clerk and the speaker
okay they schedule thank you the
priority of bills on the calendar
representative Nutter
I had a question you just reminded me on
our first day here you had mentioned
that um we don't really deal in science
here it's most Just Energy and
Communications and you you had mentioned
that we should rename the committee if
we renamed the committee to energy and
Communications it would move us up in
that's an excellent point
I guess that's we'll have to take up
with the speaker
all right I guess we're down here I'm
going to close the public hearing on
I'm sorry I can't hear you do you have a
comment representative naughter I'm
sorry Mr chair just it wasn't a hearing
it was an exact session
oh did I say hearing okay exact session
so the exact session is closed for 6 30.
and now we'll open an access exact
session
on House Bill 234
and the chair will recognize
representative Summers for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I make the motion
to itl Bill 234 FN
chair recognizes representative
regini
I second that motion it's been moved and
seconded that we judge House Bill 234 to
be
foreign
representative McWilliams
thank you chair um I just want to
reiterate House Bill 234
was about wreck sweeping
our Focus here is really on creating a
long-term strategy for getting that
triple or sometimes quadruple value for
our single dollar so turning every
dollar invested into three or four
dollars worth of Smart Energy savings
and so uh ending Rex sweeping would
potentially help us long term get off of
our addiction to natural gas and
therefore reduce overall electric rates
in the big picture long term 10-year
strategy thank you
representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman uh to speak this
motion I I know for weeks we've been
talking and had presentations by ISO New
England the generators of New England
and multiple other parties including the
department of energy and such and all of
them have claimed about and we've all
had discussions about the the high
electrical rates that we're paying in
fact this morning even with the puc we
talked about the rate prices everybody
are paying everybody's paying for
electricity and this bill if passed
would increase the pay rate payers would
charge the ratepayers three million
dollars
three million dollars to transfer this
over for the ratepayers at this time I
do not feel it is right to be raising
the electrical rate so those people that
are out there and our rate payers and I
hope they're all watching right now and
so I vote to itl this
thank you further comment on this bill
representative muns
in in one of the bills that we um we
heard uh earlier today there was a lot
of discussion about
um you know taking of property
and how that was wrong and how that
shouldn't be allowed to continue and
um I think one aspect of this bill is
um just simply the the the the the the
fairness of
uh taking property away from people
without their knowledge
um and um
you know
um you know I think if nothing else
that's one reason why we should be
voting for this bill
representative Bernardi has a comment
so uh thank you uh Mr chair uh with
respect to
um taking a property if one does not
claim one's wrecks their abandoned
property we in the in this legislature
set a policy of allowing those wrecks to
be claimed for the benefit of passing
those those dollars back to through the
utilities to the rate payers to reduce
their costs that's what we need to do
representative Wendy Thomas has a
comment thank you Mr chair
um I question
um whether or not the property is
abandoned if to a if to claim it is an
onerous process which we saw um was
demonstrated
thank you
to provide a little history when the
renewable portfolio standard was
originally passed
wreck sweeping was added to the initial
legislation for the express purpose of
keeping costs as low as possible by
allowing the utilities to to
reclaim those abandoned wrecks they were
in enabled to reduce their costs and
those costs were passed directly onto
rate payers so that was the reason it
was passed originally in the first place
and it doesn't seem to me in this high
cost environment that now is a good time
to
take away
that protection for ratepayers by
increasing their costs
in addition to the increases they've
already experienced in the last year
representative Carmen has a comment
thank you Mr chair uh pursuant to what
you just said I'm wondering do you can
we ever see a time when it would make
sense to do this when when costs are
lower
well I can tell you that this wreck
sweeping repeal has a has come before
this legislature several times in the
eight plus years I've been here and it's
representative McWilliams
I just want to add on to the history of
um wreck Sweeping in the RPS when this
was first added a dollar one dollar was
taken from everybody's monthly bill and
applied to use for Energy Efficiency
programs
and things have changed since that was
enacted years ago and so one dollar is
still the amount that we are using for
Energy Efficiency and we refund the rest
of the money back to rate payers and and
I I really am sensitive to the fact that
we are in an energy Spike right now and
people are paying double what they've
been paying with their electric rates
and part of that is because
unfortunately we really haven't had a
long-term strategy to diversify our
portfolio mix and so we haven't had a
way of addressing that low-hanging fruit
the Energy Efficiency weatherization
programs we really haven't funded them
to the extent that other states around
us have and therefore we are hurting for
that and we have people who are hurting
paying to still heat the outdoors
because they need more insulation in
their homes they can't access funds to
do that right now we are in a pretty
pickle and I really feel for my
constituents who are hurting and not
able to pay their electric bills right
now but doing this is part of a longer
strategy to make sure that we do have
money and we can diversify fire Energy
Mix because that's what we need is we
need to stand up and be proud that we
are New Hampshire and we have a strategy
to get out of this problem and so yes we
do need to do something in order to
change what we've been doing because
what we've been doing isn't working
thank you
thank you representative McWilliams you
have conflated Reggie rebates and wreck
further comments on this uh
legislation
okay seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the role on the question of itl for
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine nodder yes
David love yes
Arnold Davis yes
Carol Brown yes
Lex brezhny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom
blochet yes
James Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams
no
Jessica Grill no
Carrie Speer no
Lucius partial no
Tony Kaplan no
Chris muns no Henry Noel
no Wendy Thomas no Thomas Corman no
Heath Howard no chairman Bose yes
10 10.
so by a vote of 10 to 10 the motion to
itl House Bill 234 fails
and the chair is certain that a motion
to pass HB 234 would also fail
send this bill to the floor without
recommendation the other is to retain
the bill I see no use in retaining the
bill
so I am going to rule that this bill
will go forward to the floor without
recommendation
so I ask
representative McWilliams to appoint
someone to write the
calendar report for the position of
ought to pass
I'm sorry I didn't hear what you said
and I need that report by noon on
Monday can you designate someone now or
do you need to wait
I will let you know by 5 30.
okay
and I will designate representative
Summers to write the report
for the position of itl will do
and I need that by noon on Monday please
and with that we'll close the exact
now we'll open an exec session on House
Bill 246 the chair recognizes
representative nodder
thank you Mr chairman I move ought to
pass
bear recognizes representative Bernardi
uh second the motion
chair recognizes representative naughter
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
offer an amendment I'll pass it out
this amendment
um if you didn't like the bill The Way
It Was Written this makes it temporary
and also restores the sections that were
repealed so um administrative race
support would no longer be an issue if
we pass this amendment so it makes it
better
if you don't like the bill you know this
representative Nutter moves ought to
pass
and offers Amendment
2023-0288h
do we have discussion on this amendment
I'll give you a a minute or two to read
I have read it and I can tell you that
what this Amendment essentially does is
it
makes the rebate program identified by
the bill
last from July 1st of 2023 through June
30th of 2025.
a two-year period
it also
restores language to the bill that was
removed from the original version of the
bill
that allows all of the
administrative costs to be extracted as
before and other uses of the fund Monies
to be kept intact rather than deleted
from
statute
so those are the changes that the
that the amendment makes
and I think this is a a much more
defendable Amendment and a much more
defendable makes the bill much more
defendable bill
anybody else have comments
representative Thomas Doug Thomas has a
comment thank you Mr chair uh I I concur
I I think this amendment uh makes this a
better Bill particularly during these
rough times that we do want to show our
people that we are trying in some way
any way we can to help them in the short
term to help them during this period of
of high rates and it gives us the
opportunity to go back to where we were
when perhaps times are a little better I
think this amendment should be adopted
representative munz has a comment I I
have a question
um there's there's new language or looks
like new language that wasn't in the
original Bill starting at line 25
um authorizing the um puc to open up a
docket
could
um Somebody explain that yes you are
correct about that I forgot to mention
that so lines 25 through 29
request that the Public Utilities
Commission opened a docket
within 60 days after the effective date
of the ACT to determine just exactly how
the the renewable energy fund dollars
seven or eight million dollars
uh would be distributed to rate payers
chances are they would apply
a rate adjustment to the
uh
to the rate that the utilities charge
their customers
the language here further
requires that the POC complete that
docket
within 60 days after it is opened
further discussion to representative
Wendy Thomas thank you Mr chair um just
as a point of disclosure I was advised I
need to let you know that I work for a
you do work for it or you did work for
the lawyer said that I could still vote
I just needed to disclose it
okay I'll accept your lawyer's word for
that um it's not my lawyer it's the
state lawyer oh the state lawyer okay
I'll accept the lawyers uh thank you uh
judgment on that
representative Kaplan has a comment yeah
I don't work for New Hampshire saves but
I I still think this uh
this amendment would have the effect of
gutting you know the renewable energy
fund and therefore it would hurt the New
Hampshire Safe program and when you when
you're feeling cold you don't burn the
representative not her has a comment yes
thank you but
um the unamended version is permanent
that would be an argument for
uh adopting the amendment
further comment representative muns
sorry just another another question
regarding that that language about the
the docket
um I'm I'm sure the intent was that it
would only apply to the two-year period
where the rates are being rebated but
what language uh causes you concern well
the fact that you know it it talks about
how monies in the renewable energy fund
under RSA 362 f8 as amended will be
distributed to Tech to rate payers it
doesn't say anything about the temporary
but the amendment the key language here
is as amended by this act
the amended language specifies a
two-year period if I'm if everybody else
is fine with that I'm I'm fine okay
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of adopting the
amendment
2023-0288 H to HB 246.
Doug Thomas
yes Janine naughter yes
David love yes
Arnold Davis yes
Carol Brown yes Lex barajny
JD Bernardi yes Tom blochet yes James
Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams
no
Jessica Grill
yes
Carrie Speer
no
lucious partial no
Tony Kaplan no
Chris muns
yes
Henry Noel
Wendy Thomas
yes
Thomas Corman yes
Heath Howard
yes
chairman Rose
sixteen four
so by a vote of 16 to 4 the amendment
zero two eight eight H is adopted
that brings us to the question of ought
to pass as amended is there any further
seeing none I asked the clerk to call
the roll on the question of the adoption
of HB 246 as amended by
uh representative Nutter did you have a
comment a clarification on the motion I
believe the motion is ought to pass as
amended right right is it
what you said you need to move in second
isn't that isn't that what I said I'm
not sure that's what I'm clarifying you
originally moved you originally moved
ought to pass yes
yes then we adopted the amendment so the
new motion is ought to pass as amended
yes
thank you okay
representative Thomas
Doug Thomas I move auto pass as as
amended
the way the clerk explained it to me is
if you move ought to pass and then you
amend it the ought to pass emotion is on
the floor after the amendment is adopted
you still you still need to have the
so
Dr Thomas okay moved it
now now the clerk is telling me that his
form requires a an official motion so
I move on to pass as a minute
representative notter second
okay now it's been moved and seconded
that we vote ought to pass is amended by
Amendment 028h
seeing not ask the clerk to call the
role of the question about to pass this
amendment amended on HB 246
FN as amended by zero two eight eight h
Doug Thomas
yes Janine naughter yes David love yes
Arnold Davis yes Carol Brown yes Lex
barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom blochet
yes James Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams no
Jessica Grill no
Carrie spear no
lucious partial no
Tony Kaplan no
Chris muns no
Henry Noel
no you
know Wendy Thomas no
Thomas Carmen no
Heath Howard no
chairman Bose
yes
10 10.
so the motion to ought to pass
House Bill 246 is amended by zero two
eight eight H fails for the vote of 10
to 10. and
a vote of itl would also fail in the
Judgment of the chair so we will send
this bill to the house floor
without recommendation
and the motion on the floor for ought to
pass as amended
will be the prevailing motion
and representative notter will write the
committee the calendar report for that
motion the other motion will be itl and
that motion will be representative
McWilliams responsibility months
so representative Munns have that to us
by noon on Monday please
with that we'll close the executive
session on House Bill 246.
now our next task is to continue two
executive sessions that we recessed back
on
the 30th of
January which is just this past Monday
so I'm going to reopen the
executive session on House Bill 418 FN
relative to eliminating the rebates
distributed by the Energy Efficiency
fund
and I will recognize representative
I wasn't paying attention I'm sorry and
I don't even know what the bill is but
my papers I'll spill 418 relative to
eliminating the rebates distributed by
the Energy Efficiency fund
thank you
I'm sorry Mr chairman my let's add my
representative Summers is recognized my
second emotion so it's been moved and
seconded that we itl house bill
418fn is there any discussion
I have my mind just I I don't have
anything to say right now I'm sorry okay
to refresh everyone's uh memory this is
a bill that
removes the existing rebates of Reggie
money we'll add about 40 million dollars
to ratepayers costs in a time of
extremely high energy rates extremely
high inflation
it will be a slap in the face to the
citizens of New Hampshire
and I certainly could not support doing
that so I will be voting to
yes to itl House Bill 418 representative
notter
thank you Mr chairman you've refreshed
my memory so everything you just said
ditto
additional comments representative
McWilliams
thank you chair Bose I think I jumped
the gun on the previous Bill my comments
about the first dollar for Reggie were
for this bill and my concerns are the
same for both bills in terms of it being
an energy spike in constituents having a
really tough time paying bills I feel
that also I have concerns for the long
term that we need to get off of our
addiction to Natural Gas diversify our
energy Supply and fund Energy Efficiency
weatherization projects to make sure
that our buildings are actually
retaining heat in the winter and so for
that reason this is part of a 10-year
strategy to reduce costs overall as
opposed to Distributing pennies back to
our ratepayers thank you
additional comments
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair I'd like to disclose that I work
for a company that has a contract with
nhsas
thank you representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman I'd just like to
add that uh earlier in HB 234fn I
mentioned that our rate payers will be
paying 3 million extra dollars on their
rates this as has been mentioned will
increase it to where they'll be paying
40 million dollars more on their rates I
additional comments representative muns
thank you Mr chair I'd just like to put
that number into context I mean we heard
con we heard uh testimony from the
Department of energy that
um the impact on the average rate rate
payer would be 1.77 a month or 28
dollars a year or 21 a year
not insignificant but um I think
um
the people of New Hampshire are smart
enough to realize that we do need to get
off of our addiction to natural gas and
an investment of 1.77 a month is is a
small investment to make that to make to
make to help make that happen thank you
foreign
wonders if it's wise to move away from
natural gas if we have nothing
Dependable to
replace it with
further comments Mr chairman
representative muns one of the reasons
we don't have anything to turn to turn
to is because we haven't been making the
Investments that we need to be for the
representative Bernardi
so representative Munns I I don't
understand what you want to replace uh
natural gas with what we really need to
do is reduce the price of natural gas in
the United States and get it here
to have uh
solar and wind as a only additional new
source of power both of them are
unreliable even in the ISO
New England presentation page 17 their
footnotes indicate that if we had
extensive Reliance on that kind of power
we would need to have backup power that
was reliable we don't we cannot rely on
and put all our eggs in Renewables as a
way to as a way to Supply Power for the
future we need a reliable source
representative Nutter has a comment
thank you Mr chairman
um this bill is a tax a cap and trade
scheme now if to add on to what
representative Bernardi just said about
replacing
um our reliable sources of energy with
solar uh this is what what it would what
it would mean replacing four
conventional power plants would
necessitate a wind farm the size of
Rhode Island to replace all conventional
power plants require land larger than
the state of California
this is um from an energy conference I
went to there's tens of thousands of
scientists that you never get to hear
about but they back this up solar panels
create three times more toxic waste per
unit of energy produced than nuclear
power plant doubling the output of
carbon dioxide wouldn't do much it's
very little however eliminating carbon
dioxide would have a minuscule effect to
to this was the if you remember from the
hearing I had asked Mr Fitzgerald what
that number was it's
0.002 percent
representative Corman has a comment
thank you Mr chair just to respond to
representative Bernardi's comment I
agree that we need reliable sources you
know I I don't I don't see any way to
dispute that but I would point out that
during the times that we are availing
ourselves of energy from solar or wind
or whatever else that means that that's
that much less natural gas that we need
to use and it's a way that we can reduce
representative Bernardi
so I I agree when when the sun is
shining and when the wind is blowing
appropriately one can reduce some of the
power needs right now the sun is not
shining the wind is blowing so hard the
windmills won't work
so we have nothing reliable in the
renewable Corridor to fill that Gap yet
we need power so we have to have
something we can turn on and use and
that in in this Arena right now the best
that we the best that we have is nuclear
and natural gas
representative Wendy Thomas did you have
a comment I did um thank you I remember
uh in one of the early sessions you said
that you didn't want opinions you wanted
everything backed up with references
um in in light of that I would like uh
representative Nadder to share the name
of the conference that she attended and
to provide the documents that she's
referring to for this this
data that she's probably to be precise
what I said was we don't want opinions
in public hearings in executive session
it's perfectly fine to offer opinions
although it's also perfectly fine to ask
members how they arrived at their
opinion I would like to ask how so I
will allow the question thank you very
much Mr chair
the answer
Dr holder thus from Germany
and our chairman was at this conference
with me it was several I brought home a
stack of books the name of the
conference please I don't remember the
name of the conference
representative Kaplan has a question
we're hearing all kinds of opinions here
about the windmills not working and
about this that and the other I mean
these are just unfounded opinions and
that may be fine in an executive session
but the fact is
that everywhere in the world
the biggest market gains in the energy
sector are being made by solar and wind
and that the intermittent issue is being
taken care of with the battery
technologies that are improving all the
time now we might not be able to
implement those right away in New
Hampshire but we can certainly start
planning to diversify our Energy Mix and
that's why we're as representative
McWilliam said that's why we're in the
pickle that we're in is because we
haven't been doing that
and we need to start doing it and that
that's what this this bill is all about
is we need to start moving quicker
towards the Diversified Energy Mix
representative Doug Thomas has a comment
thank you Mr chair I just want to um
comment that regarding natural gas
my my district Londonderry has the
natural gas plant which is the second
largest producer of energy in this state
and uh I do the calculation on what
would we need to replace that plant if
we did with solar cells solar panels and
it would cover uh over half
the the area of my town alone so you
know we we need both
we need to do both we need to keep
natural gas as well and uh any
presumptions that we need to get rid of
natural gas I think is perhaps farther
than I can see in my lifetime right now
because of the fact of being unreliable
in in the other so we need the Baseline
we need the Baseline plants we need the
net the renewable plants we cannot just
dismiss natural gas right now we're
trying to get the price down when we do
it will be cheaper but there are a lot
of factors involving the price of
natural gas now and they're not all
I would remind members that in
2019 or possibly 2020 one or the other
a bill identical to this one passed both
houses of the general court and was
vetoed by the governor and his veto was
sustained
any further representative Corman has a
comment
thank you Mr chair so um I actually
agree with what representative Bernardi
said I agree with what representative
Doug Thomas said I I am not saying that
we should have zero natural gas what
what I believe is that we want to reduce
our natural gas and that if we reduce
our demand of natural gas when demand
goes down price goes down
so you know I see incorporating
renewable sources as not only good for
the environment but actually good
economically in terms of getting the
demand for natural gas down and yes we
absolutely need reliable sources I I
agree and during those times that the
wind is blowing so hard that the
windmills won't work or the sun isn't
shining yeah we need we need the other
sources but during the times that the
wind is friendly and and when the sun is
is friendly let's Avail ourselves of
that
representative munz has another comment
um I also agree with representative Doug
Thomas I mean we do need both no no
question about it
um this bill will allow us
to
develop the alternative that we don't
and I also agree we need both
but I will point out that everywhere
it's been tried whether you're talking
about California
Massachusetts
Germany the UK Spain
renewable energy from wind and solar has
proven to be more expensive has raised
costs for electricity rate fares
and
in the absence of affordable and
Deployable and scalable batteries
renewable energy just isn't going to get
us there
and raising people's
New Hampshire constituents electricity
bills in a feudal attempt to get to a
result that's not achievable
is not something that my constituents
any further discussion on this issue
yes representative spear a question is
was I allowed to ask a question yes
uh I've seen the numbers that you're
talking about and one of the things that
they that I have read in the news and in
other articles that I've read on energy
is that those numbers are going to come
way down when those developments have
been completed when the payoff on those
developments have been completed they
chose to spend the money up front get
the development done and then after that
it'll spread out so to say that it's
going to cost that amount of money
forever is not really what they're
predicting they're predicting the cost
are going to come down
I was driving across the United States
over the past year and I saw a
staggering amount of farms with
windmills in them so I looked up some of
the numbers States like Nebraska is 70
powered by wind
Vermont is staggeringly I don't have the
exact numbers for the month but they're
more using uh
what is it solar but we have windmills
up in the older windmills up in the
northern part of the state where the
wind is very high and we just sell that
power off to Vermont we sell that power
off to Maine
we don't seem to have a very good plan
at all to catch up with anybody or to
use the energy that we do generate
that's my comment
we sell that
wind power to our neighboring states
because we don't have transmission
capability to bring it down here to New
Hampshire
so that's why we sell it but thank you
representative uh Carol Brown
um thank you Mr chair for letting me I
promised I wasn't going to say anything
to the assistant chair
running for this office there were two
things that people talk to me about the
first one was abortion
and the second one was the price of
their energy in their home
whatever we do here at the state
we should not be making our our citizens
rates go up for any reason they're
already too high and the second thing is
if we have any kind of rolling blackouts
in this state and the legislature is
responsible for that is completely
unacceptable that we don't have an
adequate supply of energy here
so and to follow up on representative
Bernardi I did some homework on this
while I was running
there's a wind farm in Alexandria and
Groton
um 25 uh 25 turbines I believe I talked
to um the coastal wind representative
from Department of energy whose Name
Escapes me
um and I I made some calls to ISO
the capacity factor for those windmills
is about 25 percent if I I'm doing this
through memory
that if you use those exact windmills to
replace Schiller station or Newington
station you need about 650 of them and
that doesn't guarantee you power 24 7.
we cannot I I this is one of the reasons
I ran
for the legislator is the cause of
energy we cannot as legislators allow
the citizens of this state not to have
this uh representative McWilliams
I just wanted to say that we're in a
unique position and we've got some
really exciting technology right where
the science technology and energy
committee got some really exciting
technology coming with EV batteries to
be able to go back into the Grid at
periods when the sun isn't shining or
the wind isn't blowing so it becomes
sort of its own little micro grid for
everyone who has an EV and they're
plugging into the grid so this is coming
it's becoming normalized I know we had a
pilot at UNH and the co-op is currently
working to make this part of their
energy mix I expect that this will
become mainstream in the next couple of
years so I look forward to continuing
this conversation with the members of
stne as this evolves because I do think
it's a very current subject and it's
it's worth chatting about and I
appreciate everybody being passionate
about it so thank you all
thank you well said uh representative
McWilliams
so in an effort to get us out of here by
six o'clock I'm going to call the vote
on House Bill 418 the motion on the
floor is itl and I uh asked the clerk to
call the role on that question
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine nodder yes David love yes Arnold
Davis yes
Carol Brown yes Lex barajny yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom pelager yes James
Summers
yes
Rebecca McWilliams no
Jessica Grill no
Carrie spear no
lucious partial no Tony Kaplan no
Chris muns no
Henry Noel
no
Wendy Thomas no
Thomas Gorman no
Heath Howard no
chairman Vose yes 10 10.
so by a vote of 10 to 10 the motion to
itl House Bill 418 fails the chair
as uh makes the Judgment that an ought
to pass motion will also fail
so this bill will go to the house floor
without recommendation the prevailing
motion on the floor will be
ought to pass representative McWilliams
will you appoint someone to write the
calendar report for that position
absolutely
I'll let you know
and representative notter will write the
itl position calendar report
and then we will be done so I'm going to
close the executive session on House
Bill 418.
that leaves us with one task
I'll open an executive session on House
Bill 92 and recognize representative
Doug Thomas
thank you Mr chair I move itl on hb92
I'll speak to my motion right after the
second
representative nodder I second the
motion it's been moved and seconded that
we passed judgment on hb92 as itl
representative Thomas
thank you Mr chair uh Doug Thomas that
is
this bill has come before us before and
for the same reasons I do itl the
reasons are basically written right into
the bill uh this bill
mandates things that go against the free
market
it eventually would require the state to
not sell any gas powered light duty
Vehicles meaning cars it it the it
places a a hefty fine on manufacturers
that don't meet the standards and the
real uh thing that troubles me is that
if New Hampshire were to adopt this bill
we would be adopting California
standards and any amendments that they
make
afterwards we would be beholding to
whatever California was to do on their
standards which uh this is not the New
Hampshire way so these are all
Troublesome to me it's an affront on the
free market uh I believe that uh yeah I
I know the intent is well the intent is
to you know have more low emission
vehicles and low emission vehicles to be
sold in the state but I think the free
market should should dictate that and so
therefore for all those reasons and more
uh we should I tell itl this bill
further comment on hb92 representative
notter thank you just a reminder that
Des testified that they can't meet the
date they just don't have enough time to
put in rule making
another thing to consider
further comments on this bill
representative Summers
thank you Mr chair I did a ton of
research on this going everything from
lithium mining into the down in the
South America where 97 96 percent of all
lithium is refined in China so basically
we all used to complain everybody's
complaining about dealing with OPEC and
getting our oil from the Middle East so
instead we're going to turn and we're
going to get all of our lithium from
China
so then so we're depending 100 almost
100 on China then I actually looked at
the
the amount of pollution that comes from
mining lithium and where you think
there's a huge drastic difference
between the electrical I mean the CO2
emissions between the lithium electrical
vehicle and the gas powered car
just to build one Lithium powered
battery powered electric car is 17
megatons a CO2 was created for one car
where a gas-powered car is around
1.8 of that okay now over time the gas
the gas power
combustible engine runs it does it does
surpass the amount of CO2 come out the
electric car over a period of time but
the amount of what's taken to strip mine
lithium which is why lithium is not
allowed to be mined in North America
anymore and passed by President Biden to
where it's actually not only not allowed
in North America but we're only allowed
to actually receive lithium from select
countries because the bad practices not
only of lithium but of the child Mining
and child um
production of cobalt in central Africa
then when I look at the California code
of regulations which is the what we
would be adopting
I know everybody talks about how it goes
to 35 percent which means all vehicles
on a car lot would be 35 percent had to
be electrical by the year 2026 if we
adopted this though by the end of next
year what they leave out is is the
current number is 25 percent that means
25 percent of all electrical vehicles at
every dealership across New Hampshire
would have to be electrical now at the
average price of sixty two thousand
dollars per electric vehicle
if you had how many dealerships could
actually afford to make 25 of their
dealership lot in all electrical at the
average price of sixty two thousand
dollars per car that's just some of the
things in this we could go in a lot
deeper but that's just what I've got
right now thank you
further comment on this legislation
representative naughter we can add to
that a lithium
electric vehicle battery weighs a
thousand pounds can take typically
contains 25 pounds of lithium 30 pounds
of Cobalt 60 pounds of nickel 110 pounds
of graphite 90 pounds of copper 400
pounds of steel aluminum and Plastics
extraction from Earth and processing
takes a lot to make one battery he went
over all of that
inner Mongolia has the most of the
world's Rare Earth oars they pump acid
into the ground the acid there's more
chemicals that are used for the
processing one ton of rare earth metals
releases up to 420 000 cubic feet of
toxic gases 2 600 cubic feet of acidic
Wastewater and a ton of radioactive
waste they are using children like you
said and other people and they're
suffering from skin and respiratory
diseases I mean we could spend a very
long time going over all of this it
sounds so Rosy but it really it's not
there's there's a lot to it
that isn't good
thank you representative Bernardi has a
comment
just thank you Mr chairman uh so to
quote the source uh Federal testimony
observed uh in the in a hearing on this
issue uh in in Congress uh the all the
mining activities that you heard about
lithium Cobalt and whatnot
six times the amount of mining needing
to be done
strip mining as compared to making a
standard car
a huge environmental impact
not done here so therefore it's okay
supposedly I don't think so
representative McWilliams
thank you chair Vos I would like to
commend all of my colleagues for your
research on the environmental impacts of
batteries and the rare earth minerals
required to do batteries I do want to
call your attention that this bill also
enables hydrogen vehicles and other
Innovative Vehicles not just EVS that
run on batteries but really to get to
the Crux of the discussion in the
argument is we heard testimony and I
certainly presented testimony that all
of the major automobile manufacturers
are going to electric vehicles either by
2030 or 2040 so it's happening this is
the direction of the future we're not
suddenly going to change their minds or
change their business practices here in
New Hampshire by saying uh well you know
we just disagree we'd like to stick with
our combustion engines here in New
Hampshire as long as we possibly can
it's the way the future of the industry
is going and so therefore we should be
able to enable that and allow dealer
Lots in New Hampshire to have these
vehicles instead of prioritizing all the
other states in the Northeast besides
New Hampshire we're the donut hole to
receive zebs and loves zero missions and
low emissions Vehicles because that is
what is happening with the future now we
did hear from uh the automotive Dealers
Association that it is possible to get a
Zev or Lev in New Hampshire uh you
you're going to have long lead times
you're going to wait a while it could be
six to nine months maybe longer but it
is possible but you know the reality is
that's not the way people tend to
purchase vehicles in New Hampshire they
tend to say you know I think I want to
get a new car I'm going to go test drive
a couple vehicles and I'm going to buy
something pretty soon they may not wait
nine months or longer and so what what
this bill attempted to do and I do have
a amendment to it but but the underlying
goal of this bill was to do was to get
purchasers in New Hampshire the ability
to buy their zebs and levs off of New
Hampshire Lots in the normal manner that
people purchase cars in New Hampshire
but I do have an amendment working with
the automotive Dealers Association to do
a commission to look at Alternatives
because I do hear my colleagues concerns
about being tied to California
amendments I think that that's a fair
point and so if we could come up with a
way to enable the transition to electric
vehicles because that's really what's
happening with the industry then I think
we can come up with some really
innovative solutions for New Hampshire
rather than tying ourselves to somewhere
else or something else this is the
fourth time this committee has heard
this bill and I think that there's
something here it's worth working out
and so for that reason I would ask for
you to consider the amendment once this
vote goes along party lines thank you
representative Doug Thomas has a comment
thank you Mr chair
um I I appreciate uh the the the the the
efforts uh to to get something here for
EVS but again I have to stress in the
past you know when we were doing buggies
and horses and the uh and the car came
along it was the free market that
demanded that we build the
infrastructure and have cars built and
so forth and and better and it was the
free market that determined where we are
today
we should rely on the free market if
people want to buy an electric vehicle
they will and they have but I want to
stress that some of the comments made
here are
in some ways built on some conjecture
because we we say that it's going to
happen we know it's going to happen no
one knows what's going to happen in the
future I mean in a few years a
technology could change something could
come up the the priorities might be
diverted I know manufacturers are
looking towards what they're doing by
then and perhaps by then if that's what
they're doing and that's what they're
producing well that's the free market if
they feel they can sell it they'll be
able to sell it so I do believe that
we're that in some cases we might be
operating on information that we're only
assuming is going to happen in the
future that's kind of like conjunction
so I think we should be very cautious
and that not to
bind ourselves to any mandates that will
affect our citizens here I believe in
the free market I believe that the
people here will decide what dictates we
have not a government mandate that ties
us to a to a a place that's the opposite
side of this country thank you
representative Bernardi has a comment
s thank you Mr chairman uh building on
what uh
representative Doug Thomas said I think
many folks may remember when Coca-Cola
launched New Coke it was going to it was
going to be the new Coke it was going to
be the coke that took off and everybody
liked
the market said no we don't like it
bring back the original
it doesn't matter if GM and Ford and
whoever say we are just going to produce
EVS if they can't sell them because the
market says
I want my combustion-based vehicle then
they're going to change their mind the
market will drive what gets produced
ultimately
representative Nutter has a comment
so during the hearing we could only ask
questions and not make comments so I had
written this down
um all right my husband just got a
bronco it's not an electric vehicle he
ordered it in February he got it in
October I recently traded in my car and
I was actually very lucky that they had
something on the lot they told me that
they some typically they don't even have
anything on the lot you have to wait
wait until they get some in they'll get
12 cars in they sell seven right away
but I'm very blessed and very happy that
I was able to trade in my race car for
something that's more reasonable
you had a race car
wow
representative Summers says Aquaman just
a quick add-on to um I mean I'm and I
I've actually heard positive things
about hydrogen cars as they would come
along
um my worry mostly like I was talking
about was lithium Cobalt and such and um
where my concern right now and it's more
of a New Hampshire thing is that our
fire departments can't even deal right
now with even a lithium battery I mean
with a lithium car fire
um I believe there was a wreck just a
week 10 days ago I believe took 32 000
gallons of water to put out one battery
we don't have the foam to put out
lithium batteries or because you have to
cool them down they they burn from the
inside so you have to cool them down to
put the actually put the fire out so
that's one thing I'm worried about the
lithium is that and then also it's just
uh as we know and many of you might have
heard on the news today that in a small
school up in Littleton today little to
New Hampshire there was three classrooms
that were burned all fire was all
started by a lithium laptop battery well
representative love did you have a
comment yes I do thank you Mr chair I
want to thank everybody here for all the
comments on all these bills it's been
very interesting and uh been nice being
a part of it
um you know the the bottom line on all
those green technology and green
legislation and stuff is let's clean up
the environment but at what cost
um you know we we can't dictate what
China does you know you heard about the
mining and the mess that it's making of
the environment over there that that
that stuff comes into the air and gets
blown this way we can't dictate that
so if we're not going to be able to
dictate to one of the major polluters in
this world
um what is little New Hampshire going to
do why are we going to burden our people
with excess excess electricity cost uh
heating costs uh Transportation costs uh
it
um that's something something I'm not
going to do to my constituents and that
is doing something to them
not for them we're doing something to
them you know little New Hampshire isn't
going to do anything to stop China or
India from polluting and until we can
get a hold of that
thank you it being 10 minutes of six I
don't think uh anybody's Gonna Change
anybody else's Mind by discussing this
further
so I'd like to ask the clerk to call the
role on the question of itl for house
yes
Janine naughter yes David love
Arnold Davis yes Carol Brown yes Lex
barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom pleasure
yes James Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams
no
Jessica Grill no
Gary spear no lucious partial no Tony
captain no
Chris muns no Henry Noel
no Wendy Thomas no Thomas Corman no
yes I'm sure 10 10.
no
no she said no she followed
all right by a vote of 10 to 10 the
motion to itl fails
the chair rules that emotion to uh to
pass would also fails so this bill will
go to
the floor without recommendation
representative McWilliams
I'd like to make a motion to adopt an
the amendment would require an ought to
pass motion I don't think that
that motion would be
um appropriate so I don't think we need
to consider an amendment on this bill I
think we need to send it to the house
floor without recommendation
with a report from
you representative McWilliams or or
someone that you designate
for the ought to pass motion and
our side will
send a calendar report for the itl
motion
I would challenge the chairs ruling on
that I I believe we should be allowed to
make an amendment an OTP with Amendment
motion if none of the other motions have
carried
okay the representative McWilliams has
challenged the rule of the chair on the
question of whether there should be a
motion of ought to pass
the only way to resolve a challenge to
the chair is to ask for a vote of the
committee
so I asked the clerk to call the role on
the question of
the challenge to the chair
on the question of
point of order ruling not to accept
emotion of to pass
point of order point of order what is
your point of order point of inquiry
would it it would it be appropriate or
or is it possible to at least describe
the amendment before we go any further
well we have a challenge on the floor we
have to resolve that first but the
challenge is based on on people not
understanding what the amendment is that
okay representative McWilliams tell us
what the amendment is
thank you chavos
um this amendment is really
straightforward and simple
it's a commission
with five members of the House of
Representatives one member of the Senate
the commissioner of the Department of
Environmental Services or designee
commissioner of the Department of energy
or designee Commissioner of Department
of Health and Human Services or designee
member of the northeast states for
coordinated air use management appointed
by the executive director of that
organization a member of the New
Hampshire Automotive Dealers Association
appointed by that Association and a
member of the automotive manufacturer
Association appointed by that
Association charged with coming up with
a way to study uh Innovative vehicle
emission standards and electric vehicles
in New Hampshire
that's the commission
okay thank you for that description
so the speaker of the house and the
president of the Senate have both
communicated to members of their
respective caucuses
that they discourage the
passage of bills to create committees
and commissions
in the most in the strongest of possible
terms
the reason for that is we already have
some 400 committees and commissions and
both the speaker and the
Senate President struggled to find
members to appoint to all these
committees and commissions
so I have ruled that this amendment
isn't worth taking up because of
instructions I've received from house
leadership that we want to discourage
the creation of committees and
commissions
that does not leave unresolved the
matter on the floor which is the
challenge to the ruling of the chair
so I'll ask the clerk to call the roll
on the question
representative Thomas I think you're for
uh uh it might be a point of order uh
just for clarification uh what's the
most what are we what is the motion that
we are voting on uh whether we do or do
not agree with the challenge to the
chair how how are you freezing the
motion
if we vote Yes what does that mean or if
we if we vote no what does that mean
so representative McWilliams challenged
my ruling that we're not going to
consider this amendment
if you vote
yes then you accept her Challenge and
and say yes we want to overrule the the
rule of the chair
if you vote no then you let the rule of
the chair stand
is everybody clear on that
a yes vote overrules the rule of the
chair and means we'll sit here for
another half hour debating this
amendment
if you vote no then that the ruling of
the chair will stand and what we we will
not go forward with this amendment
so I asked the clerk to call the role on
the question of the
challenge to the rule of the chair
Doug Thomas
no Janine nodder no
David love no
Arnold Davis no Carol Brown no Lex
barajny no JD Bernardi no Tom closure no
James Summers no Rebecca Williams yes
Jessica Grill yes
Gary spear yes lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns yes Henry
Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes Howard Heath yes
chairman Bose no
10 10. so the motion fails by a vote of
10 to 10. so the ruling of the chair
stands that we will not consider the
emotion the amendment
and that the house bill 92 will go to
the house floor without recommendation
and the motion on the floor will be
ought to pass representative McWilliams
will designate a member to write the
report for that position
and representative
Thomas Doug Thomas that is will write
the report for the position of itl
and with that we will close the
executive session on House Bill 92
And We Made It by six o'clock to uh to
close the executive session I should say
on House Bill 92. and so we're out of
here at six o'clock we're back here on
Monday bright and early at nine o'clock
to start this process all over again I
thank you all for your hard work and
have a nice weekend
be